Hi, everyone, and welcome back to That UFO Podcast. As always, my name is Andy, and this is the ever-popular Omnibus show for you. And this is a very special one. It's a Skinwalker Ranch Omnibus, Part 1. Now, for me, this was a bit of an interesting one to listen back to, and I did listen back to more of this, and I probably ever have of some of the other Omnibus shows. It takes me through the history of the podcast from June 2020, when it was one month old, through to 2023, 2024. So, Part 1 covers one of my very first interviews, which was with Thomas Winterton, Superintendent of the Ranch, and that was nearly two hours long, and I'll give you a quick story ahead of that if you want to hear it. You're going to hear it, I'm going to tell you. I remember the night before that I'd recorded with Nick Pope, and it was an awful interview, and that was nothing against Nick Pope, and purely down to the fact that the recording was terrible, the connection was terrible, I couldn't really hear him, and I was really hoping at that time using Skype and being quite new to recording podcasts, it would turn out okay, and it didn't. And genuinely, after that recording with Nick Pope, I was tempted to quit the podcast and stop it altogether. No hyperbole there. Genuinely, I was so annoyed at how the recording had turned out, thinking that was a big guest and I'd ruined it. Needless to say, I got back in the saddle the next night and had a two-hour interview with Thomas Winterton I really, really enjoyed and I think a lot of other folks did as well. By that point, I'd done about 11, 12 shows, something like that and it was my eighth interview and folks really enjoyed it. From there, I managed to speak to Dragon, Brian Arnold, who is the security on the ranch, currently on a bit of a hat, sabbatical, one of his sons wasn't too well and hopefully he's a lot better now. I then had Travis Taylor on the podcast and Brandon Fugal multiple times. All of those feature in this first part. Also, on the Thomas Winterton show, if you think my audio sounds like I'm on a bit of an old school radio, I made a proper rookie mistake back in the early days of the podcast. What I'd done was, I had a really good microphone from the get-go. But for about the first seven interviews or eight interviews, if you listen to me in the very first shows, you'll hear my audio doesn't sound great and that's because I plugged the microphone into the laptop but I hadn't connected the actual microphone to be on the settings, the microphone to work and I was still using the laptop audio. You then notice afterwards, all of a sudden the audio improves when I realized what I was doing wrong. It's absolutely fine to listen to and it's only that first interview, it just sounds a little bit old school radio from my side. Thomas Winterton does most of the talking. This is part 1 of the Skinwalker Ranch Omnibus and I hope you enjoy. Part 2 includes interviews again with Brandon Fugal, Eric Bard, Ben Woodruff and Jim Sagala. Sit back, enjoy the Omnibus and I'll speak to you all soon. So welcome back, everyone, to episode 8 of That UFO Podcast. And as I announced a few weeks ago, tonight's guest, I'm very excited to speak to one of the cast, one of the stars of The Curse of Skinwalker Ranch, or The Secret of Skinwalker Ranch, if you're in the USA. It's The Curse of Skinwalker Ranch in the UK. We have Thomas Winterton, Superintendent of the Ranch. Thomas, how are you?
I'm great. Yeah, thanks for having me on.
No, it's an absolute pleasure. Someone that's straight away got a lot of interest in, and a lot of people send in over questions, which I've got to read out later on in the show. You've become a bit of a celebrity in the last year, at least, with the History Channel show taking off. How has that been? Has it been a bit of a weird experience, or are you used to it now? Yeah.
You know what? It's been a little bit of a rollercoaster, simply because I'm a businessman by trade. I own a couple of the businesses. I live in a very small town. I live 15 minutes from the ranch, so as the viewers can see, we live in a very remote part of Utah, more cows than people. This newfound, I guess we'll say celebrity, this attention has definitely been something that I'm having to get used to. But it's fun to go in a store and have people want your autograph or want to take a picture with you. That's cool. I like that. But it definitely is taking some adjustment. I'm a private person. I've never been one that shared a lot on social media. I like my privacy. So there are some adjustments that come with the newfound recognition. But overall, I'm happy and it's good.
Awesome. Well, it's great to hear your voice doing a few different interviews out there. I listened to a few in research in this podcast and I've had you on a few things anyway. And of course, the last couple of months, I've been catching up with the series. I started watching it when it was on in the US originally, just via means online because it came on a little bit later here in the UK and I wanted to kind of watch it straight away. But I've been catching up with it while it's been on here as well. So it's been great. What I want to start off with is something I heard quite recently on an interview you've done previously. Now, we're going to talk a lot about Skinwalker Ranch and everything that comes with that. But you've had your own UFO sighting when you were younger. And I just wanted to hear a little bit about that from you, Thomas. Okay.
So you'd like to know about my UFO sighting when I was a child?
Yes. Yeah.
You know, unfortunately, it really was pretty anticlimactic. I was when I was growing up, there was an old oil refinery that was out on the west side of town. And my window in my bedroom overlooked that. And I was up late. I mean, it was late for a kid. It was probably like 11 or 12 at night. And I looked out the window and I saw this big, gorgeous, beautiful orange moon just out there on the horizon above the refinery. I mean, it looked identical to the moon. But I mean, it was just gorgeous. It was just out there hovering. But it wasn't a full moon. It was like a half moon. But instead of, it was like on its, it was scooped kind of like a bowl, I guess, sitting there on the horizon. And it was big enough and beautiful enough that it definitely caught my attention. I looked at it, I thought, wow. But then I went about my business and I don't remember if I was cleaning up my room or what I was doing. But when I finished, I looked back out the window to see if I could get one more look at the moon before I went to bed. And it wasn't there. And it was low enough on the horizon. Like it was just out there kind of above the refinery, that I just assumed that it had dropped over the horizon. Or, you know, it was just out of sight. And didn't think anything else of it. And the next morning when I got up, I was telling my mom, I got up and I was like, man, you should have saw the moon last night. It was so beautiful. And my mom said, I don't think there was a moon last night. Yeah, there was. I saw it. It was above the refinery. And so we had a calendar, you know, hanging there close and we looked at it. And it was actually that night there was not a moon. So I don't know what I saw out there, hanging above the refinery, but it definitely was not the moon. And that was my first time of seeing an unidentified object. I have no idea what it was, but definitely not scary. It was just big and beautiful and unknown.
No, that's amazing. And was that in the same sort of area that you live now or had you relocated since? Yeah.
So I haven't gone far in life. I live, I actually lived just across the field from where I grew up. So I live about 40 acres away from where my childhood home was. And the whole Una basin has been a very big hotbed of UFO sightings and objects. And anyone that's lived here for a number of years, you'll find that there's a high percentage of people that have their own stories to share of unidentified objects up in the air.
And we've heard many of those over the years. And obviously, it's came to a point where Skinwalker Ranch, it's grown arms and legs over the time with its myth and its history. And it's now culminated in a series one and soon to be series two of a very, very popular show. So one of the listeners had asked, what exactly is your educational background? So as a child, you've had this UFO sighting. You then go to school, college, whatever, and you have a career path that's led you to where you are now. Can you just tell us a little bit about that?
Sure, absolutely. So I'm kind of, I've got my fingers into a lot of different areas. I started off in construction. So I went to college for construction management. So I got my contractor's license when I was like 23. And the requirements for contractor's license varies, even across the United States, different states have different requirements. And so in some states, that's not a very big deal. But in Utah, it actually takes a lot of work. And it takes at least four years before a person can get their contractor's license. It's kind of the equivalent of having a bachelor's degree in some ways, because you have to work four years full time under a licensed contractor. You have to take several state tests and pass them in order to get this. So for me, it was a big achievement to be able to get this at the age of 23. And then I started building. I didn't just want to build any homes. I wanted to build the biggest, best homes. And if I'm not challenged, I'm not happy. So I quickly got into high end custom homes. We were doing very large homes, eight, nine, ten thousand square foot homes. And so that's really what kind of got me into the ranch was 2008 when we had a recession here in the United States. And I think it was pretty much worldwide. Construction became very hard because people couldn't get loans. And especially the clients that I was specifically dealing with, high end homes that were costing hundreds of thousands of dollars, millions of dollars. These took jumbo loans and those went away. And so my wife and I built a couple of small motels. We decided we needed a plan B. And as the viewers may or may not see on the series, we live in an area where there's a lot of oil wells. Sometimes if like when they'll pan the shot, if you look out in the distance around the ranch, you'll see a lot of oil wells that are out there. We got a lot of oil under the UNO basin. And so we decided to build these little motels and we specialize in high end. We are a little boutique hotel. We are rooms were extremely luxurious and nice and we cater to the upper end oil field guys, the engineers and the geologists and that. And when Brandon bought the ranch, he sent Jim Morris, who's the ranch manager out. And this was really the first weekend that Jim had come out and Brandon had said, go see if you can wrap your arms around what exactly we just picked up. And so Jim came out here and he was going through town and he actually ended up stopping and staying at my little motel that I'd built. And we got visiting and the next day when he was checking out, he, we were just talking and I'd mentioned that I'd built the hotel myself and that I was a contractor. And he said, oh, well, we just bought Skinwalker Ranch. I don't know if you've ever heard of it. And of course, living in the basin, the ranch is famous around here. When Mr. Bigelow had it and the Shermans, right as they were transitioning between the Sherman family and Mr. Bigelow was when I was in high school. And so it was kind of the height of all this activity that was taking place. And so in high school, we tried to sneak out there as kids and try to sneak onto the property. And so when Jim said Skinwalker Ranch, I immediately had my interest. And he said, you know, being a contractor, would you be willing to come out and do a property inspection for us? There's an old ranch house there. There's a modular home that's sitting there. And we just don't have any idea, you know, what kind of condition everything is in. So I went and did a property inspection for them there. We found the property to be in a state of disrepair. It appears that Mr. Bigelow had not spent any money on it for several years and had let it kind of fall into disrepair. And so I immediately made a list up, and Brandon asked me to go in and start to fix things and upgrade things. And after about a month, four or five weeks, I hit it off with Brandon instantly. We have a lot in common. He asked me if I would stay on and be the superintendent of the ranch and just kind of oversee it where I live close. You know, a lot of the ranch team lives out in Salt Lake area, which is a couple of hours away. And so because of my close proximity and because of my background in construction, it kind of made it a perfect position for me. And so I oversee all of the facilities. I've upgraded it. The command center, the control room that you see with all the TVs on the show. That was Eric Bard and I designed that together. And then I built that and did all the construction on it. And so the helipad, we've upgraded a lot of the facilities, the front gate has been upgraded. And so I oversee all the facilities. My responsibilities also include like anytime we add cameras or scientific instrumentation, it's my job to get all of the infrastructure over there. So I'm in charge of making sure we have power and internet, any physical amenities that are needed to make that work. It's my job to make sure that we have those. And then I also arrange for the grazing and take care of the ranch as far as making sure that the land is cared for, that it's getting watered. And then my dad is a state senator here in Utah, and I've been heavily involved in politics. I've ran all of his campaigns. I've been a campaign manager. And so I also do a lot of the public relations outreach as far as anytime we have issues that need coordinated with the local government officials, I am the one that usually reaches out and takes care of those. So that's my responsibilities in a nutshell. The kind of my background that got me into that was my construction management and then my side job of being campaign manager and being involved in politics. So it got my fingers in a lot of things.
I was going to say and you have not even mentioned, I believe your CEO of your wife's company as well, which deals a lot of meditational therapies. Is that right too?
Yeah. So I actually have a film production company and then we have this. We have residence meditations, which when it looked like we're going to start filming this last summer, we actually ended up selling our motels. It was too much, too many irons in the fire. I stepped away from the film production company, which our focus there, people hear that and they think, oh, well, that's why you guys are doing a film out there on the ranch. It had absolutely nothing to do with that. We actually do family documentaries. So we're about capturing people's life stories and putting them into movies. So I stepped away from that and I stepped away from the motel. Really, my wife's company that we've started this meditation company is that's that's my whole focus. So the ranch is something that I enjoy doing and I work out there every week. It is a job, you know, I spend at least 30 or 40 hours a week on the ranch. But my main focus is this meditation company of my wife's and and we're having amazing results with it and changing lives. And for me, that's what it's all about is trying to improve the human race.
So absolutely. I would recommend the links are on your Twitter bio as well for its resonance meditation. Yeah.
Yeah.
And it's all that yeah. Encouraged. It's amazing. And I won't take much of your time here because it's another issue. But I encourage people to look into it because it's going to change the world. It's not just a typical meditation.
So no, absolutely. Please, please check that out as well. And we'll have a lot of lessons interested in those sorts of topics too. So I just want to double back a little bit. So you talked about what you've grown up in that area. So you know about Skinwalker Ranch. What was your own personal knowledge of the ranch, its history, the myths around it? What was your view of the ranch growing up in the area?
So I've never even to this day, I've never watched a single one of the documentaries on it. I've never read any of the books. My knowledge of Skinwalker Ranch growing up here was based solely on a lot of the rumors and stories that are going around at church or at school and then in the local newspapers. I haven't seen any of the movies. I haven't read any of the books. And going on to the ranch, my excitement for being able to go on the ranch, and I was excited when Jim offered me the chance because here's this mysterious place that nobody else gets to go on. It was kind of the notoriety, the ability to go do something that most people were not able to. But as far as my personal beliefs in it, you know, the whole paranormal stuff, the skinwalker, all these orbs, all the things have been talked about. I didn't believe in it. I just thought it was people's imaginations running wild. And, you know, part of the problem in the UFO world and the paranormal world is we have a lot of claims and very little evidence to back it up. I'm just supposed to take your word that that hairy thing on your screen is not a dust ball, but rather some type of object up in the sky. So, you know, it's amazing as far as technologically advanced as we are, we still can't seem to get a clear picture of something. You know, they're all grainy and fuzzy. I think you could call me, I was a very healthy skeptic. And I don't, I didn't believe in a lot of it. That was really my viewpoint coming on to the ranch. I had heard the stories. I didn't believe the stories and I didn't think there was anything to it other than just a bunch of imaginations running wild.
So you touched on the first time you met Brandon Fugal. So I've just started with one of the kind of, if you're not huge on social media like normally like some of us are, then, and I don't mean huge in a celebrity way, you've got far more celebrity than I do, God. But one of the guys on Twitter, Dan at The Signal, he's been really prolific in the UFO community for quite a while. He's based in Wales, and himself and myself, just in talking about the Skinwalker Ranch series, decided, do you know what, while I've started up this podcast, I'd love to try something different and do a bit of a watch along. So me and Dan have started basically dropping episodes where we watch the series one episode at a time, and just talk about it, give our thoughts, digress on it, just go off on all different tangents. We compared in the first episode, Brandon Fugal to Bruce Wayne, particularly when he first meets Travis, and they drive in that car down the highway, and he's in this suit, it couldn't look any sharper. If he did have a superhero costume lying across the backseat, you wouldn't be surprised. But would that be fair? What was it like meeting Brandon Fugal for that first time? What was the conversation?
Yeah, so when I met Brandon Fugal for the first time, Jim Morse took me, I drove out to Salt Lake, and Jim Morse took me into Brandon's office. And Brandon, so Brandon is the largest commercial real estate broker in the Intermountain West. He's, his name is everywhere. And you got to understand that for your viewers that are over there, you know, across the pond, the brand and advertise, Brandon is big, he's splashy. He is one of the best salesmen I've ever met in my life as far as he he knows how to present well. So like in his real estate business, when you drive up the between Provo, Utah and Salt Lake, Utah, we call the I-15 corridor because I-15 is the interstate that runs up. Brandon's name, I swear, is like literally on every single building driving up the interstate. And he has been incredibly successful. So I knew Brandon Fugal by name only. I didn't know who he was. All I knew is that every impressive building between Provo and Salt Lake had his name splashed all over the side of it with his phone number. And so this guy must be pretty important. His name's everywhere. And you go to his office and again, his office is incredible. And so for a small town businessman like myself, walking into this new world of these guys that are just operating extremely high level, I love it. I don't get intimidated easy, so I wasn't intimidated at all. But here's a new world I'm being introduced into and Brandon comes in and he spent, I believe our first conversation that day was about three hours long, which for Brandon, he's always going 100 different directions. He's putting out a million fires and I wouldn't be surprised if he's got that superhero cape hidden in the trunk behind the car. I wouldn't be surprised at all. But our first conversation is about three hours and he very meticulously and very clearly communicated with me why he bought the ranch, what his vision was for it, his belief system around it, and then he laid out where he thought that I could assist him in it. We spent three hours together and he's always had a curiosity about the unknown and those life's answers. Are we alone in the universe? Where did we come from? Where are we going? Obviously, we have religious answers to those, but he's really fascinated on the science side, and has put his money where his mouth is. The ranch is not his first endeavor into trying to figure out the unknown. He's invested in tech companies before that were geared around trying to figure this stuff out as well. When he had this opportunity to buy this mysterious ranch where these things are supposedly going on, he jumped on it. Brandon is one of the coolest human beings that I've had the privilege of meeting. When you see him on TV, I read some of the message boards on that, and you hear Brandon in the first episode when he's like, all right, Eric, get the case. You know, he's being like serious. People are like, oh, they're dramatizing this. But those of us that know Brandon Fugal, that is Brandon Fugal. That's not acting. What can I say? He eats his shit up. He loves his stuff. It's what he's grown up in. So that's not Brandon acting. That is really Brandon. He's just a great person to be around. He's very open, very transparent and very caring. I watch people have no idea how much Brandon does for those people around him. He's a very caring human being and he's a good guy. I can't say enough good about Brandon. But his intentions here is purely to get to the bottom of this mystery and try to figure it out and to be very transparent about it. He doesn't have an agenda.
Yeah. I think something that comes across with Brandon and just it's very factual, whether you like him or not, he doesn't have to do this. He has put his own money into this. This is not a money making scheme because I think anyone who's in the UFO community, there are very few people who make money from it. This is a guy who's got enough money. As you see enough other projects that this is definitely a labor of love for him as well. Then something I think obviously Brandon's came into most of our lives through the show like yourself. Until you appear on the show and we get to know you, that's when you start existing for most people. Was that meeting with Brandon, am I right in saying around 2017?
I think my first meeting with him would have been like either April or May of 2016.
Okay. So for me, your life or existence came into being around the start of this year, but this TV tells me that, no, this was last summer. What were you doing then from that meeting with Brandon until we saw you on the screens because you clearly had an important job on the ranch?
Yeah. So like I said, the property was in disrepair and Mr. Bigelow, we know very little about what Mr. Bigelow did or did not do during his time on Skinwalker Ranch. It's still locked away behind, it's still hidden and he hasn't come forth with any information. In turning over the ranch to Brandon, the only thing that Brandon received when he purchased the ranch was the real estate documents that are required by law, you know, soils tests and some of the things that prove that the property is, there's nothing dangerous on the property as far as radioactive or in Utah, real estate disclosures require that you disclose, you know, if there's something wrong with the property, you're supposed to disclose it to the buyer. So there was those type of things. But there was no scientific data that was turned over, nothing. And when we came on, it was hard to tell that there had been a scientific effort at all. And so we basically started from scratch. Brandon's, that first meeting that I was with Brandon, he explained to me that he bought this property, and he wasn't even sure if there was anything to all of this. Because Mr. Fugal hadn't transferred over any data, he wasn't sure if this was a bunch of stories or if there was actually something strange happening at the ranch. And so he wanted me to meet his principal investigator, Eric Bard, who's a trusted confidant of Brandon's. And one of the greatest scientists, I mean, this guy is just brilliant and so disciplined in his approach and so meticulous about the way that he does his science. He's above reproach. And Brandon said, for the first little while, I want you to make as little disturbances as possible. And I just want to observe and see if we can see anything going on. And so even when we went and put cameras up, Bigelow had some old camera. He'd put his cameras inside of these metal housing casings out there on a pole. And so we actually just took his cameras out because they were obsolete and just they were no good. And when we put our cameras, we actually put them inside just so that the outside appearance didn't change at all. We didn't want to broadcast any that we were there, really, that we were trying to watch. And so we were just in a state of observation. And so for the first 12 to even maybe 16 months that Brandon owned the ranch, we were in an observation period where we were just trying to see, is there something happening at Skinwalker Ranch? And it didn't take very long. And matter of fact, Brandon had his first UFO sighting on the ranch, I think six months after he purchased the property, you know, going into the fall here. But it didn't take very long before we started to witness things that were unexplainable. And the answer became very clear that, yes, there is something strange taking place on Skinwalker Ranch. And then, about, I'd say early 2017, the discussion began to shift from, is there something happening to, there is something happening now, what do we do about it? What is the next step? And that's when we started to transition into taking some pretty aggressive steps to update the infrastructure. Brandon is very wealthy, but he's wealthy because he's smart with his money. He just didn't start dumping money a million directions. Our investment has always been, it's always followed the data. So for example, the first camera system that we put out on the ranch was a very inexpensive, low grade, low quality system. It was simply there to just see if we could capture. And once we started capturing stuff, then Brandon incrementally started to increase the quality of the cameras and the surveillance systems that we had based on the data that we were getting. And we've spent money on things and haven't got any results. And so there's no sense spending even more money in that area. And so our spending has been focused solely on where we're getting the results. So my time out at the ranch in the last four years was, it is a ranch that requires care. It needs to be irrigated. You have to get livestock on there that turns into a big fire hazard because the grass grows two feet tall in the spring. And then because we're in a desert by August, it's just so dead and dry that even a spark would just burn the whole place down. The cows come in, they eat the grass down and then it doesn't do that. So the fences, I mean, there's so much maintenance just with the regular ranch that takes place that I was trying to take care of. And then when you add on to that, the science, once 2017 started, that's when we started to make aggressive changes. And really, so then the whole narrative of my injury comes into play because it was, it was March of 2017 when I had that severe injury. And it may be coincidentally, maybe not. We don't know for sure. We can't say positively. But, that's when I started to do some major excavation on the ranch in conjunction with upgrading the facilities. And then, you know, I start, I start changing the landscape drastically, putting in some roads and things for security to be able to get around on the ranch. And then I end up with this injury. So I've been very busy over the past four years. I've installed every single camera on the place. Every, I've run miles and miles of power lines and internet lines. I've upgraded the septic, the septic system, the wastewater system was completely shot. We've replaced that. The old ranch house had a lot of mold issues and stuff in it that we had to take care of. I obviously put in the helipad and we remodeled the command center. It was just a dumpy old little modular trailer that was complete shambles. We've remodeled that to what you see on television. That's what I've been doing the last four years.
That's amazing. There must have been as much hard work as that sounds. Getting to create that little command center is like a tech geek's dream. When that door opened for the first time and you see all those screens, it's like I paused the TV that I was watching. I was just looking around going, oh my God, how many TVs? They've got at least 9, 10, 11, 12 cameras on display just now and then I've got so many TVs here and there's just boxes everywhere and you would just love five, 10 minutes in that room to go and just mess about with it to see what you can do. So that must have been a lot of fun. Can I just ask then, so that takes us up to the almost present day, the last year or so, when did you first start to hear that there's potentially going to be a show made about the ranch? Was that quite a quick process or was it something that was always in the offing?
Now, so it's something that once we determined that there was something happening on the ranch and that discussion turned, okay, yeah, we're seeing things happen here. Now, what do we do with this information? Do we keep it to ourselves like Bigelow did? Do we share out in a public forum? If we share it in a public forum, how do you do that? Is that just something like we make a YouTube video and put it up? Is this something you put in the Science Journal? It really became how do you release this information? About the same time, and I want to make sure I get my dates here, but the entire time we owned the ranch, one of the first things we had to do, there was a road that went right through the middle of the ranch that was a public road. When we bought it, the county notified Brandon that we couldn't lock the gate anymore. There was a public road, we had to let the public go across. Which put a lot of panic through the team, because it's like, how can you carry on an ongoing science investigation if you've got tourists going through the middle of your laboratory? And so I was able to go to the county and get that road vacated and shut down. And when I did that, it required public hearings. And Brandon, he didn't want this to stigmatize his business. You know, this whole paranormal world doesn't always mix well when you're talking about business professionals and real estate, and you're trying to sell a building to people and they think you're a quack, you know, because you're chasing ghosts and goblins. So Brandon was very adamant that people not know his identity. So anytime we had to go public with something, we always did it through my name. So I was the one that attended the public hearings. I was the one that got the road vacated. We did, Brandon let me, he reached out and said, hey, release a few of these photos on the Internet. So I would put a few photos out. So when people went searching for Skinwalker Ranch, my name was the only one that they could find associated with it. And because of that, I had both the blessing and the curse of having hundreds of people reach out to me on a regular basis, asking, can we come on the ranch or we want this or we want that? And part of that was, is at least once or twice a month, I got solicited from some type of movie producer or TV producer that was wanting to do a show on Skinwalker Ranch. And I'd always just take most of them. Brandon kind of charged me with the task of vetting through them and picking out which ones are serious, not just TV producers, but anybody that contacted us in regards to the ranch. And so Brandon would have me vet them and I'd have these TV people reach out and I would look and be, no, and so 99% of them got filtered out. And I had one guy about the same time that now the discussion is, we're starting to have this discussion of, well, how do we release this to the public? I had a TV producer named TJ. Allard. He's one of the executive producers on the show. And TJ reached out to me and introduced himself, and eventually convinced me into taking a phone call. And he pitched this idea of allowing TV cameras to come on and document our process, our science investigation. And so, I told him, we're not interested. You're always welcome to continue to call back. That's fine. You're a nice guy. I'll take your call. Well, TJ then started to reach out to me every single month, and he did so for almost a year. Hey, man, just checking in. You think it's something you guys would be interested in? Well, about month six or seven, eight of this, I don't know the exact time, but I did reach out to Brandon and I said, you know, we're having this discussion on how to release this. I've got this TV guy that's pitched this idea, and he's been pretty persistent. Brandon at the time was like, I don't know if we really want to do that. I was like, no problem. Then as time went on, TJ kept being persistent. Finally, I said, all right, I'll let you talk to Jim Morse. Jim's the manager. If Jim thinks it's a good idea, then we'll take you to Brandon. Jim talked to him for another couple of months. Then finally, Jim's like, yeah, T.J.'s the real deal. He's a good guy. It's worth having a conversation. I think TJ may have even flown in to talk to Brandon. I'm not sure about that. But TJ finally got to talk to Brandon, and thus the idea of the whole network series came in to being, and that's kind of how it came to be. It's not something that we went out looking for. I have to give TJ a lot of credit for being persistent and following up every single month, and he just didn't give up. It took a long time from when we first contacted, and then even after that point that he had that conversation with Brandon, and I think it was a long time after that, before it became a reality, so.
So on The Ranch at this point, we're getting to the point now where we're about to start filming the show. Is it yourself, Jim Morse? Is Jim Sagala there as well?
So our ranch team from the beginning has basically been myself and Eric Bard, the principal investigator, Jim Morse, who's the ranch manager, and Bryant Arnold, Dragon. He's been there from the beginning. And then Jim Sagala, he has an interesting past in the fact that he has done a lot of work that is tied in with the ranch through other individuals. So he's tied in with some of the scientists that worked for Mr. Bigelow, Mr. Bigelow's investigation. And so Jim Sagala had a lot of knowledge as far as the Bigelow days. And then with my injury, that's kind of Jim Sagala, he was one of the three individuals that investigated my head injury. And so it made sense to bring him in because one, he's coming at it from kind of that biomedical side with my injury. And then he also had pretty good knowledge of some of the things that Bigelow had done during Bigelow days. So he's been tied into the ranch for quite some time, but not necessarily like on our branch team, if that makes sense.
Yeah, of course, that's really interesting to know. How did things start to change on the day-to-day running of the ranch as the cameras and crew? And I'm guessing to you, Janie's people start to come in for you guys, because you've now had it, what, two to three years at this point working on the ranch. And I'm guessing things changed to some degree. What was that like?
Yeah. So they absolutely did change. I mean, you know, well, Jim Sagala had been on the ranch several times before, and he'd been working behind the scenes on my investigation, on my head injury, and been working on some of the science as well. Travis was new to the scene. You know, we're bringing on a new skeptical scientist. And when you bring a new scientist on, it almost is like you have to go back to the beginning and say, we've done this, this, this, this. And then they want to, of course, see that for themselves. They want to be able to verify for themselves what's going on. And then the investigation, so it is authentic on TV as far as we're not dramatizing, it's not scripted. They left it up to us to do what we wanted to do. I was never told what to say as far as like, you know, do this or do that. So it's authentic that way, but it did change the fact that there's a lot of the science that would just put people to sleep. It's definitely not made for TV. And so for those couple of months that you have the cameras there, you're really focused more on the visual side of things. We've been trying to process the data from the summer filming since the cameras turned off and went away because we gathered a lot of data and then you're trying to go through and post-process it, figure out, plot it, figure out what it all means. So it changes in the format that we're trying to share what our investigation is with the audience, which is legit, but at the same time, even things like when we're measuring RF, for example, we're out there. Well, we're all wearing microphones. The cameras are all broadcasting wirelessly. We're creating a lot of radio frequencies just by our presence being there. There's nothing abnormal about that. So when you have a meter and it's spiking and it's showing high levels of RF, well, a lot of that could just be caused by our cameras and our microphones and our self-emitted, all our cell phones and all the equipment that's there. The process becomes a little harder because you have to eliminate the known sources from the unknown sources, which means if you're starting to see those spikes, you got to turn off the cameras, you got to turn off the microphones, you got to turn off the cell phones. You've got to eliminate everything you possibly can that might be emitting that signal so that you can tell that that signal is legit and not just manmade. So there's a lot of that stuff that you have to learn how to work with the film crew and try to figure out. We're out there with, I think it's episode 3 when we're out there trying to triangulate, and there's a camera shot of us like we got these coffee cans. It's Jim Sagala and Travis and I. We got these coffee cans with these little RF meters, right? And I've taken a lot of criticism for this as I'm sure Travis and Jim, but we're like holding this RF meter out in front of the coffee can, which obviously defeats the whole purpose. And so people are like, you're not even using those right. You guys don't know what the heck you're doing. Well, when the meter is inside the coffee can and you've got to hold it so that you can still see inside the can and see the meter, but keep it inside. The camera can't see that. It doesn't make for a good camera shot for the audience. So it's balancing. It's like actually doing the exercise and then being able to film it in a way that the audience could get an idea of what it is that we're trying to accomplish. And so there's so much of that, that's like, oh, we need to, you got to pull that out of the can where we can pick that up with the camera. And so that's a lot of the adjustments. Trying to learn how to do the science and make it work for the camera guys so that we can give them their sexy shot that's going to bring ratings to the television show.
This is something I've addressed with Dan when we do the Watch Along show. And I love the show and I can compare it to the unidentified series with Tom DeLong and Luisa Elizondo. I don't know if you watched any of that around obviously the Tic Tac UFO. And it's again History Channel produced it. It's, you know, that's about UFOs and the US government's recent admissions. And then this is here's a serious scientific investigation on history again about Skinwalker Ranch. So the comparisons are probably pretty fair. So something then I'll address now. So the reception of season one, there was a lot of great reviews. The ratings were really good. I've actually been involved in a conversation with a few people today where Brandon has been destroying some skeptics fantastically on Twitter, which I love to watch him do because he's very eloquent and he's extremely intelligent and I love the way he comes across. However, like you've said yourself, there's a lot of mixed feelings on the production, potentially manufactured, forced incidents, and you've addressed that there when you say that you've got to do certain things for different camera shots. Have you watched the full season back? Would you say any of those criticisms were fair around the production aspect of it?
Yeah. I know what we filmed and then just like the regular viewers, I'm sitting down on television and you have to realize that we filmed all summer and that's condensed down to eight. I don't know what they are, 45 or 50-minute episodes. You're taking weeks and weeks and weeks of filming and editing it down for 45 minutes episode. I think the frustrating thing with the whole production is, first of all, I think that Prometheus did a wonderful job. I want to be clear that I think they did a great job of trying to balance, showing the viewer the science that's going on, but putting it in a format that's going to be watchable for 95 percent of the people that are not. Those of us that are in the science, we want the details. We could do without the drama, without the buildups and that. We want to know what are the facts here? What's the data? What are you seeing? That's what's important. But you have to understand that 95 percent of the viewers are coming home from work. They're kicking their feet up. They just want something to entertain them for an hour, not think about their day. Prometheus has had the challenge of trying to edit that and keep it true to the science, but at the same time, I'm just going to say it, dramatizing it in ways. I have to say as I'm watching it, like if I'm being 100% honest, I'm happy with most of, I'm happy with probably 90% of everything they did. I'm happy with, I understand they had to portray it somehow, and I'm happy with the way they did it. There's 10% of it probably that I cringe, and I say, I wish that they would have shown that differently because that should have, in my opinion, that should have been portrayed differently, or they shouldn't, you know, Episode 6 was hard for me. I did not like the way that that was edited. I'm just going to say it. I didn't like the way that Episode 6 was edited.
Just for the listeners that might not be sure of Episode 6, what was the particular incident you weren't happy about?
Well, that's the episode with the drilling and then the alpacas, and specifically dealing with the whole alpaca incident of them being attacked. I was very unhappy about the way that that was portrayed and edited. I felt like in some ways it was deceiving as to what the way that it was filmed. Let's just put it that way. I have to be careful because I'm not here to throw anybody under the bus, but I do feel like I have the right to have a voice and say, I'm happy with the way that was shown and the way that that was not shown. But for me, yes, there are parts of it that I'm like, I wish that would have been portrayed differently. But overall, like I say, 90 percent of it, I'm happy with what they showed, and maybe that's also because I was there. So when I see the criticisms and the critics, oh, you're using the coffee cans wrong. Yeah, it does show us using those wrong, but we did do it the right way. The cameras just didn't, they chose not to use that film because it didn't look as good as this stuff. So in my mind, I can be at peace with that because I think the critics have everything. He's right. We were using those cans wrong. So I can't blame him for filling that way. But it was just a representation. We did use them the correct way. We did go through and, you know, the camera. Like, for example, when we have to take the cameras down to check for RF, that's something that's not getting filmed. So the audience can't see us doing our very best to be true to science and trying to eliminate, okay, was it this? Was it that? And so yeah, it's one of those things where it's almost like a marriage, you know, you got to compromise a little bit and, you know, you're not going to get perfect. So you just strive to get for something that you can both live with. And that's kind of what I feel like with this TV series.
No, I really appreciate the honesty on that. And I think when you get involved in something like the community, whether it's paranormal, the UFO community, you know, people who see a spiritual side to what's going on or whatever it is, they're very protective because this is something for their whole life. It's been theirs. There'll be people that for Skinwalker Ranch, this is what it means to them. And when people try and make it look like something it's not, they get protective. And the UFO community is one of the worst for that. It's great, but it's also brutal at times as well, the slightest thing. So I get that. And you're right that it's entertainment at the end of the day. And if you want to move the conversation forward and you want to bring a new audience to kind of see what's being done there with the investigation, and does that involve eventually getting more funding, more eyes on the project, and moving it into a bigger discussion, then you do have to aim at people in an entertaining way. Because like you say, as incredible as the science is, and the data is going to be the thing that ultimately gives us answers, it's not going to get ratings. And ratings, if they're low, aren't going to renew shows. So there's a balance there to be found. And I think if I had anything, and this is just my own personal for season two, whoever's in charge of mixing the music and the dramatic headshots of, you know, when you look to the side, and I just get that cringe of, ah, he shouldn't have a look. But I reckon the look, and particularly Dragon, some of his looks, I think, has he actually done that at that time? Or have they taken a totally random shot from five minutes before, where someone's been ordered in a Chinese and he's not been happy with what's came, what's been delivered, and they've just used that as the shot. So I always worry about that on these reality-based series. But yeah, that's an absolute correlation there. Both.
Sometimes they're real, and sometimes they were edited from five minutes earlier when the Chinese was not right.
So yes. Do you know what? I can live with that though. You get that. It's getting an audience, and do you know what? It has been renewed for a second season. I'm going to wrap up on talking about season two. But just to go back, then, you've mentioned a few times about your head and your injury. So what we see is that before the season started a couple of years previous, you had done some digging. I believe the shot used in the show was with an excavator or some kind of digging and equipment. And off the back of that, I mean, your words will be better than mine. Do you want to just quickly talk through what happened and what we can see on the show?
Yeah. So yeah, I was using a skid steer. And I was actually carving into the side of the mesa. There was a section of ranch up on the mesa that security could only access by foot. We'd had some issues with trespassers. And by the time you get up on top of mesa with the foot, they're gone and we've dealt with vandalism, all kinds of stuff. So my fix for that was, hey, I'll carve a road up on top so we can get up on there with the UTVs and then they can't outrun us. We can better patrol the perimeter of the ranch. I started to do this excavation and it was during the course of doing it. Matter of fact, so that particular, that particular road that I was working on lies unfinished today. It's about three quarters of the way finished. Still doesn't get up on top. But the one thing that I fought with the network on a little bit was they kept saying, matter of fact, I saw a rough cut of the first episode and they had me and I was digging and then my head started to swell up. And I told them, if you put that in there, I will sing like a canary because that's not what happened. I was not digging and it started to swell up. See, the fact of the matter is, while there have been literally dozens of incidents where I have been digging and then something bad happens, correlation does not mean that you can't point for sure and say, oh, that happened because you dug. It could have seriously been a series of coincidences that have nothing to do with each other. But it happens enough that it does give us pause and it's like, okay, it's something we need to keep in the back of mind, we need to be careful of. In this particular case, here I am defacing the mesa to put this road in, just this little UTV trail up the side. My injury started on a Saturday. I hadn't even been to the ranch in a couple of days. It had been two days since I've been at the ranch, or three days. I don't remember now exactly, but on the back of my head, on the lower part of my head, on Saturday night, it was actually my birthday. I can remember the date perfect because it started on my birthday, March 4th. That night when I went to bed, I noticed that I had a sore spot on the back of my head. It was like a bruise, about a little bit, probably like one inch in diameter. I didn't think much of it. We'd actually spent my birthday at a funeral of a loved one. So I'd been sat all day inside of a church house at a funeral, hadn't done any physical activity. Went to bed when I woke up Sunday morning, that bruise had swollen up. It was really tight. It was like a little goose egg. It was extremely painful. My thought was, maybe I'd just gotten a spider bite, or some type of insect had bitten me, and I had reacted to it. I mentioned it to my wife. Sunday morning, we went to church, and as church was going on, as this hour rolled on, I started to feel sicker and sicker. I finally told my wife that I was going to leave church early. I went home, laid down, and my head just hurt really, really bad. I felt nauseous. I thought maybe I had the flu. At this point, I was pretty certain that I'd gotten an insect bite and it was making me sick. I'm otherwise an extremely healthy person. I've had physicals. I passed them with flying colors. I'm a healthy individual. Every test that I've taken, my markers have always come back excellent. I wasn't worried. I never go to the doctor unless I absolutely am dying and I have to. My wife came home. She was concerned about me. Sunday progressed into Sunday evening and then into Monday morning. I was now pretty sick. I was not up on my feet. And Monday, she wanted to take me to the hospital and I refused to let her. I told her, no, I'll be fine. It's just a spider bite. Like, let it run its course. I'll start feeling better soon. And then by Monday night, I was in extreme pain. And starting Monday night, probably around 10 p.m., the goose egg went, it stayed pretty much the same size all of Sunday and all of Monday. But coming to Monday night, the goose egg started to grow and it started to spread. And what ended up happening was that my, the fatty tissue of my scalp separated from my skull. And so I basically got scalped. And Monday night into Tuesday morning, it's the most excruciating pain I've ever felt in my life. I was, I can't even describe the amount of pain I was in. And I just toughed it out. At this point, I'm not, I don't know that I was thinking 100% straight, but my wife woke up Tuesday morning, and she saw that my head had completely swollen up. There was a definite line on my forehead where it had separated, and it continued to slowly move down my forehead towards my eyes. And so she freaked out, loaded me up, took me to the hospital where I was admitted, and ended up spending the week in the hospital. And by the end of the third day, I could pretty much grab the hair on my head and walk my face around my skull because it wasn't attached. It was detached. It was pretty gruesome. And because of my association with the ranch, I was only out of the hospital a day or two when I was contacted by Brandon and the team and asking me if I'd be willing to allow some people to come investigate it. And so I had only been home a couple of days when the investigation into what had taken place. Now, mind you, when I was in the hospital, my doctors could not figure out what was going on. I did over, I think they ran 43 different tests. They were able to rule out insect bites. They were able to rule out. Every test I took, my doctor would come back into my room after the test, after the lab results came back and he'd shake his head and say, you're the healthiest sick person I've ever met. All my lab tests were coming back, not just good, but they were spot on perfect. When they biopsied the fluid in my head, I mean, it came back 100 percent sterile. They couldn't even, I mean, it was nothing. Everything that they were seeing in my results justified what they should be seeing. My doctor used the term medically impossible several times with me. They could not figure out what was going on. When they released me from the hospital, I even had to sign a paper on the release forms that was the hospital saying, we have no idea what caused this. We have no idea what happened to you. Therefore, we don't know what to tell you to stay away from and maybe sign that paper. Then the investigation site started. These individuals had three individuals that were investigating my injury very closely. It's been over the course of the past two or three years. They've had me continue to take further tests and more MRIs, more all kinds of different tests. It's through this investigation process that as time goes on and as they learn more about what took place and have dove into my medical records and everything, that the confidence level has increased dramatically, that it is associated with the ranch and that it did occur on the ranch, but in all honesty, none of us can say 100% sure that it happened on the ranch or that it, you know. But the investigation and where we're being led shows that, yes, it is tied into the ranch. And that's why I think the network continues to and they bring it up all the time. I think if I cringe a lot of us, because like, oh, seriously, you're showing that picture again. But would that be the picture of the scan, where it shows the fluid and both the scan and then the one that I'm in the hospital, where I look like total, I look like, oh man, they show the picture of me in the hospital, my head bandaged. And I've seen that. I don't know how many times I've seen that in the episodes. And I'm like, seriously, you're showing that picture again. So but that's one of the reasons why they do is because the investigation, which to be honest with the viewers, there are a lot of facts with my injury that are not public. And I don't know if they ever will become public. Some of that's not really in my hands because of the things that they've unearthed. So it does appear like it is associated with the ranch and the investigation. Careful, careful, long, disciplined investigation has shown that indications are strong, that it is ranch related. And then comes the speculation as to what caused it, why.
It's good to hear you say that even though it's something you've experienced and you know, like you say, the pain you went through and you've had this separate investigation, which I'm sure people are going to love to hear the kind of mysterious side of it. But for you, it's trying to get some answers. And if that's something that's getting you closer to that, that's really good to hear. And from our point of view, it's great you're fit and healthy. But then there's also the potential that this could be a warning shot from whatever the phenomena is on the ranch. Because like you say, yeah, you've done some digging, you've defaced it, you've changed it. And if that's something that we're not observant, it's fine. But actually, like we know, the first episode is called, Bad Things Happen When You Dig, for a reason. You know, something bad happened when you dug. It does flare up again near the start of the season. And everyone seems really concerned. I know you take yourself away from the scene, don't you? How much did that shape the safety protocols going forward? And did that have an impact on the show going forward? That, you know, you'd started to feel that kind of pain again.
Yeah, so I've had several small reoccurrences and all ranch related. And each time you think you've got it behind you, you think that it's in your past. When that happened, when we were out there, now it's interesting, here we are shining lasers up on the mesa. And, and then next thing I know, like my head is in that, you know, the concerning thing was it wasn't like the pain was excruciating. I mean, it hurts. I'm not going to lie. The pain hurt. It was not the same kind of pain that I felt with my first injury. But it was it was the fact that it was taking place in that exact same spot that it started the first time. That was a concerning thing. It's like, great. Here we go again. It did start to swell up again. And this time, if the producers want me to go out there and say, we were shining lights on the mesa and my head started to swell up, I'll do it because we were out there shining lights on the mesa and my head started to swell up. I was on the ranch and this starts to happen again. And it did shake us. And there was a whole discussion that went on in my absence. And then also, I was taking, I took some phone calls off site too while this whole thing is going on. And Brandon is not about to let his curiosity be more important than the health of his team. Brandon is very, very people-oriented. And his concern is genuine. It's not dramatized. It's not contrived. And so there was discussion. Brandon was seriously saying, I don't know if this is worth it, guys. Like, he had a conversation with me. He's like, Tom, like, is it really worth it? Are we playing with fire? Should we pull out? You know, I don't want, this isn't worth somebody that I care about deeply getting hurt. And, and then, you know, you see, you see some of that discussion on TV. I think it's an episode three when I come back. But it is something that I can't, in my heart, I can't believe that all this stuff that's happening on the ranch is like honoring the little barbed wire fence that goes around the border, that somehow that fence is keeping all the ghost and goblins in, right? And so there's a good chance that a lot of the things that we're seeing on the ranch are happening in the surrounding area as well, which we have a lot of people. Even though we're rural, you know, you have hundreds if not thousands of people within a short proximate distance that, um, that call this home. And, uh, and as long as we've got somebody like Brandon that has the money and the resources to come in and investigate it, um, I, I had a little bit of fear in my heart, like, don't pull out because, you know, yeah, Bigelow came and investigated and what did we get out of it? We don't know what we got. Nothing came of it. They locked everything behind. So as long as we've got someone like Brandon that's willing to foot the bill and pay for this investigation, I don't want to lose that opportunity. And we owe it to the surrounding areas to see if this is something that's just on the ranch or maybe there's something dangerous in the surrounding areas as well. And so, um, we, we pushed on and I encouraged him not to, not to run, but it shaped the rest of the season. I think what it did is it made Travis because Travis thought we were all a bunch of scaredy cats. And matter of fact, his exact words to us before the TV series even started is he thought we were all batshit crazy. And I think that my injury kind of snapped him out of it and brought, made it real for him that this is a, this is not something we're just goofing around about. We're not just saying these things to make it sound mysterious. Like there are real effects going on here. I think if anything, my injury made Travis realize that there are consequences and that the investigation needs to be done, but it needs to be done safely. It needs to be done cautiously. I know that's kind of when his view of Dragon changed because at that point he realized that we have good reason to be cautious about what we're doing. And there's a reason why we haven't just been running around poking the hornet's nest. So it did change the rest of the season. It'll change the rest of the investigation as far as the show goes, because I think that's what made it real like, oh man, somebody like, okay, people could get her. And then you see later on in the later episodes that Travis himself starts to experience some of these same things. And so it validated the fact that we need to be cautious.
Absolutely. And that incident was highlighted, you know, again, hopefully something doesn't happen again to you, because it can't be a nice thing to experience. However, was there anything that the cameras did or didn't pick up that you would put alongside that as some of the strangest things that you've been a part of or witnessed while you've been on the ranch?
Yeah, so my injury is definitely the top. And then because I spend so much time on the ranch, as far as my physical, like physically present on the ranch, I spend just as much, if not more time than anybody else on the ranch team and have done since day one. I have had the opportunity, blessing or curse, I'm not sure, of having a lot of experiences on the ranch. I've experienced tear. And this is a feeling where I didn't see anything. I couldn't, like I couldn't tangibly see what the danger was. But there was like a neurological or psychological effect. I think, I think it had to do some type of, we've recorded these high electromagnetic. My brain is shortening out now. We've registered a lot of these radio frequencies that are extremely high, borderline dangerous. And there have been times on this ranch and they've happened at night. I've been over there doing my responsibilities. One night was when I was plowing snow. And I actually heard an audible voice associated with this. And it told me to stop and don't go any further. And when I ignored this voice, I know for a fact it was not audible. Like it happened inside my head. But you couldn't have told me the difference. It sounded just as if you're talking to me. But I know it wasn't audible because I was plowing snow. My skid steer was making so much noise. And then I had earbuds in my ears listening to an audio book. So somebody could have been standing three feet away from me, yelling at me. And I may not have heard them because of all the noise the machine was making. But I heard the voice crystal clear, which tells me it came from inside my head, not outside my head. I ignored the warning. It told me to not go any further. And immediately, when I continued down on... When I came, I was plowing snow. So I went back to the ranch house and I was coming back. And when I got to that point that I'd been warned not to go any further, I just thought, well, that's stupid. I'm just imagining this stuff. And I kept going and I only made it maybe 100 feet. And all of a sudden this terror gripped me, this fear. And it's unlike anything I've ever experienced in my entire life. I've been scared before, but nothing like this. And it became so bad that I was shaking. Like I was like at Parkinson's, I was shaking so severely I couldn't control it. And these times when this fear comes over me, the psychological or the neurological effects, I had one, well, this particular time I shook for about 12 hours before I stopped shaking. I couldn't control it. It was outside of my ability to control it. The next time it was almost 24 hours before I stopped shaking. So I've had that happen. I've seen things like, there was one day I thought I saw a dog walking across the road. We'd had some animals, some pack of dogs chasing the livestock. And so I saw this dog crossing the road and I thought I would go up and catch it. And when I got up to it, it wasn't there, like it just vaporized. So it was like a mirage type thing. We've had the equipment. I've had my cell phone, you see on the episode where the cell phones start going crazy. I've had my phone gripped. I've seen batteries go from 100% to zero in under two minutes. I've had, I'm trying to think, I've had a lot of things with my equipment take place. So many that I could literally spend two hours just telling you about the experience, maybe four hours talking about the experiences I've seen. But I've seen shadow figures over in the homesteads. So all kinds of strange, crazy things.
That's the beauty of the ranch, isn't it? And the area that there's, it's not just one phenomena, isn't just there's UFOs, it's not just there's, there's lights on the mesa or, you know, it's not you're getting these weird sounds coming from underneath the homes. There's a lot going on, you know, huge dire wolf type creatures, portals potentially opening up left, right and center. So that's the kind of mystique and the nature of the ranch. Obviously, we've got a second series, Brandon himself has said should be filming soon. If you've got anything more like, do you know any more about the dates or what we can kind of expect from a second season and even if you're kind of bound by networks that you can't discuss that kind of detail, what would you like to see in a second season?
Well, yeah, so Brandon being the boss, can get away with a lot of things I can't. So I took his lead. He tweeted out the other day that we were having a second season and I took the lead and was like, sweet, it's public knowledge now, I can share it with people and then only to be told that, no, I can't share that with people yet and it hasn't been made official. So I'll let Brandon take the lead on that stuff. He seems to be able to get away with it. That's fair. But I will say, and I've been vocal about this with Brandon and I've been vocal about it with the network and our meetings, when you're looking forward to what would... Hypothetically, if there was a second season, what would we do? We discovered a lot of things in episode one, I mean, in season one that I'd like to go back and revisit and more meticulously and carefully investigate out. There was a lot of loose ends left hanging that need followed up on. In addition, there's things in second season that I hope... I told the network that I sincerely hope in second season that they won't be less... In season one, they did not... They have this rule, they called it the fourth curtain, and that is that they don't want to become the story. They're there to capture the story. They don't want to become the story. So the production crew experienced a lot of things themselves. Their equipment was not immune to the anomalies that take place on the ranch. They struggled with batteries going dead. They struggled with getting equipment to work properly. Matter of fact, there's a huge section of filming that we did that got wiped mysteriously on a section. They experienced strange things on that ranch as well. Unfortunately, I feel like when you don't document those, then it leads to the criticism and justly so that says, well, why is it that that guy's $35,000 drone won't work, but the network's drone works just fine to capture it. It must be made up. It must be, this is just fake. I really hope that season 2, that when, not if, but when they experienced some of the same troubles that we're experiencing, the audience can see that and be shown behind the curtain and be like, oh, the network's cameras just went down and we don't know why, we can't figure it out rather than that never being shown. So I hope that that is shown. I hope that they allow us to show more mundane things. And by that, I mean technically every object in the sky is a UFO for at least a minute until your brain registers, that's a plane or that's a helicopter or that's a drone. We see so many UFOs on the ranch, it's unbelievable. But they might be a UFO for a day, they might be a UFO for a week, they might be a UFO for a year until we finally are able to crack the mystery of what that was. That was flight 1248 United going to London and for whatever reason, it didn't show up or whatever it is. And truth be told, 98 or 99% of the UFOs we see on the ranch, yeah, they're UFOs for a time. But then as we do the investigation, as Eric does his post-processing on the video and all that, at some point, we learn that it's just of mundane origin. And so I hope that they allow us to show some of those things so that people can see. We do our due diligence and we're not just drinking Kool-Aid. Not every fly on the camera lens is a UFO. Not every snowflake out there is an orb. But if that's all you show on television and that's all the audience sees, then how are they supposed to know that you've eliminated? You're calling this an unknown object because you've already eliminated out the insects and the bugs and the planes and the drones and the helicopters and the dust and all the things that can look damn impressive in a camera. But actually at the end of the day, it's just regular. If they'll allow us to show the guys going through that process of eliminating it and finding out that, oh, that was really cool to see. But at the end of the day, that was actually a piece of dust that was reflecting the infrared camera lens. So I think that will help bring credibility to the show if the audience is able to see behind the curtain just a little bit more and see, and I don't want to call them failures because it's not a failure, but see some of the debunking that takes place.
No, that would be great. You would think it especially in 2020 or more than likely 2021 when we potentially get to see a second season, if they make a second season, of course. You've got a lot of different platforms where you could put content like that, but if they don't want it in a main show that they still want to make dramatized or really focus on entertainment aspect, and you talked about some of the bold and science or the more mundane things, you could put that on a YouTube or you could put that on Twitter or whatever kind of platform they want. If they want to put on their own website, here's bonus content for people. Yeah, I'm sure there would be a market for that because that's something that definitely when I go through the Twitter feeds and the message boards, people question these things. The interest is definitely there. That probably takes us nicely, Thomas, on to some listener questions because the first one is linked on to what you've just said there. Ashley had a few questions for you. What kind of experiments would Thomas and the team like to do next? Also, are there any experiments you've done, you think you could have improved on?
I want better GPR. If Thomas gets to call the shots and I get to do this then, I want better, not, I'm not saying the guys that did in season 1 didn't do a good job. I'm saying they weren't able to do enough of the job. I want to go back, revisit that. And I want to investigate further over at the Homestead 2. You know, where we did the drilling. I think that we need to look into that more. You know, it's funny, I actually made a whole list the other day because I did submit a list saying, girl, you know, if there were a season 2, these are some of the ideas that I would like to explore further, if I had to say. But we triangulated, I think, one of the biggest things is we keep picking up these strange signals, these strange RFs. And when we've done the rockets, when we did the weather balloon, the data seems to suggest that the higher up we're going, the stronger the signals are getting, which would be opposite of what should be happening, according to the scientists. So, I would really like to drill down and go higher, figure out a way to put equipment up higher for longer, and get some good data that's not just a few seconds long, like the, you know, the rockets were great, but you're really limited in time as to the sample size that you're able to get. So, I'd like to really look further at the RF signals that we're picking up out there. And then, I'd like to branch out a little bit, and I would like to see us setting up some instrumentation that would allow us to tell, you know, when we're seeing something on the ranch, are we seeing it other places in the Una Basin as well? So, I'd like to branch out a little bit and see, kind of take a wider area and see if we can get a, an idea of just how localized this is to the ranch.
Awesome. I suppose the ideal was, you know, when you done that rocket experiment, what we were all going to hopefully see was the rocket shooting into the sky and then about, you know, a couple of hundred feet up, hitting something, dropping out the sky, and it being like, oh, there's something sitting there. It's got an invisibility cloak or it's hidden, and we just can't see it. But, but yeah, so, but no, but some of those experiments, like you say, they would intrigue you enough, you want to see more and you kind of want to take it that next step further. And again, that ties in with what you said earlier, that these experiments for all, they've got a monetary value, like someone like Brandon. Okay, so if there's something in the first one you do, let's spend a bit more next time in investigating it further. And again, that would be great for season two. So thanks for that question, Ashley. Steven had a question or two questions. Are you aware of the history of different UFO cases? And if so, do you see any patterns with what goes on around the world and what goes on in the ranch in terms of UFOs?
Yeah, so before I became associated with the ranch, this is not a area that caught my interest. I did not spend any time on UFO theories or in the paranormal world. As a businessman, like I said, I didn't even believe in this stuff. Since becoming associated with the ranch, as more and more things have happened on the ranch, then obviously it's led me to reach out and start looking at, you know, do they see these things in other places? I think the Tic Tacs is a very pretty visible one that's come to light recently with the Pentagon releasing the Tic Tac videos and finally admitting that, yes, we're encountering these things. We're not sure what they are. And so in doing that, I've studied a little bit. I'm far from calling myself an expert on any of it. I have, I know just enough to make me dangerous and but I am, I am learning more and I am studying more about it and trying to get myself better versed in what people are seeing in other places. And so then it can help me better identify what we're seeing on the ranch.
Awesome. Stephen's follow up question, I suppose is really going to push for how much you want to answer this. And it's absolutely no doubt going to be more of a guess or assessment on your part. What do you think is buried under the ranch?
All I will say with that is I'm not sure. But the longer that I'm there and the more, the more that I see, the more open-minded I am to the possibility that there is indeed something below the ranch. And I can't help but think that if there is something under there, maybe it's of ancient origin, some type of piece of advanced technology, some type of AI. What we deal with on the ranch, it seems to have an intelligence. I will tell you, I could spend an hour here telling you of specific circumstances when we've had our equipment toyed with. I'm going to use the word toyed. Cameras turned on and off at precisely the exact same moment that we're picking up anomalies. It just so happens that it happens to be the camera that would have recorded that or the instrumentation that would have picked that up. We've seen this enough that the only way that my brain can come up with a logical explanation is that there is an intelligence to whatever it is at Skinwalker Ranch and that it is the cat, we are the mouse and we're being toyed with. So as far as what's being buried underneath, I'm very open-minded now. I would have laughed at that idea just even two years ago. Today, I would say I'm very open-minded to the fact that there possibly could be something buried under the ranch. If there is, I would say it's some type of source of intelligence, artificial or technology, I don't know, but that's my guess.
Awesome. I think Travis does a bit of a line-tracing, doesn't he, on the show? I don't know if this was more for dramatic effect, but definitely if you were going to draw a type of UFO, I'm sure in your top five shapes of alien spacecraft, that would have came out. But again, it is based on seismology, is that the right term, and sending signals under the ground and picking it back up. So yeah, that's pretty interesting. Can I just ask slightly on topic of what you've said, but this is a question from myself before I go back to listener questions. Has Brandon ever had any meetings with Lou Elizondo or Tom DeLong, or anyone at two of the stars that you know of?
Not that I know of, no.
Okay, cool.
He probably would have told me if he had.
Okay, cool. That would be good. That would be a great roundtable to have, I think, Brandon Fugal and Louise Elizondo, Tom DeLong, and a few others. That would be interesting to hear. Interesting and a question regarding the scene that, again, you talked about the alpacas, it drummed up a lot of controversy and you had your own issues with that. The scene in one of the last episodes with the death of the cattle or the cow, it's very much tied in on that episode. There's a UFO in the sky, the cattle's died, an expert veterinarian comes in, and he basically says there's been a massive stress that's came on, that stress-induced pneumonia, I believe is what he says has killed the cattle. But there's no getting away from whether it's the editing or what you guys wanted it to be. The inclination is that that UFO above the cattle had something to do with it dying. What were your thoughts on that scene and incident? Do you think it was a true reflection of what happened?
Yeah, so the official determination from the vet was that it was a rapid onset stress-induced pneumonia. He could tell from... So he was showing us when he was doing the neocropsy that if it was something that had built up over time, there's scar tissue that builds up in the lungs. And there was none of that. And so he said, it had to have happened very rapidly. And it was stress-induced pneumonia. So the cow got stressed. It happened really recently. And so that's... And you know what? Here's the thing. This is the tough thing about the ranch, is there's a million things that happen. So cows die every day on ranches. That's cows get pneumonia every day and they die. There's nothing strange about a cow getting pneumonia and dying. That's just part of ranching. But then on the other hand, you have to start saying, okay, that's the current train of thought. But what stressed the cow? What was it that made that cow get stressed enough that it caught pneumonia? Other stress-induced pneumonias of other ranchers, we say, oh, that happens all the time. Well, maybe we need to look a little closer and say, why does that happen all the time? Are there RF signals that their bodies are susceptible to that stressing them and causing that? Why are we seeing this? Sometimes things become so normal that we just accept that's just the way it is. That's just life. And maybe sometimes we need to question the, you know, question the answers, question the questions. And so because it is on the ranch, then that is naturally our question. Was this just a regular death and nothing strange about it? Or was there more to it? So when we start going back through the footage, and this is anytime we like with this cow, we're going to go back and look at all the data that we have available to us, leading up to this point, and see if we can figure out and understand what stressed that cow. If it's that a dog was out there chasing it, well, that explains it. There's nothing strange about that. So as we're looking at this footage, there's this object up in the sky. Now, the reason why that object, I think, merits further investigation is for two things. You could have a fly literally walking across the lens of your camera that could look identical to that. We've seen it a million times. With our cameras, it's really hard to gauge depth perception. How far away was that object? This particular object, at one point during the video, it appears, and Eric's still doing further post-processing, but it appears to us that the object disappears behind the tree branch and then comes out the other side. That's important because a fly would be in front of the tree branch, not behind it. Well, then that takes it to the next step, and if we can prove absolutely that that's what happened is it went behind the tree, that gives us an idea on distance. For the object to look that big in the camera and at least be the distance of the trees, we now can start taking measurements that tell us the size of that craft. And the size of that craft, if it's a fly flying one inch away from the screen, that explains why it looks like it's going 10,000 miles an hour, you know, in two frames it's gone. Well, it only went two inches, it was nothing. But if you're talking about a distance out there beyond the trees and it covered that amount of ground, now we could triangulate and we can see that that, for it to go that amount of ground, you know, it'd be going like a thousand miles an hour. I don't know of a drone or a helicopter that can go that fast. So that's kind of our thinking on this particular object. The fact that it is above the cow and, you know, in looking at it, there again, we can't be certain, but it does look like the cow's reactions while it's on the ground seem to be corresponding with the movement of this craft. So that is actually, it's not far from what we were seeing. And I'm sure that we got a few head movements and nods and some music in there to add to it. But it actually, when we went back, started looking at the footage, like that was, you know, I think that was edited pretty accurately.
Particularly if it's right, what you say about Brandon being the character he is in general, that he was particularly animated during the scene with London Malton Howe and Travis. And so yeah, no, that's a great answer. No, that's Brandon, that's Brandon. That sounds like that could be a catchphrase on the second season if Brandon's in it more. That's Brandon. So a couple more listener questions. I've got Dan asking, how are your injuries now? Anything, has anything happened regarding your head injury since season one wrapped up? And he also says he's glad that you're well.
Well, thank you for your concern. And I have not had any reoccurrences since the one that we saw in episode two. Thank goodness. And other than that, like I say, I'm in good health. I do have several, it's interesting, like my head is still very tender in that particular spot where it started. So my injury happened March 4th of 2017. And here it is 2020. And three years later, like my, the back of my head is still tender to the touch. And I still get weird sensations in my, inside my head and my scalp that I didn't have them before. I've only had them since my injury. So there are a few minor things, but overall I'm healthy. I feel good. Haven't had any more reoccurrences since that little one that we saw in episode two when we were out camping.
Awesome. It also asks, you've spoken the last episode and you've mentioned on the show as well, that strange events have happened at home and they persist to the present day. Do you care to share any particular stories or details of what seems to have followed you from the ranch to your own property? Yeah.
I will just say that since I started working in the ranch, we've had some not so scary things happen and we've had some outright terrifying things that have happened. My son just a couple of weeks ago, my oldest son, he's 15. My kids think it's cool that I'm on TV. There's a lot of perks that come with the ranch. We were able to go fly in Brandon's helicopter. There's some cool things like that that my kids really enjoy and think it's cool that dad's involved in this project. But that being said, my oldest son came to me just two or three weeks ago and just said, you still feel like it's worth it, dad. You see what's going on here at home and you feel like it's still worth it. It was a valid question. As far as specific instances, I'll refer him to my Twitter feed. If you go to my Twitter feed and I post it, a little video and an explanation about a time that happened with my car. The reason why I'm hesitant to share things that go on at my house is I shared this particular incident about my car and the windows rolling down. It's no different than the rest of the million UFO stories we've been told in the fact that in order for you to accept it, you have to overlook a lot of, for example, my windows rolled down and the specific camera of my surveillance system at my house, before the windows go down, it shuts itself off. None of the other seven cameras that are on the system work beautifully, never even so much as flickered. And yet the one on the front of my house facing this car goes off for a couple of minutes. There's no way people would have, for this to be significant, people have to take me at my word that I didn't go upstairs and turn that camera off, that I didn't just use the key fob and roll the windows down, that I didn't turn it off or walk outside. Like, there's a lot of holes here that I'm expecting people to believe. And the truth is, I don't expect them to believe. I'm simply just throwing an experience out there and saying, this is what's taken place. And as far as being able to prove it, well, I can't prove that my key fob was on my dresser the whole time, or my little nightstand. I can't prove that I didn't go upstairs and turn that camera off. And so because of that, I also can't prove that it happened the exact way it did. All I know is I came home from the ranch. It's a cold morning. It's 11 Fahrenheit below zero here in Roosevelt. My windows are rolled up. I pull in. I come in the house. My key fob, I only have one key fob to my car. I set it down. I was actually showering and getting ready. That's how I know for a fact. I didn't have the key fob in my pocket because I was showering and getting ready. My son comes and knocks on my bedroom door and says, Dad, your windows are all down in your car. The heck? Well, so I go outside and sure enough, the windows are all down. I try to roll them up. I can't roll them up. So I have to run in the house, grab my key fob, run out there, roll them up. I immediately go upstairs to my camera system to look and see how the heck my windows rolled themselves down. Lo and behold, that one camera facing my car went down for three minutes. Now I think it was a three-minute time period that it went down. Now, Eric helped me get into the log of my camera system, which shows every time it's been logged in to, it shows when it's been given a command to stop recording. It logs all of this stuff. There were no, nobody logged in to the system. It'd probably be a very easy system to hack. I'm not saying it's very secure, but nobody logged in to it. There were no commands given to that camera to shut off. It just decided to quit working for three minutes. The same three minutes that these windows rolled themselves down. My car does have, and I learned this from the viewers on Twitter. I appreciate it. I didn't know this, but my key fob, if I hold the unlock button long enough, the windows will roll themselves down. It's a feature that is built into the car. It is made to do that. I didn't know it was there when I put it on Twitter. I'm grateful for the Twitter followers that bring that to my attention. It explains part of the mystery, but I didn't have the key fob on me, so I know for a fact there was no way that key fob button got pushed and rolled those windows down. But then it brings it back. What is it that we see on the ranch all the time? It's the electromagnetic radiation that we're picking up, these radio frequencies. Well, that's all the key fob is. There's a radio frequency to the car, tells it to do that. And then the camera going down, again, another electronic. So, it's possible that whatever has the ability to hit that frequency and make that car do that. That's one example of things that we've seen. The list is long and I've had some things that have been serious enough that I've had to call the authorities, and some things that have terrified my family. So, there's those things that I know are real, and then I tell people, there's also the observer effect. I mean, you go buy a white jeep, and the next day you realize that 10 of your neighbors have the same white jeep, and you didn't notice that the day before, right? Like, we noticed those things. So, before I worked on the ranch, who's to say that I didn't have crazy things happening around me, but I just was oblivious to it. So, I try to take that into account and say, is it that there's really more crazy things going on at my house? Or is it simply that I work on the ranch and now I recognize and observe more crazy things? They were there the whole time, but I just didn't notice them. I, like, there's all these things you have to weigh out and balance and say, what is it? There are several of these serious things that have taken place that I know for a fact. Those things didn't happen before my association with the ranch. So, there's definitely some aspect or element of it. And then you add in the fact that so many people that have visited the ranch go home and whatever it is, this is their words, it followed them home. You know, the hitchhiker effect. I believe in it completely. I believe it's real, but that's just me.
No, awesome. Dan also asked, are you a cat or a dog person?
I'm a dog person. I got two chows. I'm a chow guy. I got a white chow and a red chow.
Awesome. And not to upset anyone, but that's the only answer to that question anyway. So last question from Andy. You mentioned before there, Thomas, about the tic-tac incident and UFOs. What do you think we are seeing in our skies when it comes to some of these crafts? Would you go as far to say aliens? Is that a personal opinion?
Yeah, I'm starting to think it would have to be extraterrestrial. I've always been of the mindset that it was just secret projects with governments, deep state type stuff. But I'm coming more of the mindset that some of these possibly, probably are extraterrestrial.
Awesome. Thank you. And thanks to all the listeners for those questions. So we'll move on to the quick fire round. So Thomas, before we finish up, a bit of a word association here. What I've done for this one is I've got a few different names. I've got the cast on here as well. And if you want to just give us a quick one word, a few words on each, or you can expand your answers, it's absolutely fine. So the first one is Dragon, Brian Arnold.
Good guy.
Brandon Fugal.
Boy. Undescribable, maybe. It's hard to describe Brandon in one word. He's an incredible human being.
Travis Taylor.
Travis is a fun guy to be around.
Eric Bobb.
Smartest guy I've ever met.
Jim Stigala.
So, Jim. So, Jim, for me, is, you know, I have a little, I'm grateful to Jim. Jim's my security blanket, because he's kind of the, when I say security blanket, I just mean he understands my injury probably better than anybody else on the ranch team. So I like having him on the ranch when it comes to my health, because I feel like he understands better than anyone else what happened to me, if that makes sense.
Yeah. Awesome. The next one would be the possibility that there are portals on the ranch.
Yeah, I think, yes. I think it's highly possible.
Okay. Your own ideas or perception of how consciousness plays into all of this phenomena?
I think that cognitive and consciousness is probably the main thing we should be focusing on the ranch. I think it plays huge into it. Matter of fact, you asked me, I think it makes up my personal opinion, is that's what we should be spending our time looking at. But yeah, absolutely huge.
Two more. Robert Bigelow.
This is public or private? He is mysterious.
He certainly is. The last one, I like to end all of my guests with the same one, is disclosure and what is Skinwalker Ranch? What is Skinwalker Ranch's part in disclosure?
Yeah, disclosure is very important. I'm grateful to work on a team. We all have the same common goal, and that is disclosure. And I know that all the gentlemen that I work with, our credibility means everything to us. We're not here. Personally, I don't care about the fame. I'm definitely not getting rich off of this. At least I haven't seen any of it yet. This is about getting answers. And there are enough smart people in the world that if we try to sell a bunch of lies, history is going to show us to be a bunch of fools. And that's not what we want. We want to play a part in this. And I think that Skinwalker Ranch has the possibility and a real probability of playing a huge part, being very instrumental in helping us understand the world around us even better than we do now and helping us gain answers to the, as of right now, the unexplained and some of these unseen forces that we coexist with in this world, whether it be other realms or, you know, just physics that we don't understand yet. And I think Skinwalker Ranch, if we're allowed to continue this investigation, and the investigation is going to happen whether the cameras roll or not. Brandon's committed to this. It's been happening for 3 years before the cameras came. It will continue after the cameras go. And, but I believe the ranch has the potential to be one of the greatest assets in this space for obtaining the answers that everybody's seeking.
So Thomas, it's been great speaking with you. And just before you go, have you got any final words for the listeners, where they can follow you, where they can find you?
Yeah, so I appreciate all the listeners. Thank you for watching. Thank you for listening to the podcast. Thank you for being engaged. I love all of our viewers, whether they like us or hate us. I just appreciate the fact that they're spending time with us, and that they're engaged in this subject. And they can... I am online. You know, I'm trying to change. I've been a very private person in the past, so social media has not been my big thing. I'm working on that. So I'm on Facebook, and I'm on Twitter, and I'm on Instagram. So they can search me out, Thomas Winterton. I think Thomas R. Winterton. I don't remember some of those.
I'll put the links in the bio.
Okay. Yeah. They can check me out online, and I encourage them to go check out what my wife's doing with meditation. It's interesting. It goes hand in hand with what we're seeing at the ranch. Some of this quantum cognitive things, very much into inner energy, and the results that we're seeing with this meditation is massive. People are getting into a theta state of meditation with her process in 45 to 60 seconds, which is phenomenal. So anyways, encourage people to check that out as well.
So do you know something I didn't ask you in the body of the show, but I really meant to. What does your wife thinks happening on the ranch?
My wife is extremely intuitive, very gifted. She has the ability to see and hear things that most people cannot, and has been proven correct so many times that I don't even question her any more. She says that I'll take it to the bank, I'll mortgage my house on it. That being said, she has asked me to never publicly speak about her views on the ranch. So you have to say, that's going to have to just stay with me, but it's interesting.
Joining me on the line now is one of the most anticipated interviews I've had in the short-lived run of the podcast so far. It is one of the stars of The Secret of Skinwalker Ranch, or if you're in the UK, The Curse of Skinwalker Ranch. The head of security, you may know him as Dragon. I have Bryant Arnold on the line with me. Bryant, how are you?
I'm doing well. Thanks for having me on. I appreciate it.
Awesome. I have to ask, do you prefer Bryant or Dragon?
You can call me whatever you choose. That was not a self-given nickname, but it has stuck and it probably rolls off the tongue a little easier than Bryant Arnold does. If you want to call it Dragon, I'm fine with that.
I have to ask, how did the Dragon nickname come about?
That's a question I get a lot. As I mentioned, it's certainly not a self-given nickname. It came about due to, well, somewhat of the previous ownership Bigelow era and some of the security guards that he had out here, as well as some folks that tried to come visit the ranch and were not allowed to be on the ranch and then have an online presence and decided to make up a few interesting stories. I guess the long and short is I'll just walk through it. Previously, Bigelow, during the Bigelow era, he hired former military, special forces, whatever, black ops guys. I don't know exactly who they were, but I guess one of them had code name Dragon. He was known to be rather violent and I guess pretty tough to deal with. So we had some people come to the ranch that wanted access to the property and I couldn't let them do that. We had what turned into somewhat of a heated discussion because many of the enthusiasts feel like because they have an interest in the property, they should have a right to be on the property. But at the end of the day, it's private property. My job is to maintain the scientific integrity of the ranch and make sure that we don't have any undue liability or injuries or anything like that because it's a dangerous place on its own regardless of any type of phenomenon that's going on here. So anyway, they weren't happy. They left. They are online enthusiasts and talked about how they got run off the property by this guy that was belligerent and drawing his weapon and all that, which did not happen. No, I did not brandish my weapon or anything like that. I just basically told them in no uncertain terms that they couldn't be here. And so with that, they started talking about it online and the online chatter went back and forth and then someone chimed into the city. I've heard of that guy. He's a loose cannon. They call him Dragon. And so that bounced back and forth and there are all these stories about me allegedly doing all this crazy stuff to people that were trying to trespass on the property. Well, Brandon, the owner of the property, being a friend of mine for 30 years, got wind of this nickname and thought it was pretty funny and liked it. So he started referring to me as Dragon. And so he would introduce me as Dragon to people that came on the ranch. And production got wind of it and so it kind of stuck. And so that's where I am. It wasn't one of those instances where I introduced myself and said, hey, my name is Brian, you can call me Dragon, or anything like that. It just kind of evolved and now it is where it is. But you'll never hear me refer to myself as that when I introduce myself. But I'm okay with it. People want to call me that. It's recognizable and I'm all right with that.
Listen, as far as nicknames go, and that's a cool story, it's not a bad nickname to have. And I do appreciate you referring to people trying to go on the ranch as enthusiasts. That's a very diplomatic term. So, yeah, so you've kind of touched on it a little bit, but what I'd like to know is what was your journey that led you to eventually working on the ranch? I know you've got a long friendship with Brandon, which I'm guessing has played a massive part in it, but if you talk us through the backstory.
Yeah, so honestly, you know, I grew up in Utah, not out, not here in the Uinta Basin where the ranch is located. And I had read a few little things in some books I'd read about, you know, haunted Utah and places in Utah that had interesting things. So I'd heard a tiny little bit about Skinwalker Ranch, but, you know, it wasn't something that I was terribly curious about, but I'd heard about it. And then in 2016, as I mentioned, Brandon and I have known each other since we were about 19 years old. Brandon came to me and told me that he was, you know, thinking about purchasing this piece of property known as Skinwalker Ranch. And, you know, I had to go back in the Rolodex of my mind and be reminded as to exactly what Skinwalker Ranch was. And knowing Brandon the way that I do, I mean, this is an individual that doesn't even own a pair of jeans. You know, he's dressed in Armani suits and $300 shoes and all the time. And my question to him was, so you want to buy 512 acres out in the middle of nowhere, a ranch for what? And so he told me a little bit more about it and gave me a little bit more of the backstory on the ranch and the opportunity there. And so I helped him a little bit with looking into the prospect of purchasing it and what some of the logistics and things like that were. And so I said, well, what is this for for you? And he said, I just want to see if any of this is real. I mean, I think honestly, as kind of an agnostic to the whole topic, I wasn't necessarily a disbeliever, but I had never had any sort of experiences. So I said, well, I guess it looks like a cool piece of property. And if that's what you want to do with your money, you might have said otherwise. And so he purchased the ranch and then he knows that I have a background in the outdoors and weapons and things of that nature. I do not have a law enforcement background or military background, but I have taken personal and private security training and have done a little bit of work like that for him in the past in other venues. And so he asked if I would come out and take a look and see what it would take to secure the place and what the logistics of something like that may look like. And so in the beginning, it was just kind of that. And we looked at the infrastructure that was left behind and it wasn't very good.
The front gate when Bigelow had it was pretty much just a cattle gate, a cattle guard with a padlock around it. So we contracted to get the front security gates that people have seen images of, put in and working with Thomas and Jim Morse to be able to get the public right of way that actually ran through the property. A lot of people don't know there was a public easement right of way that ran through. And when Bob Bigelow owned the place, he just shut it off illegally and kind of had his armed guards out there, making sure people can't get on. So we went about it the right way. We got that easement taken, made it no more public access and things like that. And then as time went on, more and more interest came to be and he invested more and more in the science of the place. And my role as kind of just an advisor morphed more into head of security as well as helping with the day-to-day operations on the ranch. I guess my technical role is the head of security, but I help with all sorts of things ranch associated with. It's pretty much myself, Eric Bard and Tom Winterton, that are kind of the brain trust along with Brandon that handled the day-to-day operations on the ranch.
Awesome. What was a 19-year-old Brandon Fugal like?
He was always been a very driven individual, but look, the way that I describe Brandon, to me, he's the same 19-year-old kid, and I've, because the way that he, you know, he's old, he's extremely successful. You know, he's a giant in his industry and has made an incredible name, as well as, you know, substantial estate for himself. But to me, I always describe him as, you know, the most successful 17-year-old kid that I know, because, you know, he's so heart-driven, he does a lot of things on emotion, and he likes to have fun. You know, he's not one of those types of people that is strictly driven by, you know, money and wealth and everything like that. He does, you know, things like Skinwalker Ranch, or, you know, likes his cars, or likes adventures, loves music, all that different kind of stuff. And so he's still, you know, he's extremely, he's been one of those people that once we got to know each other and understood each other, he's one of those friends that I know will do anything for me and knows that I'll do anything for him. And it's been, you know, an amazing relationship to build, but yeah, he was just that same, you know, enthusiastic, interested, you know, inquisitive, fun loving individual that he is today.
Awesome. He seems a very genuine guy on Twitter. He does a lot of charity things and he puts up pictures that kids draw of him and things like that. So yeah, he seems really cool.
Yeah, no, he is. He is, you know, people look at him and they look at his success and they, you know, try to. Make their own assessments of who he is and what not. But I'll tell you, he is extremely loyal individual, he's a very genuine individual. And yeah, a lot of people would shy away from him, but he engages with people on Twitter and other social media outlets. And at the end of the day, he truly does want to share the information because for so long, it was stories and everything was kept close to the vest, and we really didn't inherit any information. We inherited stories, and we inherited sort of a narrative and a backstory as to the ranch. But as far as any hard data or findings or anything like that, that's to this day has still been sealed away at Bigelow Aerospace. And so we kind of had breadcrumbs that we've had to kind of chase around to do our own type of investigation. So yeah, he's dedicated to Skinwalker Ranch, and he's invested a lot in both the infrastructure and the people and the equipment and everything that's here. And he truly does. He wants to get to the bottom of what's going on. And in doing so, isn't looking to just keep it in his pocket.
Yeah. And that's benefiting the rest of us. So you've touched on it very slightly, but what was your previous knowledge of the ranch and the myth and the lore behind it? You say you grew up in Utah, but maybe not necessarily near the Uinta Basin.
Right. So yeah, I knew very little. There was a book, I don't know when it was written. In fact, Brandon probably was the one that gave it to me. And it's called Haunted Utah, that talks about interesting and strange places around within the state of Utah, whether it be paranormal, supernatural type of things. And so I read, it really consisted of maybe one or two chapters or a single chapter within this book. So I knew a little bit about it with that, but that was about it. I have spent a lot of time in the Uinta Basin on hunting and fishing trips and camping and spending time in the outdoors, which I enjoy. And so you've heard stories of UFOs within the Uinta Basin. But as far as the ranch itself, I didn't have a really strong back knowledge of it. And so once Brandon purchased it, obviously I wanted to know more about what it was that we were dealing with or that has allegedly we've been dealing with on this property, or that they had been dealing with on this property. So I picked up George Knapp and Colm Kelleher's book, The Hunt for the Skinwalker, and I read it. And it was interesting and fantastic, and had a lot of really amazing stories in it. But again, as I mentioned earlier, I was more of an agnostic when it came to the subject of UFOs and paranormal activity, because I really hadn't experienced anything for myself in my life. But again, I also call it a religious background, whatever. I always felt that we weren't alone in the universe and that there was more life out there than what we just knew as a human race. And I'd seen various things on television and the internet and so on and so forth of other people's experiences. So, with that, I think it helped me because I came into the ranch with an open mind. But I also was not going to take any little thing and try and become part of a narrative until I actually had my own personal experiences. Because first off, my main job is to make sure that the people that are here are safe, that the equipment stays safe. And so, if I'm always jumping at every twig that breaks or peering at the sky looking for something to happen, that takes away from that ability. And I didn't want to fill my mind necessarily with all sorts of things that would hamper my ability to do that. But again, if I have an experience, then I know that it's something that I will 100% stand behind and I know that it will be genuine and true because I'm not just going to start making stuff up just because I happen to be associated with a place that has a history of that.
Awesome. So you've mentioned a lot about the outdoors and your love of nature and camping and I believe you're an eagle scout as well from the background that I checked out.
That's correct. Yes, an eagle scout.
So would Dragon or Bryant, before you got involved with Skinwalker Ranch, would you have spent a month out in the middle of the ranch yourself at night comfortably not expecting any kind of strangeness to go on? Or would you still have had a bit of a trepidation as to possibilities? I don't mean like the ranch wildlife and mountain lions or whatever else might be out there.
Well, you can't help it because you hear stories and your mind is the most powerful thing that you have for good and for bad, let's say. In the beginning, because it took a long time for me to have any kind of experience on Skinwalker Ranch. But even just the ranch itself, it can be a bit of a creepy place without all the lore. But then you mix those stories in that you hear about portals and these dire wolf creatures and all shapeshifters and the whole score, the whole lore of the Skinwalker and everything like that. Sure. I definitely would have had some trepidation of being by myself for, say, like you mentioned, a month time camping out in the middle of the ranch, given that back history. Now, if it was just a piece of property that I didn't know anything about, then I probably wouldn't have had a problem with it because I enjoy time in the outdoors like that.
Okay. And you mentioned before you had an experience on the ranch. So was your first experience before the camera started rolling? Yeah.
It had a couple of small experiences prior to that. I mean, I've had a lot of times where, I mean, I guess you could call it an experience, but not necessarily seeing something. There are times the ranch feels almost like, it almost feels like a place that has a bit of a split personality, if you will. I don't know if that makes sense. But some days on the ranch, it is the most peaceful, amazing place. I feel like I'm in the middle of an old Western movie. The sun is shining and you've got the mesa in the fields and it just feels amazing. And I'm just taking in the outdoors and there's other times where I'll go to certain places or there's certain days on the ranch where all the hair on my body will stand on end and I just get a really dark and ominous feeling, almost a sense of, call it, interfere or danger or a darkness or just a bad vibe, I guess for lack of a better term. And so I generally will try to remove myself from those areas during that time. Some people say, not me, I would go poking around looking and see what's happening. But given what's happened with Thomas and his injury and some of the other things, yeah, it's interesting because some days I feel great, other days I want to get the hell off of the property as quickly as possible, just because of a feeling. But as far as experiences go, there was, when I'm here working, I stay on-site. In the command center, I have a bedroom that's set up for myself, and so I was spending the night and was wide awake. I was actually just fiddling around on my phone, passing the time before I went to sleep. I was the only one around and all of a sudden, I was laying in bed and it was if somebody came and need the side of my bed, shook the entire bed as if people have children, their kid will come up and knee him in the side of the bed or jump on the bed and it shakes the bed and startles you. That happened, shook the bed and that was so strange. I couldn't figure out, so I got up and walked around to see if anyone was there. There was absolutely no one there. It was a calm night. It wasn't anything else that really could have happened. Obviously, that night's sleep was a little bit less peaceful. I had that experience which made me stop to think. Because you've heard about, if you've read the stories and things, people talk about almost poltergeist-ish type experiences that they've had. That made me wonder. There was another experience that I had when I was actually assisting Eric Bard, our principal investigator, with some scientific thing. The Bigelow folks left behind their old cameras. They had these kind of fisheye-type cameras that they had secured to some of the power poles out. We were getting funny reflections off of them, these glares and things that was messing with some of our own equipment that we installed. Eric asked if I could go and remove a couple of those cameras off of the poles. I went out to the field where one of those was mounted. It was probably about 25, 30 feet in the air, so I had an extension ladder, an aluminum extension ladder, that I leaned up against the pole, and I had a reciprocating type saw because the old bolts that were holding them on, I had to cut them off. I climbed up the ladder, everything was fine, and I started cutting away on this camera, on the bolts that were holding this camera, and it makes quite a vibration and things like that. So I stopped, and all of a sudden, the ladder that I was standing on started to vibrate almost as if in response to the vibrations I was making. I thought, that's strange. So I put my hand up on the wooden power pole to see if it was just something coming through the power lines or something like that, and there was no vibration there. It was just strictly the ladder that was touching the ground that was vibrating. And so it stopped, so I started cutting again, and as soon as I stopped, then almost as in response, the ladder started vibrating again, but the pole was not. I don't know where it was coming from, the vibration reverberating up through the ladder, through the ground or something like that. But that was another one of those experiences that I would consider strange and unusual for me. But that, and aside from some of the feelings I felt, that was the extent of it. I used to actually joke saying that if you want things to happen on Skinwalker Ranch, you better not have me around because it seems like whenever I'm there, nothing happens and I would be there for weeks at a time, and then I would leave for the weekend and all of a sudden, we'd pick up a whole bunch of things on our camera, our surveillance, whatever, and people would talk about seeing things, and then I'd come back and the place would go quiet again. I even joked with the production company when they first came to us and were talking to us about the possibility of doing this docu-series on the ranch. I said, well, are you sure you want me to be a part of this? Because it seems like nothing happens when I'm on the ranch. That had been my experience leading up to, but then during the filming, and those of you that have watched and yourself, when we were firing the rockets and we saw what I would consider UFOs and show up, you could tell it really shook me. It actually had almost a physical effect on me because my mind was racing, because I couldn't make sense of what I was seeing. It's unfortunate that we didn't get better footage of the main UFO that I saw. But to this day, I will take it to my grave. I know what I saw, I know what I felt. The cool thing was that I had other witnesses there. We did get some footage on camera, and we had the cattle that reacted the way that they did at the time, as well as some of the instrumentation. But that's definitely, that experience is the most profound one I have had here on Skinwalker Ranch.
You know, I won't jump ahead too much, but that's something I'll talk about, is when you see the UFO, and I've actually got it in my notes. Myself and a co-host, Dan, that I have, we do a Skinwalker Watch Along, where we basically watch each episode in real time, and we make notes about it and discuss it as it's happening, and just kind of talk about it. And do you know what? Great numbers and people love it. And on that episode, we noted how you looked so excited, like a kid, that you'd saw a UFO, and you genuinely seemed like, you know, on these shows it can be, and I'll touch on this later, but overly dramatized at times, and the music comes in and it's sort of for effect. But you could tell it was really genuine, the way you were reacting to this thing in the sky. And like you say, that it's typical UFO, UAP footage of a bloody object in the sky. And it's always different when you see it with your own eyes. But what was it like that we didn't get to see then on the actual episode? Since we've touched on it, I might as well talk about that point now.
Yeah. So, I mean, you are right. It really was, it was an exciting thing because even Travis Taylor, who had been here just a short time, had had experiences that, to him, someone that came in as such a skeptic, I mean, he told us we were all crazy when we met him because he didn't believe any of it because he has such a scientific mind and things like that. And for him to have experiences, I was a little bit irritated, to be honest with you, the fact that I still had not had an experience. So yeah, it definitely was a genuine reaction. It was exciting, and it was surprising. And I remember calling my family afterward, and they said, you look like you're white as a ghost. Because I had portrayed to them, I just saw a UFO and I don't know what to think about it. But yes, going back to your question, so after we had shot the rockets off, I looked up kind of in the horizon about Mid Skyline, and it looked like, with the production, you have drone operators that fly drones around and things like that. And at first, I saw something appear, kind of like a darker silhouette, that at first my mind, because I try to think in the rational mind all the time, appeared to me as if it was a drone in the sky. And as it moved and got closer into sight, well, first off, I looked over and I saw that Anthony, our drone operator, was holding his drone in his hand. So I knew that it wasn't the drone and I said, what in the world is that? And you kind of saw everybody say, what is that? And point. And so what it appeared to me like was at first somewhat of a dark object. And as it got closer in sight, it either turned or the way the light reflected off of it, it glinted really bright as if it was putting off its own type of light or if it was a metallic object that was reflecting the sun's light. And it turned and it kind of had that somewhat of an oval type shape to it. And it stayed in one spot for a matter of four, five, six seconds. And at one point it turned and glinted extremely bright. So it became very, very illuminated. And then it just sat there and slowly, almost as if it shrunk down to a speck. And then either disappeared or went somewhere or went, but almost like it shrunk down into a speck and then was gone. It's hard to explain. Here I am making all these hand signals and I know this is a podcast trying to explain what I saw. But it definitely made an impact and it wasn't just a little white spot in the sky moving around or anything like that. It had a little bit more of a craft type shape to it, to me, to my eye and to some of the other witnesses as well. I asked some of the production people to draw a picture of what they saw, because some of them turned around and saw it. What I described was pretty much what they saw as well. That helped me realize, look, I wasn't just seeing this in my mind's eye or something of that nature. It was definitely something tangible that I had seen. With that, again, my heart rate was racing, and my blood pressure went up, and I got the sense of almost being motion sick. I don't know if the scientists speculate whether that was the electromagnetic anomalies that we were measuring at the same time, or if it was just personally, I think it was an adrenaline rush and my own mind and body reacting to something that I really didn't have. But an explanation for that made tangible sense.
Absolutely. It was a very cool moment as well to be caught on camera. So jumping back slightly then, what was your day-to-day life like before the camera started rolling? So it was yourself, Jim Morse, Thomas Winterton and Eric Bard, am I right? Before all the rest of the crew joined. So what would your day-to-day life be like without the cameras there?
It's pretty much, you know, this is a working ranch and, you know, there's a lot of interest in the place too. So, I mean, my day-to-day consisted of obviously patrolling the perimeter and, you know, making sure that we don't have a bunch of trespassers. So that as well as, you know, at various times there are visitors to the property. Plus we do have caretakers that live on the ranch as well. And so, you know, making sure that if we do have guests, that, you know, they feel comfortable. And so, you know, I would follow them around and, you know, show them around. And then a lot of my time is spent helping Eric, you know, installing equipment and managing the equipment that we have here, as well as helping Thomas with, you know, the miscellaneous things that he does on the ranch. He's an amazing, I mean, the amount of work he has put into this property is nothing short of amazing. And so, you know, sometimes you need an extra set of hands and, you know, help with that type of things. I helped with procuring the vehicles that we use on the property. And then, you know, a lot of what I do is I'm constantly keeping Brandon updated on what's happening on property. And, you know, the goings on because he and I are, you know, friends first and foremost, and he trusts me that, you know, I'll make sure that every he's up to date on everything and that, you know, things are taken care of. But, you know, it's a lot of long days, some boring days of just, you know, cruising back and forth in the vehicles or on foot or whatever it may be. There's a lot of exploring to do, which has been fun. You know, we found some really neat places and things on the ranch. And, you know, I guess just pretty much doing whatever needs to be done, taking care of whatever needs to be done. But, you know, definitely a lot of time boots on the ground and spending a lot of time checking out all different areas on the property and things of that nature.
Awesome. I will back up how much work Thomas Winterton had done because that was the first thing I discussed with him was, you know, what as a ranch superintendent and what kind of stuff did you do? And he almost listed off everything he'd done in setting things up on the ranch. And I was amazed at the cabling that was laid. And, you know, and like you've mentioned, what really surprised me was how run down the ranch was when Bigelow left and how outdated the equipment was and things were just rotten and just left. So that surprised me that it was left to just go that way towards the end.
Yeah, I think for the last several years, you know, three or four years, I don't think that he, I mean, he he staffed it with a couple of security guards. And then they had the older caretaking couple that was here. But, you know, I was I was surprised as well with basically what we inherited was an old double wide trailer that was, you know, not very well equipped or in very good condition and, you know, and old equipment and things like that. And and I don't know if it was just a matter of, you know, he'd gotten what he wanted out of the property and then finally decided that, you know, he'd had enough or what it was. But yeah, with without Thomas Winterton, this I don't know how we would have gotten the place to where it is. You know, a lot of kudos definitely go his way. He's he's really talented and he's a hard worker. So, yeah, we're grateful we have him.
So just to segue into talking about the show and the production crew arriving on the ranch, did you prefer the ranch without the TV show being filmed? Or what's what's your preference?
So it's kind of as far as how much extra, I guess, I know, complications and, you know, and things there are to do with the ranch. It was definitely it's definitely simpler without without production on site. There's no question. I mean, we're talking, you know, a crew of over 30 individuals that, you know, you have to look out for and make sure that, you know, they're staying in line with what they should be doing and that, you know, they're taking care of and everything like that. So it definitely complicates things. It makes it a little more difficult when, you know, you want to be able to go about your normal duties and you have to be quiet because someone's interviewing somewhere or because something else is going on or, you know, with Travis wanting to try about 50 million experiments and try and, you know, keep up with that sort of thing and everything else. So it definitely complicates things. But on the other side, as I think Thomas mentioned, it's interesting when you bring new people onto the ranch, the ranch seems to kind of liven up a little bit. And whether it's a curiosity thing, whether it's an energy thing, I don't know what that is, but definitely more events start happening and there's more life on the property when it comes to the phenomenon or whatever it is that you want to call it that is associated with this place. And plus, it's nice to have new people around too. It can get a little bit lonely at times out here when it's just yourself or yourself and one other individual or just you and the dog. It was nice to be able to have more people from different places to add different ideas on things as well as to get to know. And we've been really fortunate. The production staff has been really good. They've been very, very respectful and a lot of them have become close friends. And Travis is one of those. I know that the way that the television show kind of portrayed our relationship a little bit, it was a little bit adversarial because he had his ideas. I had my mandates and the things that I was told weren't going to happen when we were on property and we kind of butted heads. And it made it look like we didn't like each other, which actually is very far from the truth. Travis and I have become very, very good friends. We have a lot in common just from just our core, who we are and what we enjoy and things like that. And we communicate on a weekly basis and get along great. So from that, I'm grateful I've made new friends and had great experiences with these people that I otherwise without a TV show would have never had the opportunity to associate with a lot of the folks that were brought on to the property. And Travis included, he's a dear friend and I think we'll be friends for life regardless of if there's a TV show or not.
So you've ruined my next couple of questions of why do you hate Travis? No, I did have down there and this is something I spoke to Thomas about that it seems a little bit, and this is something I think was fair and I love the show, but I'll always be honest about it. There were times where it seemed like you see it had that. It's a reality TV show in a sense, as well as being a documented scientific study. And there were times where the headshots and the dramatic, again, it's a podcast, but it's like you've made that noise yourself. And some of the headshots, Thomas had said himself, yeah, it was maybe the reaction they're showing was a reaction from two minutes before that comment was made. And it just fits in nicely, but it's something you've got to expect when you're doing that kind of show. They absolutely portrayed you and Travis as having this bit of a button of heads.
And we didn't agree on certain things, and he wasn't happy with the fact that there were certain things he wanted to do that I was shutting down until we got further sign-off from Brandon and things like that. But yes, I can think of one time in particular, and I told the production that they only edited me with my resting bitch face on or scowl or something like that, because there was a time where he was explaining after he'd had that incident in the night when he was awoken in his trailer and things like that, and he was explaining the wormhole phenomenon that he had.
I was going to say the wormhole thing.
The thing about it though is people need to know that that little five-minute clip was actually close to three hours of Thomas, I mean, excuse me, not Thomas, but Travis and Jim Sagala explaining the deep, deep dive into quantum entanglement and all of this crazy stuff. And that shot that they took of me with the most confused look on my face when he said it could be a wormhole and they panned to me and it shows like I'm the most confused individual. No, and that made sense. That was from him talking about, now if I spin a basketball on this side of the court and somebody else spins a basketball over on this side of the court and they're spinning at different rates than the quantum entanglement. I mean, and I was like, what in the hell are you talking about? And so that's why I pulled that face. But yet, because it was, I guess they looked at it as a good shot for that type of thing. That facial expression was edited into that. And look, I make the faces that I make, I've been told I'm very expressive with that sort of thing. But you take three hours worth of filming and you condense it into a five to seven minute clip of television and it's bound to happen, I guess.
Yeah. People like that though, that you've got that honesty and you blow up later in the series because it's something about not having a Ph.D. But I think anyone would get that kind of frustration when you're in there with all these really intelligent people. It's not that you don't necessarily understand the gist of what they're talking about, but when they must go into some of the detail that they do, and it's just like you're talking a different language, you literally might be talking a different language. That must be frustrating because like you say, we see a 30-second clip in Awed Dragons kicking off, but it's maybe been two hours of conversation where you've had to sit, just tapping your pen off the table. Is that more realistic?
Yeah, it is. Yeah, that whole thing, yeah, I had gotten irritated because, again, the big thing is everyone wanted to dig, dig, dig, dig, dig. It was Brandon's mandate to me that because of what we'd inherited lore-wise and what had happened with Thomas and things like that, that that was going to be one of the last resorts. And so when one of the very first things that Travis talked about doing was digging, it put that... I got labeled the anti-digging guy, and I've taken a lot of heat for it, and that's okay. But at the end of the day, that was me following the mandate of the owner of the property and being willing to be that equal opportunity asshole, if you will, and not be afraid to say anything, just people even, you know, whether they are as credentialed as the scientists are or anything like that, ultimately, the health and safety of everybody falls on my shoulders. And so, you know, I wasn't going to back down from that. And yes, when I blew up and kind of dropped the effing PhD line, if you will, it was because I had tried to get my point across, and I kept getting cut off and then finally was told, well, you know, I want to hear what they have to say, so basically stop talking. And, you know, I'm part of the day to day operations here. I'm hands on. It's not just, and I know that's another question. People are like, why does the security guy even have anything to say? They don't understand the relationship that I have with the owner of the property and what's been asked of me to do. And so with that, yes, I am going to have a say because I've been asked to have a seat at the table. And so when I was trying to get at least my point across and my concerns across and I kept getting cut off, that was when I kind of had enough and it was, it was a long discussion. And, you know, finally I snapped. And of course, they jumped all over that one. You know, in hindsight, do I wish I would have, you know, been a little bit more political about that? Probably so. But I'm an emotional guy. I kind of say it how it is, you know, what you see is what you get. And, you know, for better or worse, that's how it came out.
And for better or worse, it made good TV. And I'm sure the production crew loved you for it as well.
Oh, yeah. No, yeah. They, well, they didn't say anything during the time, but, you know, after the fact, I'm sure that they loved having that bite to put in there. And, you know, I took heat from my mother, who's pretty conservative about, you know, the cursing on camera. But she knows, you know, she's known me since, you know, forever, and knows that I'm kind of that way, if I don't have much of a filter, if you will. And sometimes it serves me well, and other times it doesn't so well.
Listen, I've got to ask, do you feel you've got a role there as head of security and an advisor? And do you feel you've got another role to play as a character on a TV show? And I don't mean that you have to be someone you're not, but do you feel any kind of obligation that the cameras are on, and they may be hard to ignore, so decisions you make could be influenced by that?
I mean, that is a good question. And I tried to just be myself throughout, but it is hard to ignore the cameras being there. You've got several cameras pointed at you, and there'll be times when they want you to repeat something you've said, because someone, there was noise or something like that. And so it definitely does influence some of the things that you say. In fact, it probably helped, or there would have been a lot more bleep outs probably, knowing that everybody was listening and that there was cameras on there. Did it influence me to play anything up or act any differently? I don't think so. I wanted to be genuine as I could and just be who I am. And anybody that knows me knows that that's kind of who I am. And granted, if people would have seen the countless hours of footage, they would have seen me laughing and joking and cutting up just like anybody else does because sarcasm is a big part of who I am. And I enjoy making people laugh and things like that. And there was a lot of that on set because you've got a group of people there and you're spending that much time. But obviously, the production had an idea of wanting to keep it a little bit more serious and a little bit more ominous and things like that. And so that's what came out. So because there were so many, those were definitely genuine reactions and genuine things that I said. But there was a lot of other stuff mixed in there that other people didn't get to see. I've been accused of never smiling and things like that. And I smile a lot, like you can see me.
I have noticed I almost want to make this the first ever video podcast just on the basis that you're smiling so much. And it's probably more than the whole entire series, like just in the first few minutes. But yeah.
And you know, there was a lot of that. And as I said, I enjoy the people that I work with here, and I enjoy what we're doing and things like that. But I do have a role to play. And when the time comes to be able to need to have that come across, then I'll have that come across. And so they chose to basically paint me in that light. I've had a discussion with them and said, hey, you want to take it easy on me. I'm taking a beating here. And you know that, sure, those are all things I said. They didn't make anything up. They didn't ask me to do anything, and I didn't put that on. But that said, it would be nice to see a little bit less of the onry, angry individual as opposed to who I truly am. And so, no, that's definitely a fair question. And what I've tried to do as well is just kind of put aside some of that, because you can't help but hear outside noise about how you're perceived and how you look, because I still want to just be my genuine self. And if that comes across the same way as it did the last season and season two, then so be it. I don't ever want to try and fake something. God sakes, I'm not an actor. You know, I remember seeing, I made the mistake, I've insulated myself for the most part from social media, but the network wanted me to have at least one social media outlet. And so, of course, I used Twitter. And, you know, after watching the first episode, I didn't know what people were going to think. And it was, I'm not going to lie, it was a little rough. It was rough to see the beating that I was taking, you know. I mean, they were not kind, because I was that guy that says no, and who the hell are you? You're just security, let the big boys talk, you know, let the smart people talk, so on and so forth. And, you know, it was a little bit hard, because this is all new to me. I'm certainly not an actor. And one of the tweets was funny, he's like, you know, the show's good, but that security guy is a horrible actor. And I'm like, well, thank God, because I'm not an actor. And so, you know, it has taken me a little bit to get a thick skin and just, you know, take it in context and realize that no matter who you are, there's always gonna be people out there that are want to say something negative. You know, you look, there's not an individual that's been thrust into the public eye that there's not people out, there's no one that is exempt from having, you know, less than favorable things said about them. I've taken the lines, share that, but at the end of the day, you know, it's okay. I stand by who I am, I stand by the things that I said, I stand by the fact that, you know, I do have, really at the end of the day, everyone's best interest in mind from a safety and a health standpoint and the integrity of the ranch. And so if I have to take a beating for that, so be it.
I've got a couple of questions left from my point of view. Then I've got some listener questions that were sent in. And then I'll have a bit of a quick fire round. So something you touched on is relationships with other people on the ranch. Now, someone who plays a very, very, very small part in the first series, but I get the feeling is around a lot more is Caleb, who works at the security. Now, my impression, and you can correct me on this, is that he is there pretty much as much as you guys, like all the time, but just doesn't want to be on camera.
So yeah, it was interesting. Yeah, Caleb is, oh gosh, I couldn't, I'll just say flat out, he is invaluable to the ranch. There is no way that I could do my job without Caleb. Caleb is, he is dedicated and he is, you know, he is just, he's a great guy and he's just one, he's my right hand man, really, at the end of the day. I couldn't do it without him. So Caleb actually, his profession is he's actually a police officer of the local county that is around Skinwalker Ranch. And so, yes, Caleb, when he is not on duty as a police officer doing his, you know, his normal peacekeeping, type duties and various things, then yes, Caleb spends his time, you know, as security on the ranch as well. And, you know, at the end of the day, I think that you will see in season two, Caleb play more of a role as far as, you know, you'll get to know Caleb a little bit better and he'll be more upfront. I think in the beginning with the production, as any sort of, you know, pilot type series goes, you know, this was kind of a trial thing. We didn't know what was going to come of it. It was like, we'll give it a shot and see if it gets legs. You know, they had a set number of individuals they were going to focus on and that they were going to basically, you know, make the central, I guess, cast, if you will, for the show. And with that, you know, Caleb was brought, you know, just to basically function as security. And then, you know, when needed and when he, you know, when he was in scene and had something happen, then, you know, definitely he was fine with being on camera. And so, I think it'll be fun both for me as well as Caleb, as well as, you know, the world out there that's watching the show to get a little bit, to get to know him a little bit better and see what he brings to the table because he is, he's, you know, he's a smart, really smart guy. He's a former US. Marine and, you know, is currently, you know, a deputy sheriff of the county around here has made incredible, has helped us so much because he's helped a lot with the Bureau of Indian Affairs, police officers, you know, because they have to work together on a lot of cases to where, you know, we have great cooperation with them. And, you know, he's great when someone comes to the gates and is belligerent, you know, he can get on his police computer and find out based off of a license plate that we pick up and, you know, we can make sure that that's taken care of. And then we hope that it never comes to that. But if there is a case where, you know, someone does have to have law enforcement brought in or, you know, force used against them, it's nice to know that we have someone that's, you know, a police officer that we can have right there on site to take care of it without, you know, having to get either any of us in trouble or make it, you know, escalate into anything more than that. So, yeah, Caleb is, Caleb's great and it'll be fun to have the world see a little bit more of Caleb going forward.
Now, that's good to hear. So, talking about some of those enthusiasts that you mentioned before, what are some of the most common security breaches that you get? I mean, what's the kind of worst stuff that you maybe could talk about has happened on the ranch? Just for a bit of background, why I ask is that Thomas Winterton mentioned that people don't realize when they try and sneak on, there could be some area of study where they're in the middle of two or three weeks worth of an experiment, and someone running across a patch of land or just breaking in, totally ruins all the data, and they have to scrap it and they don't realize it. So that's where I'm going with that one.
Right. So, as I mentioned, this property is pretty vast. It's 512 acres in rural Utah. And so with that, it's impossible to secure a perimeter of that size. I mean, you can't put fencing all the way around. I mean, we have barbed wire fence to keep the cattle on and things like that. But if people truly want to get on the property and trespass, then they can do so. And so, the most common instance is, yes, people will sneak on, either they'll come over the top of the mesa, which is a big, you know, flat plateau there, where you can hike through and around, or they'll come from some of the other sides. You know, most people, most of the enthusiasts, if you will, are exactly that. They'll come to the front, you know, there's a turnaround area where we have a big stop sign that says, you know, don't proceed, or they may get brave and come down to the gate and snap a photo of themselves in front of the gate and things like that. And at the end of the day, we know that that's just harmless enthusiasm and excitement for the place. But it's those that come on the property and they'll start shining flashlights on our cameras and our equipment, or they'll flash laser beams on the mesa and, you know, various things like that, or they'll come trampling through. And again, you know, Eric has set up so much equipment that measures everything from vibrations into the ground down to a finite degree so that we can tell and we can coordinate with other equipment to see if there's, you know, something actually actively happening, or if, you know, it's just, you know, just normal movement of the earth or normal lights in the sky and things like that. And so the amount of data that has to be poured through to pick out what is, what it could be a snowflake blowing through the wind on infrared that looks spectacular, by the way, it really does, to vet that all out. So something as simple as a flashlight shining as a spot on the Mesa where we've had actual times where, you know, we've had luminous objects in the sky or the Mesa itself has glung. To try and weed through that and determine what is, you know, human interference versus something that we need to delve deeper into and try and study and see if we can figure out what's causing that to happen is a ridiculous task. And it can take weeks on end pouring through footage and files and then ultimately find out that we realize it was somebody on the south end of the property shining a bright flashlight up on the side of the Mesa as opposed to something that, you know, really doesn't have an everyday explanation. So yeah, it really does mess with the scientific integrity of what's going on. It's a living laboratory. And when you have outside interferences and unknown people being on the property and we pick up movement or, you know, shapes or things like that, it really can set back, you know, pouring through that data and figuring out really if it's something we need to further investigate or if we just need to scrap altogether.
Has it gotten worse since the show aired on TV?
Oh, exponentially worse. Absolutely. Yes. Again, you know, we're grateful that people are curious and excited about Skinwalker Ranch. But with that, you know, there are individuals that feel like it because they're a fan of the show or they're an enthusiast about the paranormal or the UFO community or whatever, that that gives them license to try and have an experience of their own, even though it's private property. You know, it would be like me being a fan of a particular sports team, just going to their facility and saying, hey, I'm a fan of Manchester United, so I get to come in here and hang out with the boys, right? Yeah. As opposed to, you know, look, you have to have an invitation. At the end of the day, it is private property. It's privately owned. It's a very expensive place to run with a lot of experiments. And so, you know, just because you're excited about something, you're a fan of something that doesn't give you necessarily the right to be able to go on there. And there's some people that take it to that. And so with the notoriety to show, there are a lot more, we call them looky-loos, if you will, that want to come check it out for themselves and have an experience for themselves. And we'll try to get in in different ways. We've had equipment damaged. We've had people try to break down the keypad to the gate, to try and be able to just drive in themselves and stuff like that. And that doesn't do anybody any good. And it makes it to where the people that are just curious and want to come take a peek will be nice to them. I've had conversations with some great people from all over the country. It's been amazing, people that will get in their car and drive thousands of miles just to come get a glimpse of the front gates of Skinwalker Ranch because they're so intrigued by what they saw on television.
Yeah, and do any of them just want a glimpse of you at the gate or Caleb?
Yeah, there has been some of that. You know, it was, it's been, you know, and like I said, the majority of individuals have been respectful. If we tell them, look, you can't park here and you can't stay. But you know, you're welcome to get out and take a picture or whatever, then, then yes, you know, and it's strange to me, you know, I've had people hand me whatever scrap of paper they have sitting in their car and want me to sign there, you know, sign an autograph or something like that. And, and you know what? I'm happy to do so. I'm not, you know, I'm not here to be an asshole all the time. And, and, you know, and try and drive people. I realized that there is an excitement and an enthusiasm for it. As long as people are respectful, then, you know, I have no problem with that at all.
Yeah. And at the end of the day, you are TV stars, whether you like it or not. You're on TV, but people watch and have to appreciate, you're not the Kardashians, you're there because you're doing a job and an important job. And it's finding that balance, isn't it, as well? So I want to ask, Brandon confirmed a few weeks ago, because we love Brandon when he's on Twitter. He confirmed that season 2 was in pre-production. And he's been hidden all year anyway, which is great because he doesn't keep many secrets, well, not on Twitter, from fans of the show, that it was always looking like a fall October debut, even with COVID-19. So what's been going on in pre-production? What's kind of happening on the ranch just now?
Yeah, it's been interesting. It's definitely different with COVID-19. I mean, we are fortunate here in the Uinta Basin of Utah that there really have been very minimal cases of COVID-19. Our state has different color ratings as far as what the safety level is as far as the virus goes and the pandemic goes. And the Uinta Basin is rated green. So that means that restaurants are open and hotels are open. And we're very fortunate because there are a lot of productions out there. Take the other Prometheus Entertainment production is the Curse of Oak Island. And they can't get on Nova Scotia right now because Canada has shut down and doesn't want the crazy Americans coming across, which I can't say that I blame them. But it has been different. And we've had to put safety protocols in place in respect to that very thing because many of the production people are from different parts of the country, several from California in particular. Everybody has had to have a COVID screening. And we take temperatures every time someone comes on the property. We take their forehead temperature and then ask them the basic questions of symptoms of COVID-19 to make sure that we're not perpetuating anything or causing something that is going to cause problems for not only those of us on the ranch, but also in the outlying community. That would be the worst thing that we could possibly do. We want this to be a positive thing for the Uinta Basin and for the state of Utah. And so with that, we definitely have put safety protocols in place, production. When I'm just doing my duties and I'm around other people, I have been wearing a face covering and things like that. I know that they've had to add extra trailers and things like that that they didn't from the previous year because of the social distancing aspect and everything. So everyone's being extremely cautious. We have two medical professionals that are on call. Ultimately, I'm the designated on-site safety individual. So I have more responsibility now that where if anyone shows any sort of symptom, they come to me and then I get them in contact with our physicians to make sure that it's nothing that's going to cause anybody any harm, both from a COVID standpoint as well as just from being on the ranch standpoint. So it's definitely different. But things have been, it's been a crazy past week with production rolling in and all the pre-production, setting things up. The ranch looks like a different place in some areas because of what is required for this type of a production to be in place. But everybody's been good and we haven't had any bad test results come back thus far. But we're going to continue to screen and we're going to take precautions. You may see, and I don't know, but you may see when we have some of our meetings where we were all crammed into the command center, some of those may take place out on the deck where we can set further apart and things like that. I don't anticipate that we will be wearing face coverings because the microphones and things like that probably won't react well to that sort of thing. But when we're in close quarters, we're definitely doing everything and we have hand washing stations set up all over the ranch and things like that, because we're very sensitive to it, but it definitely has changed things for us. But our hope is that we can get some good footage and have another successful filming season. And in doing so, hopefully, they'll be able to edit it such that we can have a fall release date. I think that's what they're shooting for, because I know the network is starving for content because a lot of things are not in production. And so hopefully, that makes it so that we can maybe do a spring and a fall type of a thing or whatever comes to be.
Yeah, I think for someone whose facial reactions have gained them a lot of notoriety, those face masks aren't going to do you any favors. They might hide a multitude of sins at Travis' theories at times. So that could be a good or bad thing for you on there.
Yeah, you're right.
So last question before I move on to the listener's question. So I was going to ask you, but it seems a silly question, what people can expect in a season two, because the ranch could stay inactive for the next six months. So what do you hope people would see or what are the plans? If nothing happened and you've got that production crew out there, what would they be expecting to film?
So yeah, that's the thing about it. Actually, it's interesting you mentioned that because even going into the first season, my question was, well, what happens if the ranch decides not to play? What are we going to have? We're fortunate on a couple of different levels in that. There is a lot of story to the property itself that I think is very intriguing, both from the Native American standpoint of things, from the past history, and just the general area and the property itself is vast. The first season, you saw a fraction of the ranch, maybe a third of the property, if that, because so much was happening and it seemed like every time we turned around, something was happening, there was a bunch of footage of stuff that we're going to retouch on in season 2 that we never even had time to do because there was only eight episodes. Then when near the end of filming, when we have that cow die, of course, that's going to play into the narrative because of the history of the place and the circumstances of which it went. With that, we had to basically cut out a bunch of, there's a lot of interesting places that we visited on the property that we never really even got to touch on in season one. So we'll have that. Then I think also, one of the criticisms that I think we've all seen is some of the follow-up to some of the things that we did. Because it was like a constant back and forth and it seemed like it was running from one experiment to the other and so on and so forth. I think that we'll be able to revisit some of the areas on the property that we only just briefly touched on that are very interesting to me. That we had some interesting results from previously. We can dive deeper into those types of things. We have some other, we're deploying new equipment on the property that I think will be extremely interesting to people. There are some other things that have happened since filming. I mean, people forget that this ranch continues on with surveillance and activity, regardless of whether there's a production team in town or not. And we had some really neat and interesting and strange things that we captured during the time, during the winter and during time when production wasn't here that we can obviously touch on as well as that. So I think, you know, I think we have a huge storyboard of opportunity. We hope that we have strange things happening when people are here on site and that we were able to capture, you know, things that were as as interesting as last time. But I think that we have, you know, a great backstory and a great opportunity to talk more about the history of the place and delve into more of that type of a thing. If, for some reason, the ranch decides to, you know, that it's shy, if you will. But if history serves true, the way that it has, as soon as you bring a whole bunch of different people in with different attitudes and different energies and whatever it is, the ranch seems to really liven up and things happen. And so I have a feeling that we're going to get more of that sort of thing. But if not, I still think that it'll make for really interesting and fun television for people to watch regardless.
Yeah, I look forward to that. So I'm going to go into the listener's questions and I've got a few. But the first one is actually I'm going to steal a moment of my own show to ask a question from a fan's point of view. Did you or Brandon or anyone who may be there or you've spoken to hear Joe Rogan's podcast from a couple of days ago?
You know, it's interesting you asked that. I actually listened to it last evening when he had George Knapp and Jeremy Korbel on. Is that the one that you're speaking of? Yeah. Jeremy Korbel. So Jeremy is a friend because I met him when he came out and finished up his documentary, The Hunt for the Skinwalker, when they came out and shot a little bit of footage for the tail end of that. And we've kept in contact and he's been a great friend of the ranch. And has been kind to me as well. And so when I saw that he posted that on Twitter, I thought, you know, I'll take a listen. And so, you know, everyone's got their opinion. And I actually respect, well, I respect George Knapp and I respect Jeremy Korbel very much. And, you know, I respect Joe Rogan as well. In the fact that, you know what, he's the type that wants to see evidence of things. And so he and I are kindred spirits in that way to where, you know, as I spoke about earlier, I didn't want to make things up and think that every bump in the night or every, you know, flash of light was an event, if you will, or the phenomenon or something. He wants tangible evidence. And so, you know what, the fact that he says he doesn't necessarily buy into Skinwalker Ranch because the evidence has been mostly, you know, whether it's kept under lock and key by Bigelow or, you know, that a cattle being mutilated can be done by human hands. And it doesn't necessarily mean that something, you know, outrageous had happened. You know, there's strangeness behind that. And he admitted to that as well. But, you know, I'm, I'm fine with him being, you know, an open-minded skeptic about it. And we're hopeful that by, you know, capturing things and more happening and hopefully being able to document those things, that it will help people like, you know, Joe and what would have been myself before being associated with this ranch to see that, you know, there really is something to it. But, you know, it was entertaining. You know, it's always good listening, especially when you've got a couple of people that I consider friends in George Knapp and Jeremy Corbell on there. It was, you know, it was definitely interesting to listen to. And they covered a lot of information on that thing. My head was spinning. I don't know how, I don't know how George Knapp can keep everything straight in his head, because he was just pounding information out there left and right on a myriad of topics. But, yeah, I was fine with it. And again, you know what, Joe has his opinion and the fact that he is skeptical by nature and wants evidence, there's nothing wrong with that. That's what we want. That's what I want.
Yeah. And the best thing, there's no such thing as bad press as there normally so. Well, that's not entirely true. But usually there's no such thing as bad press and he's got a massive reach on that podcast. And if that gets more eyes back on a show, like Skinwalker Ranch from the mainstream, then same as Unidentified that's on History Channel, that's never a bad thing. So, the first genuine listener question is from Kayleen, and she had a couple. How do you perceive Dr. Taylor's more out there theories? Kayleen enjoys your facial expressions when conversations get weird.
Yeah, I'll address the facial expressions. Yeah, I've been told that a lot of times. There's no questioning of wondering how I feel about something most of the time. It's written all over my face. But as far as Travis' out there theories and his thoughts on things, look, Travis is a brilliant mind. You don't have multiple PhDs and multiple master's degrees and work in the defense industry and the aerospace industry like he has without having back knowledge to it. And he also has a very creative mind. You know, he's written a series of science fiction novels and things like that. And so I always kind of gave him a hard time about that because, as I mentioned previously, when we first met Travis, when he was, you know, given as someone as an idea to bring in as a scientist for the television show, he was not the kindest individual when it came to his opinion on things. He said, you know, his words were, I think you all are batshit crazy. And so it's been extremely fun for me and kind of fun to kind of rib him a little bit about the fact that, you know, by the time we finished filming, he didn't have explanations and came. And he was the one that was the voice saying, there is something that we can't explain happening here that we need to get to the bottom of that I don't have a scientific explanation for. And so, you know what, if he has really wild ideas and exciting things, you know what, who am I to question it? If we can even get something out of that and it leads to anything, then I'm okay with it. You know, I don't want to dismiss anybody's opinion about anything, because Thomas has had great insights to things, and I feel like I've had good ideas that have been brought forward and things like that. And so, yeah, I mean, Travis is loud and he's in your face, and he is not shy to share his opinions about things and what he thinks. But, you know, it's fun and he's enthusiastic, and now he's gone from being the biggest skeptic to one that is scratching his own head and can't wait to get back to try and get to the bottom of what's happening.
Yeah, we talk about this on the Watch Along, and myself and Dan noted from Episode 1 how Travis was very much like, there's no such thing as aliens. This can all be explained. You know, we can all go home in a couple of days' time. To about Episode 4 or 5 where he's basically wearing an I Love UFO hat and ready to storm Area 51. He is ready to go because he so turned around. So it was like, if you ever watched Breaking Bad and how over six seasons, Walter White. Oh, yeah.
It's actually probably my favorite series of all time.
So you know how Walter White goes from being a smelled mannered chemist with cancer to being like the biggest, baddest drug dealer on the planet. It's like Travis done that in about four episodes of TV and like 40 minute segments to go from, as you say, the massive skeptic to full blown. Yeah, the truth is out there. Like it was great to watch. So it made for good television as well. And you've sort of touched on this within the body of the interview, but Kayleen also wanted to know, she thinks you've got the toughest position on the team. And she said, have you done much research and an attempt to understand the phenomenon? So maybe even since you've been on the ranch and had those experiences, if you'd looked any more into things outside of what scientific team study?
Sure. So yeah, it can be a difficult position to be put in, just because you're kind of the no guy when you've got a bunch of gung ho excited people that really want to try find things out. And ultimately, if you allow something to happen and people get hurt, that weighs heavy on me as far as that goes. But I'm grateful and happy to do it. But as far as studying, yes, yes, I have. I've talked more with people when it comes to looking into, these are all things that previously I would have never really even thought twice about, but frequency and energy, and the thoughts of my own personal take on, based on the way things have happened on the ranch, it doesn't to me seem like it's necessarily crafts showing up from different planets. To me, the way things manifest themselves and the feelings I get, it feels like almost an interdimensional type of a thing. So whether that's an intelligent such as ours, that has learned how to utilize, whether it's the energy in the Uinta Basin, or if you want to call the dimensional realm is thin here, whether you look at that from a human spiritual standpoint, or another existence standpoint, or whatever it may be. It's made me really open my eyes and look into more of that, and also look for other areas around the world that have maybe had other things, like the things that we've experienced here on Skinwalker Ranch that take place. I think there are more places very similar to Skinwalker Ranch. The difference is a Skinwalker Ranch has been studied more heavily for a longer period of time than really anywhere when it comes to this type of phenomenon. So yeah, that was a great question, but yes, it's definitely made me study a lot more and look into more of just possibilities of what could be happening as opposed to just, okay, the scientists say it's this, so that's what I'm going to go with.
Awesome. Great answer. Thank you, Kayleen. We had Dave from Shadows of Your Mind magazine, which has just relaunched recently and is a free magazine, 60 pages of content. People should definitely be giving that a look. He said, you've seen a lot during your time at Skinwalker Ranch. What do you think would be your threshold point when you would say, okay, this is too weird. Enough is enough. I like that question.
Wow. Yeah. I mean, that's a good question. And I don't know. I don't know that I could say that I have a threshold because I haven't reached it yet. But if I get to the point where I feel like my life is in danger, or if it's going to cause me physical harm, or it gets to the point where it's just something that is causing me to have physical ailments, so I can't care for my family and things like that. That may make me take a step back and say enough is enough. But as far as getting too weird, I haven't seen a five-foot wolf show up and try and tear a calf through a gate. I can't say what my threshold is because I certainly haven't reached it. That one may have to be a wait and see type of a thing. I'm not saying that I couldn't get there because some of the things that have been explained could possibly have happened here. That would definitely make you take a step back. But as long as I'm physically healthy and as long as I don't feel like I'm putting myself or the people I care about in harm, or that it's going to cause me to not have a good quality of life and things like that, I'll just keep going as long as they'll allow me to do so, because I really do love this place. It's my favorite place on the planet. I love it.
Just before you get to that breaking point, I'm sure Brandon would buy you a tank as one last attempt to keep you on-site, keep everyone safe. Yeah, maybe so. Dan is a massive fan of the show and yours. He said, thank you very much for your tireless efforts. Has anything from the ranch ever followed you home?
I'm fortunate in the fact that I'm aware of, I haven't dealt with the whole hitchhiker phenomenon that a lot of people have. I'm grateful because I have children of my own, that it would be awful if I had to expose them to something that caused them grief or fear or harm or whatever. So for me personally, and I'll knock on the wood that's next to me here, I have not had any of that sort of thing follow me home. As far as physical ailments, I have never had anything happen to me on Skinwalker Ranch that has even made me feel sick or bad. Because I've talked to many people that have spent time on the ranch, that have been laid up in bed with an illness that they can't explain for weeks on end. And so I'm grateful that I have not personally had to deal with any of that type of thing.
That's good to hear because we know most famously, no doubt, there's been others, but Thomas not only had the injury and then had a recurrence of it, but he's had the following home, the hitchhiker effect as well with something.
He's had a lot of that. And I don't know if it's because he lives in closer proximity, but then I've heard of people going many states away and having had experiences like that. In fact, I won't give it away, but our own Dr. Taylor has called me with a few interesting experiences, I'll say, back in Alabama. So I'll leave it at that because I don't want to say any more, but it's definitely a thing. And I'm just grateful that it hasn't caused me any sort of trouble on my end of things.
So even the ranch doesn't want to mess with a guy with the code name Dragon. That's what I'm taking from that.
Okay, you can take it from that.
One final listener question again from Dan before we go into the quickfire round to finish off. Now you've been at the ranch for a while, do you feel you or your approach to the ranch has changed or developed at all?
Yes. Yes, I do. Even though I called myself an agnostic, I think I was a skeptic in the beginning to where I was like, yeah, there's nothing going on here because I hadn't experienced anything first off and because of the stories do sound pretty fantastic in nature. So my approach was a little bit more of a cavalier attitude as far as it is what it is, I'll come do whatever here and I can do pretty much what I want, to seeing people that have come on the property with that attitude that are usually the ones that get knocked on their butt or get messed with the most. Case in point, Dr. Taylor, he was pretty cavalier in his attitude as to where he approached the ranch and it messed with him the entire time he was here. And so that plus being associated with more people and getting to know individuals that have been here on the property and having people come on, I do approach it as Uncle Jim likes to say, and Jim Morris we call Uncle Jim. So if I refer to Uncle Jim, that's Jim Morris because he's like everybody's uncle. Is that I do, I think I approach it with a sense of reverence more and an attitude of, I try to put out there the energy or the feeling that I'm here to do a job, and my job is that I respect the ranch and the people that are on it, and I have a role to protect those people. In doing so, I think it has really served me well as far as not having the negative experiences because I think if you want to call it an intelligence, if you want to call it a spirit, whatever you want to call what's going on at the ranch, I think that it feeds off of whatever energy you put out there. And so I try to bring a positive energy. I try to leave all my worldly garbage behind when I enter the gates of the ranch and just focus on what I'm doing on the property and focus on the job that I have to do here.
Well, that's a great answer. And I think for me, again, watching the series back for about a third time now for the show, the Larry Sespich, when he turns up in Episode 6, I think it's Poking the Nest. And just that moment where he says, and I'm not religious in the slightest, but he says a bit of a prayer and he lays down some tobacco and just the reverence he speaks with was really powerful.
And that experience, honestly, it changed my experience of the summer. It's unfortunate that Larry spent more time than just that brief few moments here. And in fact, off camera, because he didn't want it to be filmed, he actually took the time to give each and every member of the cast and of the production crew a Native American blessing with sweet grass and an eagle feather in his Native Ute tongue as kind of a protection and a blessing that good experiences will happen and that the negative experiences will stay away. And it absolutely was one of the most profound and special experiences I had had. In fact, people at the end of when they saw me give him a big hug at the end of when he came and did the blessing on the ground where they wanted to drill and dig. There was a lot more to that because he had, you know, personally, he and I had had conversations and talked about various things that really, to this day, I hold very dear and will cherish for a long, long time. Yeah, that was definitely a special moment. And I hope that we get Larry back and more of the Native Americans of the area that are willing, because there's not many that are, to come on to the property to share that, because I think that that really is a really cool, special part of what of what Skinwalker Ranch is.
Yeah, for me, that was the coolest moment of the show. And he was my favorite cameo of all the people you had in every episode from outside. I loved Larry. So if we could get him back, that would be amazing. And so thanks again for the questions, folks. We did get more than that, but a lot of them have been answered within the body of the interview as well. So thank you very much. So I'm going to move on, just to finish off, dragging on the quick fire round. So I'm actually going to reel off some names of the cast, some places, and a few other topics. And I'm just looking for a word, a couple of words, or a couple of sentences that I'm not precious on each. Just your thoughts on each of these, okay? Okay. So not trying to catch out on anything. The first one would be Travis Taylor.
Enthusiastic and brilliant. And yeah, he's a good guy. Yeah, he really is. He's super enthusiastic and he's very smart. And I guess the last word I'll use is friend. He's definitely a friend.
That's good to hear. Although not too friendly for season two because obviously you two are kind of button heads again in a friendly competitive kind of way.
Hey, you know what? I argue with my friends all the time. So I'm sure that there's probably a good opportunity that something at some point that will happen.
Good. I'm Scottish. That's how we communicate is argument. So that's good to hear. That's right. So the next one would be Brandon Fugal.
Gosh, that one goes deep. Probably one of my closest friends, just an extremely kind and generous individual who is driven beyond anyone I've ever met and is willing to be forthright and straightforward and is dedicated to figuring out and including all of his resources into uncovering or at least getting a better understanding of what's going on at Skinwalker Ranch.
The closest thing to planet Earth has to Bruce Wayne is Brandon Fugal, so I like him. The next one would be Eric Bard.
Genius. Eric personally is probably the smartest person I know. He is absolutely brilliant in so many different realms, and he is a brother. I love Eric, and I think that Eric is the unsung hero of Skinwalker Ranch, to be honest with you.
Nice. Next one, Jim Sagala.
Jim Sagala is a smart man. He's definitely got that East Coast mentality, and he can be a little bit in your face a little bit. He and I did conflict a couple of times, but Jim is also a friend, and he's a very smart man with a lot of knowledge and a lot to add.
Awesome. Next one, former guest of the show, Thomas Winterton.
Tom's a brother. Thomas is one of the hardest working people I've ever met, and is beyond dedicated to Skinwalker Ranch and to the individuals associated with it. There is nothing that I've seen yet that that guy can't do when it comes to figuring things out. If I say Eric's the unsung hero, that's behind the science. Thomas Winterton is the lifeblood of Skinwalker Ranch, and what keeps it up and running, and day to day, he keeps the place going.
Yeah, he's a great guy. Jim Morse.
Uncle Jim, he's just a kind man that can make friends with anybody he meets. Jim's been invaluable to the relations with both the Native Americans and the community, and Uncle Jim is just a dear friend and just one of the kindest souls that I know.
Awesome. Skinwalker Ranch.
Skinwalker Ranch. It is, it's craziness wrapped up in a barbed wire fence, I guess. It's my favorite place on the planet where I, when I'm away, I miss it. But when I'm here, sometimes I want to get the hell away. It is definitely a special place that I think holds some really incredible mysteries or answers to mysteries and questions that hopefully we can get to the bottom of. But it is a place that needs to be respected.
Awesome. The next one would be your thoughts on CE5.
CE5.
So, the contact method for summoning extraterrestrial craft in the sky.
Oh, gosh.
I don't know.
I honestly, I don't have an opinion on that. Honestly, I don't.
Never had any of it tried on the site?
No. No, we haven't.
Okay. Might be interesting.
Yeah. I'll definitely make note of that.
Next one would be UFOs.
I believe in them. I believe in them now. I've seen one. Well, I've seen multiple. And I'll take it to my grave. I know what I've seen. And until someone can give me a better explanation of what I've seen with my own eyes, UFOs are real. And I hope that we can find out more about them.
Second last one would be extraterrestrials.
I would say, you know, to me, an extraterrestrial would be maybe anybody not from our realm. So I think that there's definitely an intelligence at play on Skinwalker Ranch. And so I would say, you know, I don't I don't know if an extraterrestrial is the little gray aliens that everyone thinks and associates with an extraterrestrial. But I do believe that there is other life. Outside of just what we know on this planet.
Yeah, I think more and more of the interdimensional, multidimensional theories coming into play with a lot of what's going on. So Skinwalker Ranch being a big part of that. And the last one I like to ask all my guests to finish on is their thoughts on disclosure.
I think it's I think it's vital. I think that, you know, I know we take the standpoint that we want to share and we want to disclose. And I wish that there was more of that out there. I think that there are a lot of there are a lot of questions that there are already answers to as long as people would disclose that information. So I think that disclosure is important. And, you know, as a human race and a better understanding, I think it's something that more needs to happen on every level of life.
Hi, everyone, and welcome back to That UFO Podcast. As always, my name is Andy, and I'm very pleased to have this guest on for what is going to be the one year anniversary of the podcast. I've had a lot of really cool names on in that time, and all of you listening or watching on YouTube now have made guests like this possible. I'd like to welcome the owner of Skinwalker Ranch, Brandon Fugal. Brandon, welcome to the podcast.
Hey, it's good to be with you. Thank you, and happy Friday.
Yeah, happy Friday indeed. Thank you very much for joining us, and it's great to have a name like yourself on, and the timing is just fantastic. I was just telling one of the producers from History who's on the call with us that my wife is due to give birth on the same day Skinwalker Ranch Season 2 premieres. So it all kind of ties in quite nicely date wise as well. So yeah, let's get right into it. I want to talk about some of the background that's led us to The Secret of Skinwalker Ranch Season 2. Brandon, Season 1 introduced us to the ranch in a more intimate way than ever before. We got to know the people who live and breathe the experience daily. What was your vision for Season 1 as you started to develop the idea? And did it turn out how you hoped?
Yeah, Season 1 was an incredible experience for all of us. And I think it was an unprecedented television experience to show the public behind the scenes for the first time the most scientifically studied paranormal hotspot on the planet. For a property that had been in lockdown mode, that had been secure for over 20 years for purposes of scientific research dealing with the paranormal, for that property to be opened up for television cameras for the first time and filming my team and their efforts and scientific investigation on an hourly basis was something I think very special. And I think it was a unique opportunity to engage the public and to show for the first time very visually what the ranch looks like. What do the old haunting homesteads that lie on the property look like? And what was it like for the team to be able to follow Dr. Travis Taylor for the first time entering the property and seeing through his eyes the incredible striking landscape that has captured so much interest and attention over decades was a unique opportunity for all of us. And to do it in an unscripted way, I think it's important to note that this is real. It is a 100% true fact and not one of the participants, with the exception of Dr. Taylor, had ever been on television, ever really had the intention of being involved with any type of television effort or media. And so it was a new experience for all of us, including myself, to allow cameras and to allow for the first time the story to be told regarding the on-going investigation at Skinwalker Ranch.
Now, I'd like to touch on that story you mentioned. So Ryan Sprague of Somewhere in the Skies had a great interview with you just a couple of weeks ago now. I would encourage people to go and listen to that. He'd done a great intro package, which he sets things up wonderfully and discusses the background of the ranch with the Shermans, Bob Bigelow and even more. Now that's been done and I would encourage people if they want to hear that detail to go and listen to that interview. But could you just summarize, Brandon, how you did come to be involved with Skinwalker Ranch?
You bet. I acquired the property in 2016 from elusive aerospace billionaire Robert Bigelow, Bigelow Aerospace, after really being introduced to the property through some scientific advisors that I had worked with a decade ago on a research project in Utah. Those advisors that unbeknownst to me had been science advisors to Mr. Bigelow, reached out to me in 2015 with the potential opportunity to engage, to meet Mr. Bigelow and discuss a potential joint venture or acquisition that would open a new chapter in the investigation and really pass the stewardship from Mr. Bigelow to someone else, to in this case, of course, to me in order to continue the research and advance the project that had been funded by not only Mr. Bigelow, but the United States Government and the Defense Department for decades. To take a very unique, secure piece of property that had been the center of gravity for a Pentagon-funded black budget program was a unique opportunity for me, but I did buy it as a skeptic. I bought it as someone who had not seen a UFO or a ghost or an orb and was approaching the property as someone who believed that there was most likely a natural prosaic explanation for what had been reported there. So with that, as the understanding, I closed on the property, escorted Bigelow security off the property, and brought in my own security detail, led by Dragon, that you see on the television series, and a team of scientists, a multidisciplinary group of professionals that would bring, I think, a new focus and energy to the site and to the investigation, and to have this unfold in real time for the general public, to see, has been a very exciting opportunity.
Now, you seem to have surrounded yourself with family and close friends on the ranch. Your brother, we see as a pilot on the show, and a few episodes in Season 1 and in Season 2. Brian Arnold is a childhood friend. I spoke to Dragon on the podcast now last year, and he spoke glowingly of you, and just how honest and genuine you are, which of course he would as a friend, but he was really nice and same as Thomas Winterton as well. Dr. Lee, you brought on in Season 2 who is a specialist in radiation. He has a much fancier title than that, but I'm just going to say specialist in radiation for the listeners, and you have mentioned that he is a close friend of yours as well. Why is it important that you've got so many close friends and family surrounding you on this venture?
Good question. By design, I pulled together a closely held group of individuals that I could trust, that had no hidden agendas that would preserve the integrity of the research, and frankly help us protect the integrity of the ranch and the investigation. You know, Dr. Christopher Lee, who we brought on and feature in Season 2 to be unveiled this next week, is a world-renowned radiation oncologist. He is really at the top of his field when it comes to medical research. And, you know, where we have seen a number of our team members end up in the hospital with serious illnesses, with serious injuries that continue to be unexplained and mysterious, we felt it was important to bring a higher level of attention to the health and safety protocols on the ranch. You know, I also in bringing these close confidants together, I wanted to bring people that came from different backgrounds and different areas of expertise. You know, Jim Morse, who is a ranch manager there, has known me since I was 18 years old. He was my first big commercial real estate development client. When I was 18 years old, I jumped into the commercial real estate business and focused on leasing and selling Class A office developments. And Jim Morse at the time was breaking ground on a signature Class A office park. And through that experience of being engaged with him, we really developed a close relationship that endures to this day. And the thing that he brought to the table was a genuine love for the Native American cultures, the people, the indigenous people, and a track record of raising millions of dollars for Indian scholarships, for American Indian services, and really working closely with the tribes to help them with economic development and other efforts. I feel that community engagement has been a big part of our stewardship of this property and really advancing the objectives that we really set out from the very beginning. But you're right, I pulled together a closely held group of people simply because I wanted to preserve the integrity of the investigation and bring a new level of focus and intensity to it. I didn't bring these people together for a television series. I brought these people together to really launch this stage of the ranch investigation five years ago in service to the truth, in service to discovery, and determining whether there really was any reality and truth to the claims that go back decades, if not millennia, regarding the high strangeness and paranormal activity on this property.
I want to talk a little bit of high strangeness and we're going to talk a lot of high strangeness given the context of the interview, but those relationships that you talk about are never more apparent than when there's a heightened sense of danger. When we look at, bad things happen when you dig, was the name of one of the episodes. I've been very fortunate to see the first two episodes through his 3NE network, so thank you to them. It's really great and I won't give anything away. However, there is again talk of digging, and that always brings up Thomas Winterton's injury that happened some time ago. Now, my co-host, Dan, who you met just before we started recording, noticed in season one, there's a map on the wall of the HQ, and there were three points triangulated. One was the ranch, one was Havana, Cuba, and I believe the other one was Geng Tzu in China. These are reportedly points where other people have picked up injuries similar to Thomas Winterton, and that's something Travis Taylor recently confirmed in an interview as well. One state department-sponsored study has reported these were typically the result of microwave energy attacks. Now, this was reported by CNN yesterday, and the debrief media outlet have reported on this as well today. Have you seen much on that, and is that something you want to comment a bit more on?
We've studied potential correlations and connections with other incidents globally. It would be in trying to assign cause and understand some of what has been observed. We, of course, take a very broad look. I'm not really at liberty to discuss the details associated with what the Defense Department has been studying with those other locations, but I will say this. I think the deeper the people dig, the more mysterious and the more unexplained the injuries and incidents appear. Assigning conventional cause and being able to come up with an explanation that is clear and straightforward continues to evade, I think, even the highest level people involved with those investigations. We see Skinwalker Ranch as a unique center of gravity for unusual phenomena, but we're not ignorant to the fact that there are other places potentially on the planet that may have similar incidents and events that attend those properties. Trying to, I think, discover what correlations may exist and what common characteristics or common signatures attend the phenomena is a key part of our investigation.
It's almost like you read my next question. I was going to ask about potentially other locations like Skinwalker Ranch. Have you ever heard from any other potential owners of sites like Skinwalker Ranch or the Uint-de-Basin, or have you ever reached out to them or have they reached out to you?
Yeah, we have. We have a relationship with a neighboring property that we believe can help us expand the scope of the investigation that is also reported unusual activity. It's very close by. There are other properties that have tried to exploit, frankly, the attention given to Skinwalker Ranch and have tried to draw some type of connection or commonality. And I think that in a lot of cases, how do I say this kindly, there's a lack of real evidence or scientific proof or rigor that has been brought to some of the other claims or the other sites. I find that this, the more time goes by, I find that Skinwalker Ranch really is unique, that in a lot of ways, for whatever reason, it really is a unique center of gravity for the phenomena, and it is very difficult to find another property that is experiencing the same frequency of activity. And I don't say that to sensationalize or to try to prop up the importance of our investigation. I just say that matter of fact, show me another effort globally. Show me another property, another effort, another multidisciplinary team utilizing resources and service to this topic. And I don't think it exists. I think that Skinwalker Ranch right now is arguably the most important science project of our time.
And that's not the first time I've heard you say that, and I would agree. Why for you and your five years of stewardship, you've called it now of the ranch, what makes it so unique? Is there anything you yourself have managed to put your finger on and say, it's the place, it's the area, it's the people?
It's the diversity. I think first and foremost, the property has been in lockdown mode, has been completely secure for now going on 25 years. So to have a piece of property that is a secure environment that has been under scientific study and research, and has been monitored consistently for that period of time is unique. But also, I think it is important to note that the diversity of phenomena that continues to persist on this property, is exciting, and it's somewhat troubling, because it's difficult to be able to identify the origin or the agenda associated with the high strangeness that we are observing and recording. People ask me all of the time whether I believe that we are seeing extraterrestrial or visitation from other worlds or whether we're seeing interdimensional phenomena or whether we're seeing spiritual phenomena, angels and demons and skinwalkers. And the answer, I think, is all of the above. The evidence speaks to the fact that we're not really seeing any one assignable cause or type of phenomena. It is a diversity. And I think there is evidence that points to the fact that we are experiencing all of those potentially on the ranch.
Given your background in real estate, you must have walked into thousands of properties for the first time to survey, to have a look around. None more unique, I'm sure, than Skinwalker Ranch itself. The first time you stepped foot on the ranch, what was it like? And I imagine when someone buys a new home or a new office, they spend a few minutes themselves just surveying it, talking to themselves, talking to the property, just imagining things. Did you ever have that personal moment in the early days where you went out onto the ranch at night or during the day yourself and just spoke to whatever may or may not be around?
Yeah, good question. At first sight of the property, I can honestly say I was speechless. My first, my first tour of the property was coming in via helicopter, via my private helicopter. And I, I came with Jim Morse at my side to inspect the property just days before closing on it with Mr. Bigelow. As we came in to the Uinta Basin and came up on the property and circled the property several times, I found that it was breathtakingly beautiful. The diversity of the landscape, the strikingly beautiful backdrop with the Mesa Plateau that runs the entire expanse of the property with cave systems, the, the old, you know, pioneer homesteads, the, the waterways that run through the property. It, you know, it really is unparalleled in its beauty and its diversity. You could shoot an entire television series like Westworld or a John Wayne, you know, cowboy western movie on this property because it, it, it, it features such incredible landscapes. And that is what one thing that I was completely unprepared for when I first inspected the property was the beauty of the property and, and how interesting and even intriguing the landscape is. You know, for the first number of months of, you know, my ownership and stewardship of the property, you know, I couldn't get over the fact that it was just so beautiful. And I didn't find it haunting or troubling. I didn't find it to be unusual other than, you know, unusual in that it presented a very stunning backdrop for this investigation. But, of course, as time went on, and as months continued, we started seeing things. We started observing things. We started recording strange phenomena that to this day remains unexplained.
Now, George Knapp recently commented, and I'm going to quote this. This is a direct quote from George Knapp. There were multiple attempts at communication during the Bigelow era, putting out certain objects and games to invite a response. It worked, twice. Not sure if Brandon's team has tried this yet, but I have a lot of confidence in the work they are doing. Are you aware of those attempts at communication, and have your team tried any of themselves?
I think it has been publicly disclosed that the Bigelow team, the participants during that era, performed experiments that were unusual, that at times were an attempt to communicate or spark communication with the entities involved with the phenomena. It is often stated that what is being observed at Skinwalker Ranch involves some type of precognitive sentient intelligence. And I think they were focused after years on just communicating with whatever those entities may be. We've taken a very different approach. We've taken a more scientific approach and frankly, one that is grounded in observational science, first and foremost, and have not delved into, I think, some of the more controversial methods of investigation. Now, that doesn't mean that we're not open-minded. That doesn't mean that we aren't inviting people to the property to bring different perspectives, different approaches to the problem set. But they took a very creative approach at times to really addressing the phenomena that we have yet to really employ.
Now, let me ask you, you talk about, you used the word summoning. And that has a lot of different connotations and something that has been discussed quite recently. And as we talk, another article was dropped by the New York Post regarding some comments from Lou Elizondo and people again within the halls of government in the United States that see this phenomenon as being, you know, demonic potentially, which again has a whole range of connotations. And you're obviously a man of faith as well. That's been well publicized and something you've talked about. Is that something that would put you or others working on the ranch off, given your strong faith that you wouldn't want to necessarily attempt that sort of communication? Or is it the danger element that may or may not be involved?
Good question. We're dealing with phenomena that is dangerous. We believe that we're dealing with both malevolent and benevolent entities based on the experiences and the evidence collected. And I think approaching the ranch with a degree of reverence and humility is important to maintaining not only the safety of those involved, but also being able to discover the truth of what is happening here. There's much said about the fact that participants in the investigation in the past have had things follow them home. They've had phenomena that have traveled with them back to their place of residence and terrorized their families in some cases. There are a number of military operatives and former scientific consultants that refuse to ever set foot on this property ever again for the rest of their lives simply because they believe that disturbing events have followed them as a result of their engagement with the property. I take those claims, I take those statements very seriously. And so we're very careful about what we introduce to the ranch. We're very careful with the investigative protocols that we're putting into place and really the nature of the experiments that we're bringing to the table and frankly unveiling to the general public. You know, it's not just instrumented rockets and balloons and ground penetrating radar studies, but it's also bringing in other experts that can help us better understand potentially what is at play, what is at work here at Skinwalker Ranch that will help us advance the investigation. And I think being very careful not to invite or to provoke potentially negative phenomena is something that we are sensitive to.
I've got one more question I want to ask before I get to talking about season 2 of The Secret of Skinwalker Ranch. Now, like we said, you're a man of faith and you've commented on previous recent interviews that your experiences with Skinwalker Ranch have only reaffirmed and made your faith stronger. What are your thoughts on how other religions could potentially integrate any form of disclosure or goings on into their faiths going forward? Do you see that being a potential issue as and when information does come out?
Good question. People ask me all of the time whether what I have been experiencing and conducting at the ranch conflicts with my faith, with my religious upbringing. The honest answer is that I was raised to believe that there are worlds without number and that we're not alone in the universe. I believe that what we're observing at Skinwalker Ranch is actually faith-affirming and faith-promoting in a lot of ways. The idea that not only we may be visited, but also that there are other dimensions of reality just as real that sit just beyond our perception, but that may be interacting with us. I think it's exciting, it's thought-provoking, and it calls into question the very nature of our existence on this planet. Where did we come from? Why are we here? Where are we going? Those time-honored questions that have been asked by people for thousands of years, I think to a degree may be answered through our investigation. What we are delving into at Skinwalker Ranch.
Given the previous involvement with the US government during the Bigelow era, do you feel there are any repercussions or consequences of the upcoming UAP Task Force report potentially coming out? There are obviously a lot of talk it may be delayed. Could that affect the investigation or could that have any bearing on what happens going forward for you?
No. We're operating independently. By design, I've kept this as a private effort. I do not hold any security clearances. We are not engaged with the government or any public interests relative to the investigation. I applaud and support any efforts for disclosure, for informing the public relative to what is going on and really the nature of our world and our reality. But we're on our own path and conducting a very dynamic research study that I believe is focused on results and is focused on getting to the bottom of answering these questions. I don't know that government channels are going to be in a position to either shed light on those topics, at least to the degree that would satisfy concerns. I think our private sector approach is unique and uniquely qualified to bring truth forward and to, I think, reveal the nature of really the phenomena and the core claims associated with these topics.
Now, season 2, The Secret of Skinwalker Ranch, that's what you're here to talk about as well. And I loved the first two episodes. I was a big fan of the first series. This podcast was in its very early days. And myself and my co-host, Dan, we had done a watch along of every episode and we commented and talked about it. And we'll be bringing that back for the new series, but in a review format rather than watching along. Now, it premieres on the 4th of May in the US on history at 10 or 9 p.m. Central. Like I said, I was really fortunate to see the first two episodes of season 2. And it gets right into things. There's no messing about, there's no slow build. It's straight into that high level scientific investigation.
Yeah, we don't screw around. And we are very fortunate to see immediate activity and results. And none of this is contrived. There is nothing faked, nothing contrived. It is 100% authentic and true. And that continues to be the number one priority associated with this investigative series. Present the truth. And frankly, inform the public relative to what we are doing, what we are experiencing with our investigation. I mean, I look at what we are about, what we are ready to unveil in Season 2, and it feels like Christmas Eve. It feels like, you know, we are at a pivotal moment to be able to unveil a lot of new, not only experiments, but also the result of, you know, advancing the investigation that we saw this past year. Again, you probably heard me state that I believe we revealed more in the first 20 minutes of our first episode of really kicking off this series than I'd seen in 20 years relative to these topics in the public domain. And we look forward to continuing to inform the public and really, you know, letting everyone have a front row seat to what we are experiencing out there. It's a, you know, a lot of it, you know, science isn't always exciting. You know, you're not going to have strange things happen at all times. You can't schedule or program the paranormal or high strangeness. You just have to go about your business in a very honest, authentic way and just let things happen as they happen. And I think what you see with the team is a very unprecedented effort to reveal the day-to-day activities and experiences on this very unique piece of property.
Now, I'm keeping this spoiler free for people, obviously. Earlier on, you mentioned waterways, and that plays a part in one of the first episodes. I had to explain to my wife why what they were doing was relevant. And you make a really good point that you are filming an ongoing scientific investigation. The same reason people can't just walk onto the ranch. The same reason there's security fences up for both the ranch and people's personal protection. Now, portals is a word that was used, easy for me to say in a Scottish accent, in the explosive trailer for the series. Now, that's quite an eyebrow-raiser when you hear portals are opening up. Can you give us a little bit of an indication as to what work or experiences may have gone on to do with that?
You bet. If you look back on the history of the property, under the Bigelow era and the Bigelow team's investigation, they had eyewitness accounts of portals opening up in the sky or opening up right above the homesteads, specifically over Homestead 2 and Homestead 3, where various phenomena would come in and out of those portals on the property.
One thing that we've tried to do is investigate whether there is some truth to those claims and whether there are portals on this property and what evidence may exist or what environmental conditions may exist that allow for that type of phenomena to exist on the property. So we bring a higher level of equipment and instrumentation to this Season 2 effort in service, to really delving into whether there really are strange things occurring environmentally that would point to portal activity on the property.
You mentioned various phenomena, and it's got me thinking that people always talk, UFOs, aliens, ghosts, orbs, dire werewolf type creatures. Is there anything that just isn't mentioned, but you're aware of, but people just don't talk about? Have I left something off of that list?
Well, there are orbs, what would appear to be intelligently controlled orbs that appear on the property that have been reported for decades. I think the cattle mutilation phenomena has been real. The fact that animals have been impacted. I mean, in season 1, we had a cow die, we believe, you know, suspiciously, I mean, you know, to take a perfectly healthy calf, and within a very short abbreviated period of time, to see it die from stress-induced pneumonia, and the events surrounding that death to be very, very mysterious. I mean, electromagnetic anomalies, when you have both iPhone and Samsung Galaxy devices that are acting strangely, and then all of the instrumentation reacting to something that was definitely unusual going on, and then to pull up the camera surveillance, and to see an object that appeared in the sky right above that animal as it was dying, it is some of the most disturbing and intriguing activity that has ever been captured on camera and witnessed on this property. I mean, going back decades, the Sherman family, the previous owners before Bigelow had many of their prized cattle end up mutilated with surgical precision in broad daylight, drained of their blood. No blood on or around these animals, yet surgically dissected within minutes. And no conventional explanation. But to see indentations, depressions in the fields of something, some type of craft or object that apparently attended some of these events, potentially just adds to the mystery. I think as we-
Can you have-
No, keep going.
I just wanted to ask, do you have a favorite moment of this second season? Do you have a favorite moment that you can talk about?
Ooh, that I can speak about. Wow. Well, there are so many things that happened during season 2, during filming this past year with the team. You know, one thing that we did that I was not willing to do during the filming of season 1 was we put into service the helicopter and utilizing the helicopter for a part of the investigation. And what we witnessed was stunning. I can't say anything more, but, you know, the trailers, the previews to season 2, you catch glimpses of what we do, everything from more aggressive digging and exploration on property to utilizing laser technology and new innovative ways to investigate the phenomena, to also using our aviation assets in service to exploring what lies above the ranch, as we are also investigating what may lie below the ranch, is really key to elevating the nature of our investigation, and it sets us apart from anything else going on on the planet.
Now, I've got a couple of listener questions for you, just to finish off, but could I ask before we get to those, if you could sum up in just a few sentences, what is going on at Skinwalker Ranch? How might that sound?
Well, in summary, Skinwalker Ranch continues to be the most scientifically studied paranormal hotspot on the planet. This 512 acre piece of property is part of an active ongoing scientific investigation that continues 24-7, 365 days a year. We have engaged experts, everyone from an on-site credentialed anthropologist full-time to physicists with credentials and expertise that bring a level of focus and scientific rigor that is unparalleled to this investigation and to these topics. And we look forward to answering many of these questions that have been posed for thousands of years relative to the nature of our existence and the nature of our world, hopefully, on this property. It is quite literally a living laboratory in service to studying the phenomena.
Now, I got a lot of questions sent in for you, of which many I'll have to keep for another time, Brandon, but I've got a few just to put to you. Stephen wanted to know, would you be doing another live feed like you've done previously with the webcams directly onto the ranch?
Yeah, good question. We in partnership with Newsweek, or no, it wasn't Newsweek, it was in partnership with Reddit this last year, had a live stream. I think it was a 24-hour live stream where the public really saw through many of our surveillance cameras what we were monitoring on the ranch and were given a sneak peek at really the day-to-day activity on the property. I'm not sure if that is set up, if that has been coordinated for this coming week with the team, these things take a level of coordination in order to live stream and really in order to access our proprietary systems. We've established a scientific platform there on-site in the command center that is unique and opening that up for a live stream and for public access or at least viewing is something that requires a little bit of coordination. I am more than willing to do so again, and if not this coming week, we look forward to having that be a part of future engagement with the public. So we're looking into it, but I'm not sure whether we're doing that in connection with season two launch as of yet.
David Lorimer asked, has the team and their investigations detected any powerful radio frequencies or X band radar emissions whilst at the ranch?
Yes, all the time. But it's transient, it's unpredictable, and it moves to different positions on the property. Even though we see repeated occurrences, and we've been collecting data on those events, on a regular basis, it is completely unpredictable and transient. Stay tuned.
Interesting answer. This next question, I had to read four or five times and get my co-hosts opinion on it because it's really different, but I thought I'd put this to you, so rather be squidding, asked, Skinwalker Ranch sits on the Phosphoria formation, which is uranium-bearing phosphate rock. Phosphorus is the most rare essential element of life, and our unsustainable use of it may be quite interesting to an observing intelligence. Has Brandon ever considered a connection to this rock or the mining of it that goes on near the ranch?
Yes, we have actually been studying the geology of not only the property but the surrounding area. Again, I believed when I acquired the property that there was a natural prosaic explanation associated with the phenomena that had been reported. I believed that there was a likely tie and connection to seismic activity and the geology that would explain a lot of the unique events that had been reported for so long. Interestingly, we have not been able to ascribe any natural cause to many of the events and many of the incidents of high strangeness that have occurred. So we'll continue to study it, but even though we're aware of the geology, the geology does not seem to be playing a role yet with respect to the phenomena, or at least explaining, providing explanation.
Barry asks, are there any specific times of year that you have noticed more or less activity, any patterns that match previous studies done by Ville or Keele?
We actually study the historical data, the historical narrative relative to the property. We've been collaborating with Mr. Bigelow's former team members and scientists in service to better understanding the framework associated with the ranch and the history and what has transpired in the past and whether there are correlations or new insights that can be gleaned by virtue of our investigation, looking back on what they had observed. But a lot of what we are doing is really brand new. It's opening a new chapter and conducting a completely new and elevated level of investigation relative to the property.
To finish up, Brandon, to show you the reach of the program, my five-year-old son had a question, and this is from Charlie. He wants to know, is there a spaceship under the ranch?
Well, Charlie, I'm going to find out. That's a good question. There's definitely something going on both above and below the property, and that's one explanation for why we continue to see strange things happen on the property. But stay tuned. That's something that we are definitely investigating and exploring, and it may be an explanation, it may be an answer. Good question.
He saw me watching one of the episodes last year where Travis Taylor was doing the ground penetrating radar and drew the shape, and the first thing he said at four years old at the time was, that looks like a spaceship. So I asked him today and he brought that back up.
Yep, that's a good question, and it's something that we're studying and that we'll be actually delving into in season two.
Any final words for the listeners and viewers, Brandon?
Yeah, I just want to thank everyone for following our journey. I mean, this is a new experience for all of us. Again, none of us, with the exception of Dr. Taylor, had ever been on television, had any experience with being filmed. We really appreciate everyone following our journey and being interested in these same topics. We were excited to reveal what we have been discovering, what we have been observing, and we think that this is really important. It's exciting, and we appreciate everyone's interest and also patience, because we're right there with you in wanting to get answers, and wanting to understand what is at work. I just want to thank everyone for being so kind, being interested, and really being positive in their voice, in following our journey. And we look forward to having you along for the ride, and opening the gates, both figuratively and literally, to allow you an unprecedented view of our investigation. Get ready for a lot more to come. We're just getting warmed up.
Welcome back to That UFO Podcast. I've been very lucky in the time doing the podcast to speak to many of the cast and stars scientists of the Skinwalker Ranch show. It's The Secret of Skinwalker Ranch or Curse of Skinwalker Ranch, depending on the US or UK. I've spoken to Thomas Winterton, Brian Arnold, and Brandon Fugal. I am delighted to be joined by a gentleman with a 20-year career supporting NASA, the US Army Space and Missile Defense Command, a published author, among many, many other academic achievements, and one of the stars of numerous documentaries, most notably, of course, History Channels, The Secret of Skinwalker Ranch. Travis Taylor joins me on the podcast. Travis, how are you?
I'm doing all right. How are you?
I'm very well. Very glad to be speaking to yourself. Finally, three years into the Skinwalker Ranch show. Like I say, it's been three years for you now. What's that journey been like for you from then to now?
Well, so from then to now is really interesting because when I first went out there more than three years ago now, I really thought I was going to get there and find that there were some folks up to some shenanigans. And I was going to like Scooby-Doo the thing and find Old Man Withers was causing all the problems. But then within just a matter of minutes from my first time being there, weird stuff started happening that I couldn't explain. And I never have yet found Old Man Withers who is causing the problem, right? It is something that's bizarre and real. And my current understanding of it is not a lot better than it was before I went out there. Except that I know now that it is some sort of real phenomena or maybe multiple phenomena occurring that needs a lot more investigation.
How much did you know already about the ranch before you went on, you set foot on it?
Well, you know, I'd heard it, heard about it on like coast to coast. And other things, and before I went out there, I got Colm Kelleher's book and read through it in great detail. And I spoke with George Napsum and I thought it was all ghost stories, right? It sounds like stuff you would tell around a campfire to scare the younger kids. But then when you get out there and you realize, while their experience may have sounded different from the stories, my experience isn't a lot less confusing and perplexing.
Now, you joined the ranch team when they had already been there for around three years prior. 2016, their investigation started under the stewardship of Brandon Fugal. What was it like getting involved with Thomas, Dragon, Eric and Cole, who had already been there working together, joining the team a few years into their work as a skeptic?
Yeah, at first, they weren't sure what to think about me coming in and looking at what they had done and sort of telling them that I wasn't a big believer, you know, and they just kind of all smirked and said, just give it time, and you will be. And that's kind of where it ended up. But we got along very good, really quickly, and started digging into the investigation, and they all accepted me as part of the team. And since then, we've really kind of been in the same foxhole together for the last three years or so.
In those first seasons, we are introduced to the ranch, the history of the ranch, the team, and we start to see those initial scientific investigations. Now, several years down the line, the technology has improved. What are the challenges that you face individually and as a group to keep progressing those investigations?
Yeah, the biggest thing is, while we do our best to try and stimulate something to happen, everything seems sort of random, serendipitous happenstance. And we'll try one thing that works one day and try it again another day, and something different will happen. So, it's real hard to be repeatable from a scientific standpoint. We have sort of reached, or we are reaching, some of the limits of some of the lower-cost technologies that we've been using, and we really are at a point where we've got to kind of step up the game and go to some more expensive, more complex systems. And I think we also have to be more aggressive in the investigation. How are we going to find out what's underneath the mesa if we don't dig into the mesa? We're pretty much exhausted, ground-penetrating radar and seismophones and everything else.
Is that a big frustration for yourself? Because we've seen several episodes titled, Bad Things Happen When You Dig. We've heard of the injuries Thomas Winterton received and others when digging has happened on the ranch. Do you have that scientific drive that, let's just dig, let's just see what happens, let's poke the hornet's nest?
Yeah, well, that's the first thing I told the guys the first day I met them. If they're telling me that things happen when you dig, so don't dig, that's a big blinking, flashing light, neon sign that says, well, we need to dig. And we need to dig a lot to see if we can measure the phenomena that's going on. It's really weird that anytime we've done any significant digging with a bulldozer or a backhoe or even drilling, for some reason we have a lot of technical malfunctions and issues with the equipment. A big thing is the batteries get zapped almost instantly. We had a bulldozer out there one day and we had to change the batteries on it like three or four times. And that's one of the things we've seen with trucks, with tractors, with everything. But now you think about it, this is a farm, right? It's a ranch and they had to dig post holes, they had to dig pipelines to run their plumbing. So digging happens. The question is, why are you digging and is there really an effect because you have an intent to dig, to find something as opposed to just infrastructure building?
In the three seasons that we've seen so far, there's been a lot of experiments shown on camera. What are some of your favorite experiments we've done so far and are there any that we've not seen on camera that you would like to talk about?
Well, there's some that are still coming up that I don't want to spoil for anybody, but they were really last summer, our investigation. We went all out and you'll see that some of the experiments we did were exciting. They had a lot of equipment, they were highly complex and they had some amazing results. But as far as my favorite experiment goes, any time that we were up in the helicopter making measurements in the anomaly over the triangle, because the results that we got from that is just beyond fascinating. And of course the one where we had the thermal cameras observing Homestead 2 when the rabbi did his ceremony to open up a portal to heaven and we saw the temperature vortex appear inside the Homestead doorway. So I, you know, but every every bit of it has been exciting and fascinating.
I listened to your interview with George Knapp on mystery wire just recently. And you talked about the time, I believe in season one, you'd opened up one of the manholes essentially and got the symptoms of radiation poisoning. Was it, did you find out exactly what it was? Was it radiation poisoning or was it an illness similar to radiation poisoning?
So all the symptoms, according to two different doctors that I saw and myself, you know, looking at everything I'd read about it is I had all of the symptoms of radiation sickness. And it was when we were behind Homestead 2 opening up the cistern in the back there. And, you know, my gamma ray detector went off and people standing right next to me, theirs didn't, so I don't know how that's possible. And, you know, we had a team come in the next day to scour the entire ranch for radiation sources, and nobody found anything with high-tech equipment that they used for the Navy. And so we can't explain what happened. But what we can't explain is that something hit me. It set off my Geiger counter, my personal dosimeter. And then I had burn marks. I had all of the other symptoms of dark, discolored urine, flu-like symptoms. All of these things that are very indicative of radiation sickness that lasted for several days to a week, depending on which symptom we're talking. So I can't explain it. Don't know what it was, but I do have one specific doctor that has treated special operations guys who have been exposed during returning down satellites or things like that, or working in a nuclear vessel. He said my symptoms were almost just like what he usually sees with them. So I can't explain it. I don't know.
We've heard recently more so from, you mentioned Colm Kelleher and his book with James Lakatsky and George Knapp about the Skinwalker Ranch, OSAP, what went on several years before Brandon Fugal took over, that other people have had exposure to the phenomena that has resulted in illness. Did anything like that ever cross your mind or did you have any conversations with people like Colm to do with that?
We've talked with them through either the phone or in person or on like Zoom calls or something. In fact, I talked with Eric Davis on day four yesterday about some things. It seems to me that they had sort of different phenomenologies occur and different illnesses. They never were exposed to radiation that Eric seemed to think and that's Eric Davis. But I will tell you this, Colm Kelleher told us from the very start that he wasn't going back out there. And it was better us being there than him sort of thing. Now, I also have heard from some other folks from the NIDS and BAS team that we seem to have generated some activity. We have poked the Hornet's Nest because we seem to be seeing a lot more activity than what they saw. But they did see stuff and they were more passive than we've been. And that might be part of it.
It seemed quite uncomfortable and quite scary for you when you started feeling those initial symptoms on camera. And obviously, on camera, it lasts a few seconds. But like you say, for you, it was days of not feeling well. Was there ever any moments throughout your time on the ranch where you've thought, this is enough, I need to get away from here and probably not go back?
Oh, that had crossed my mind a few times over the few years. And we all have things that there's this phenomena that we've noticed that the longer you're exposed to the ranch, that you seem to become more likely to be irritable and more likely to be exhausted mentally and emotionally. And there are days when you feel like you just got to get away from the place and go in. And we don't know exactly why that is. I think it has something to do possibly with the microwaves we keep detecting out there affecting our sleep patterns. But I haven't proven that yet, but that is my working hypothesis. But I remember one morning in Season 2 where I got up and walked over to the guys and said it was all I could do just to not get in my car and drive to the airport and go home this morning. I mean, that happens. But we fight through it and we keep going. Because there is something going on there that we just got to get to the bottom of.
And you have got an incredibly impressive CV between your academic achievements and your working life. What do your colleagues say in those different backgrounds that know you work at the ranch and you investigate at the ranch? What are their opinions on it?
At first, they thought I was nuts and that I would completely discredit myself for future work. But now that they have seen the exhaustive, in fact, I had a colleague who actually told me that I was nuts for going out there, doing what I do before I went. He told me actually yesterday that he was extremely impressed by the exhaustive amount of scientific rigor that we put into the effort. And it's kind of helping change opinion, I think, in the culture. And I think shows like Skinwalker Ranch, Ancient Aliens, those types of shows are actually convincing the academic community that, hey, this is something that we need to look into. There's no such thing as fringe in the scientific method. If it's an unknown, you're supposed to, as a scientist, investigate it with the scientific method. And I think also with all the UAP stuff coming out from the Pentagon is really making people realize, hey, there's a possible whole field of science here that we have not been looking at for a long time seriously and it's time to get serious.
You mentioned the UAP Task Force report from the Pentagon was one thing that they released. Recently, you were hired by Radiance Technologies, which is a firm taking on classified work for the DoD. One of your colleagues is a certain John J. Stratton, who was former head of the UAP Task Force for the Pentagon. I'm just wondering if your paths cross. Do you have conversations about Skinwalker Ranch and given his background, what may or may not be going on now?
I talk with Jay every day. Jay is a good friend of mine. I've known him for several years. We've passed sort of war stories, as you'd say. In fact, his office and my office actually share a wall. I mean, we work on... I was in a meeting with him this morning. And so we talk about these things all the time. You know, he tells me some of the things that happened when the previous work was done out there. And he's also extremely impressed with the fact that, you know, the technology is so much cheaper and more available for us than it was for Bigelow's team. So we have an opportunity to do a lot more now at Skinwalker Ranch than Bigelow's team ever did, simply due to cost and availability. And, you know, what effect it had with, you know, or what it stimulated for that era, though, I think was, it was a hotspot for activity that made people take serious enough that they would start a program and start go investigating these phenomena. And I think it's going to continue.
Brandon said himself on several occasions, Brandon seems a man you have to take at face value and take his word that he didn't receive any documents from Brandon Fugal, from Robert Bigelow, sorry, when they took over ownership of the ranch. There was no exchange of information. Is that something you think would have helped or hindered your own investigations having that information?
Well, I have mixed feelings about it. Had they given us the information, at least we might not have reinvented the wheel on some of the experiments they did. But they mostly observed and the data they got, why they won't release it to us, I don't understand all of the details of that. It may be that Bigelow still thinks some of it is proprietary to him or the government owes him something for it or what, I don't know. But anytime you start on a scientific project, that's part of the scientific method. Actually, the first step of the scientific method is to do your homework and read all the papers that's ever been written about the topic. So doing that, it would have been nice to have had the previous experiments and data that was gathered from the Bigelow work. But I've never been able to see any of that. It's never been released to any of us. So we're basically starting over and I think we've done all right.
I would say I've done more than okay. The science on the ranch has been very interesting and it does translate well to a TV show because that can be a difficult thing to show, scientific experiments on TV given the nature of what you're doing. If you were put in charge of the ranch for a month and History Channel gave you a sizable budget, what are some of the first things you would do? You've mentioned digging, but what else would you do to really move forward those investigations yourself?
Oh, wow. So if I had a ginormous budget, so to speak, yeah, I would pay for some infrared satellite imagery and detailed space imagery done of the area. I would also probably set up an entire grid on every, like one every square meter of the ranch, have a set of sensors that would be seismometry, microwave, magnetic, gamma rays, across the board, you name it, and have all that come into a major server system in the command center that we could continually run with artificial intelligence and machine learning, looking through it for any types of anomalous data, as well as I would have an array of cameras and radio telescopes and radar, constantly sweeping the sky above it. But all of that stuff is expensive, and the biggest thing, even if you had the equipment, you gather so much data, it would take expensive computer systems and people running them to go through all the data. That's the problem that the search for extraterrestrial intelligence has had for a long time. They've gathered so much data, they can't go through all of it. That's one of the things that we started live feeds on our website, skinwalkerranch.com, so that people can go there and actually look. If they see something, they can tell us, hey, we saw something at such and such time, and we'll go back and look for it and gather the data. That's what I would do, is just add a lot more sensors and a lot more capabilities.
Interesting. On a recent interview again with George Knapp, you mentioned that you had never seen a UFO until you got to Skinwalker Ranch. Now, you've seen more than you can count. What's been the most incredible of all your sightings and experiences involving UFOs?
Yes, I'm not sure which episodes have aired in the UK this year so far.
No Season 3 yet, just Season 1 and 2. We've not got Season 3 yet.
Well, you haven't got Season 3 yet. Oh, well, then I'm not going to spoil it for you. But the most exciting one that I've seen occurred in Season 3. And I think it's around Episode 4 or 5. I forget which one. And you'll see it's just an amazing event that takes place. But in the previous season, in Season 2, when I actually was at home and I was looking at my phone, I was actually going to show my son the mesa through the cameras that I can access through my phone. And I told him, I said, well, let's look here. And it looked like it was lightning on the mesa and raining. And I called Eric who was there and he was there. It was a Saturday. And I said, Eric, go out and look at the mesa. It's lightning just struck right where we launched the rockets from. And he went, it's not raining here. There's no lightning. What are you talking about? So when I got back to the ranch on Monday morning, we went and looked at that time, exact time that I had called him. And we found in multiple cameras looking in the direction of the mesa, a UFO that flew in and did some maneuvers and took off at like a couple thousand miles per hour. And we'd have never looked there had not been some weird phenomena affecting my phone and the server. We never found the video that I saw through my phone where it looked like there was a storm on the mesa. That is really bizarre, really weird, but it was amazing.
The ranch is probably the highest profile spot on earth for this type of activity and all the different types of activity we hear about through the OSAP program, Bigelow, Colm Kelleher, George Knapp and others and now yourselves. People must reach out to you from other places around the world and say, I live here or I'm in a location where other sorts of phenomena happen. Is there anywhere else if there was a Christmas special of the show and you were told you could head out on location that you yourself would want to go with a camera crew and maybe some equipment?
Oh, absolutely. There's several places. Like Dulce, New Mexico, there's a spot up in upstate New York. There's a place out in Arizona. There's a place in Spain that seems to be a really big hotspot. I forget the city there, but we actually spoke to one of the scientists that's working there and they are seeing some of the same things that we're seeing. So there are spots all around the world. I think there's one in Italy. Maybe there in the UK somewhere, like around Stonehenge or some of the places like that. People see things all the time. And it would be really interesting to take some of our equipment and see if we get similar measurements as we've gotten at Skinwalker.
What's your biggest regret so far in the three years of your time in the ranch?
Wow, biggest regret. Well, there have been several instances where something has occurred. And we only had like one instrument or one camera that was there. And it would fail for whatever reason. And we didn't have enough equipment there to have captured it. And it would have been, it was amazing things. And we kind of have this kind of saying that if we didn't capture it on the sensors and on the cameras, it didn't happen, right? Because nobody's gonna, it's just a ghost story at that point. And we've had a few of those. I really, the night that we were cooking out by my trailer and there was something watching us, and then we ended up chasing it through the weeds and up the mason, it vanished. The fact that we could see us chasing around on the ranch and the security cameras, but never got an image of whatever this thing was. I really regret that. I wish we could have gotten a picture of whatever this thing was.
And I have to ask, to be fair, what has been your biggest success?
Well, I would say our biggest success, well, and you'll see more big successes in season 3, but our biggest success has been the fact that we've caught multiple UAP, UFOs maybe, on multiple cameras and sensors at one time with scientific data to back it up so that we can do analysis and kind of figure out what this thing is. And I think identifying that there's an anomaly above the ranch at about a mile high is really significant because the Bigelow team never even bothered to look upward. They only looked really on the surface and around, and we have been kind of digging down and digging up, so to speak.
Recently you attended the UFO Symposium and there were videos released to the public showing some of them were previous videos we had seen. One was a newer video and we got to hear some analysis. It's been relatively controversial analysis in what the video may or may not show. What do you want to say to the public in terms of releasing footage? Is it something from a scientific point of view that really needs time and study and extra data? Or should people be able to just look at a piece of footage and take it at face value that it may be something anomalous but we don't know?
A little bit of both. You can't really look at a video by itself without doing very detailed analysis about every single frame in the video before you can say there's really an anomalous thing here. And you also can't throw out pieces of the video like the audio from the pilots, like the location of the thing, like any other information that comes along with it. You can't throw that out. And there are a lot of people that just ignore the audio from the pilots. They say, well, they're just pilots. They don't know what they're seeing. And I think, well, we're paying these guys to set behind a high-tech piece of war equipment. And they got their finger on the trigger. And each time they pull the trigger, they're making a diplomacy policy statement for whatever country they're doing that for. And if we don't trust them to look at something and realize it's not a bird or a balloon or an airplane, then we got problems in that case. So you can't throw out the testimony. But at the same time, you do need to have some healthy skepticism. But let me tell you, there's a difference in scientific skepticism and skepticism with a pre-planned agenda. I mean, if you start from the beginning saying the result of this is a bird or it's a weather balloon, then you're going to taint your analysis. In the same way, you also can't say, I'm sure this is a UFO and it's going to taint your analysis to get there. You've got to look at it and say, I don't know what this is. I'm going to do analysis and see what it tells me what it is. And that's what you've got to do in this kind of situation. I'll tell you this, the one video of the three things the helicopter saw was very intriguing to me. And with the pilots saying they thought they were moving as fast as F-16s really suggests that it wasn't birds that wasn't some really mundane explanation.
Yeah, I'm no expert, but the one thing I said was, I'm sure the pilots can identify a bird in the sky as opposed to what may be a piece of technology. So I'll let the experts deal with the analytics. But for me, that's I'll reserve my judgment on that one still. Just before we get to some listener questions, Travis, I want to ask, if someone said tomorrow that it's the final episode of Skinwalker Ranch, we're packing up, you've got one last talking head moment to sum up your time on the show, but also your best theory as to what's happening, what would that sound like?
Oh, well, certainly I hope that's not going to happen because there's so many questions to be answered there. But I would say thanks for the amazing opportunity to be out there and see something that really has changed the way I look at the universe and the world and life in general. But I would also say that I haven't got an idea of what could be causing that strange phenomena or multiple phenomena or is it just one thing? I don't know if they're all from the same source. I would say if I were to speculate, I could come up with all sorts of science fiction and fantasy answers that would range from a crashed alien spacecraft going haywire to some portal into a connected universe. You could come up with all sorts of science fiction scenarios, but I would say that we just don't have enough data to tell you which one of those science fiction scenarios is more likely than the other.
To be fair, I will say you did lead me along in one of the episodes where you drew what looked like a spacecraft when it was the sonar readings of under the ground, and it had the shape. I don't know if that was you allowing your brain to just lead you a little bit, but it certainly looked like a craft that you sketched on the outlines.
I was just mapping the hotspots on the return of the ground penetrating radar, and it did turn out sort of football shape. That's American football, not soccer. But it was odd, and we've gone back and dug down through there, and drilled again, and I'm not sure that we found any evidence that it's anything more than a strange layer of more dense material. Now, that part being said, wait till you see what we pull out of the ground in season 3.
Well, on that note, we've got plenty of listener questions for you to cover some more ground. Half the listeners that listen to the podcast are based in the US., so many of them are, I believe, four episodes in as of this evening when this one goes out. The first question from Tim says, Travis, I'm a big fan. Have you any theories you can share, unless it conflicts with the show's wishes until it finishes airing, as to the origin of the 1.6 GHz frequencies? I've read all sorts of bits about it being possible, US. Air Force and GPS, but I'm open to any of it.
Yeah, no, it's not GPS. GPS is at 1.575 and several other decimal places, and it would have to have a significant Doppler blue shift for it to be at the 1.61-ish that we're measuring. I have some ideas about if it actually means anything for the frequency it's at, but that's to come. We haven't found the source. We've triangulated with multiple systems and never been able to find where it's coming from. It seems to be coming from everywhere. The 1.6 gigahertz is bizarre and fascinating, and we have seen it actually move around the central 1.6 gigahertz in a way that looks like it might be being modulated in a way to send information. We don't know what that is. I haven't been able to decode it or anything yet, and it's not a standard encryption or a waveform encoding that we normally use. So I don't know what it could be. It is important because it seems to happen a lot of times when we have phenomena occur. Could it be something that somebody is hiding behind a tree and eavesdropping on us with a thing? I doubt it, but until we look behind every tree, I can't 100% guarantee that.
A little bit of a follow up on that one is from Paul Markham. Paul asks, is there any chance the 1.6 gigahertz signal and voice echoing back to you in a recent episode could be caused by you tapping into a government or private satellite surveillance system?
A lot of people have asked that question. Actually, they thought maybe we were hitting the iridium satellites or something like that. I've looked into that. It would take a lot more gain than anything we're producing. If somebody were looking at us with a satellite, and they were illuminating us with this, they would be illuminating a large spot of the Uinta Basin as well. It doesn't really fit the math and orbital mechanics for it to be a satellite. Possibly could be an airplane or something, but we'd see the airplane. We're constantly looking at the skies, and we've got radar systems, the ADS-B and all that looking at air traffic. So I don't know. We're not sure what this 1.6 gigahertz phenomena is. It could still be a man-made solution, but it seems to be happening in such a strange way that we can't seem to find the source.
Our next question is from Adam. He says, Hi, Travis, do you feel you and the team are being toyed with by whatever it is, or are you starting to understand or develop understanding of trends and characteristics, or maybe a baseline of data you can understand?
So sometimes it seems like there's a trickster god playing with us like Loki is standing behind the curtain, manipulating things, and being very random and purposefully random. But we haven't been able to figure that part of it out. I will say that the more data we gather, we do feel like that we know that these kinds of things happen, but we can never say this is going to happen when we do this. Because a lot of times we'll do something, we'll get a response, we'll do the same thing, we'll get a completely different response. So, yeah, I would say we have more data, is all we can say, we're not much better at understanding what's causing it.
Question from Walker. He asks, just wanted to establish, if Travis is convinced this could be non-human, did you ever experience any ontological shock after that realization? As a scientist, I assume Travis is fact-driven, just wondering how he relies on his intuition, and if so, have those intuitive impulses increased or strengthened since working on the ranch?
I have hunches that I think are a lot of times, they come to me after I've actually been asleep because I think my brain is processing all the data that I've seen the day before. But I really don't follow like an intuition or something. Sometimes I will take a shot in the dark because I'm at a loss for what's happening. But my belief system or my approach to solving problems hasn't really changed. I still go at it with the scientific method and with logic. But sometimes I will try a hair brain hypothesis or something that other folks might say is crazy or fringe or something just to see if a stimulus occurs. Because we really honestly don't know what's going on and we're just gathering more data.
Question from Gary. Does Dr. Taylor have any thoughts on why the carcasses of mutilated cattle are left on the ranch and not removed by the perpetrators, who or whatever they might be?
No, that's a really good question. And that's kind of the trend with most cattle mutilation phenomena, is that for some reason they take a few things from the cow, but leave the rest of the cow, and I can't explain what that's about. I will tell you, I've seen several, I've flown around and seen some right after it's occurred, and there's never any blood, and there's always stuff missing, and the cow seems to not be attacked by the predators and the carnivores and even the microbiology that seems to, and the insects that seem to eat away at carcasses doesn't affect these things. Now, I will tell you, I have seen where a friend of mine had a cattle ranch and they had some get struck by lightning and that the predators and carnivores wouldn't eat those cows either that were killed by lightning. So it makes me wonder if there's an electromagnetic phenomena that's part of this, and as much magnetic and electromagnetic stuff you see out there, it wouldn't surprise me.
That's interesting. Kimberly asks, and Kimberly's been a long time listener to the podcast, so hi, Kimberly, if you get a chance, can you ask Travis, what event has been the most mind-blowing moment for him at the ranch?
Oh, wow. Well, the most mind-blowing actually would be a spoiler for anybody in the UK, so I would hate to do that to you, but it's one where something happened to Eric and I sort of simultaneously, and we were in different locations and we both came to each other to tell each other the story, and our stories were the same, which led us to a discovery. The other one is, I have no idea how I was exposed to radiation. There's no, there's no, there's nothing there. I mean, something hit me with a beam of gamma rays, and there were people within 10 feet from me that didn't get hit by the gamma rays, and that's not typically how gamma rays work. So that is baffling and mind-blowing to me and I can't explain it.
Next question from Melanie, and I suppose this is one for myself who is not a scientist, obviously. Melanie wonders, how do you call what you're doing at the ranch science? When there are no controls or repeatable experiments with the same or different results? And also, do you know if the Insider application will have the actual data that's being collected?
Ah, well, so I'll go backwards with that one. The Insider thing, we are showing some of the data, we actually are showing some feeds live, real time. And as I get time, I know Eric is already doing this, he's going through stuff and talking about experiments with folks on there. I plan to actually give some presentations of some of the data and some of my analyses, but it's just a matter of having time to do it. Then the other part is, how do we call it science? Well, so we are repeating our experimental processes. Just because we don't get the same results doesn't mean it's not science, it means that either our hypothesis was wrong or our experimental apparatus wasn't necessarily the right experimental apparatus. Sooner or later, we'll find something that's repeatable, verifiable, or falsifiable. And that's one of the things I really harp on, is that you have to come up with hypotheses that you can verify or falsify. And you don't have big hypotheses like you asked me earlier, what is it? Well, I can't just say, well, it's aliens causing this, because you can't verify that. What experiment could you do that you could prove that it was aliens doing it, unless you found an alien or an alien came to you that you couldn't? But what you can say is, okay, well, data suggests that when weird phenomena occur across multiple types of phenomena, that we measure microwave signals or gamma rays or weird sounds. So we can put out instruments to see if this occurs. And we have found that is repeatable, probably 80 to 90% of the time when phenomena occurs, we measure this 1.6 gigahertz microwave system. So we are actually doing science and finding repeatable results. So we're doing small steps though. And we're not, I think we're a long way from that. It's a portal to another dimension thing.
Maybe season 4. Last couple of questions, Travis. In your George Knapp interview, you mentioned that blood pressure or ADD medication could affect people's ability to perceive anomalous activity on the ranch. Do you suspect that those people are more susceptible to having strange experiences, or do the medications potentially interfere with the ability to perceive?
Yeah, so it's the latter. So there are some studies that have recently been done by folks studying hallucinations and using hallucinogenic drugs and sensory deprivation tanks, as well as coma patients and so on. And it appears that the data is now beginning to show us that the hallucinations occur when there's less brain activity. And so maybe these are stimulus that are out there in the environment, but our hyperactive brains aren't detecting it because it's too big of a noise floor. And so when you are in a coma state, a meditative state or these drugs, they lower your brain activity and you will have these types of connections, hallucinations, whatever. And the ADD, blood pressure medicines and things like that, they actually may hype up your brain activity. And so they may actually act as sort of a buffer or a protection, like nicotine, caffeine, things like that, may actually prevent some people from seeing or experiencing these things.
Javacat asks, have you ever experienced or anyone close to you any hitchhiker activity since you started your investigations?
Yeah, we, everybody is real curious, but yes, the answer is yes. And in the risk of stimulating whatever, we don't know why it happens or what it is, but we don't talk about it a lot because we don't want it to get worse. There have been people who have had it so bad that it's really affected their family life and so on. But we all, except for Dragon, nothing happens to him. He's like our repellent. But all of us have had things like our car electronics going on and off, blowing out and coming back on, batteries being drained, strange, seeing weird things where there shouldn't be weird things and stuff like that. Keep in mind, I live in Alabama. That's a long way from Utah. And if I have these events happening to me, it means it's non-local. It means it's connected across space and time somehow.
And final question from Barry. On that Hitchhiker effect, what are your thoughts on the hypothesis that it can spread to other people like a contagion?
I've seen some data and heard anecdotal stories about that being true. I don't know that it is true 100 percent. Although, I have heard some significant stories and seen some instrument data from one of the particular subjects and his family that seems to be backing that up, that it could be possible. I know Gary Nolan, I think, has done some research in that. So you might look him up and read whatever he's done about it. But it's possible and I think the evidence is beginning to suggest to me that that is what's happening. So it kind of makes me think about it a little bit because I don't want it to happen in my family either.
Welcome back to That UFO Podcast, delighted to be joined again by Mr. Brandon Fugal, owner of Skinwalker Ranch. Brandon, welcome back to the podcast.
Hey, it's good to be with you. Thank you for welcoming me back and I look forward to answering any questions as we're heading into our third season of our docu-series and continue our historic scientific investigation.
Well, we've got a lot of listeners in the States where you are three episodes in to season three. I believe episode three airs this evening. It's the afternoon as we record this just now. Listeners in the UK have a little bit longer to wait unless they're watching it via other means, which in 2022 are of course available online. I've had a lot of different questions from listeners, Brandon, for you as well. I want to kick off by asking, how has the reception been to season three, especially now we are a few episodes in?
Very positive. I think it is important to note that our investigation continues 24-7, 365 days a year. Even when the production team is not present on the property, we have our full-time physicist and additional team members that are actively engaged with the ongoing investigation.
You're very engaged and active yourself on social media, which is massively appreciated by people like myself. And like you say, people forget, some people forget, you've got a lot of fans of the show and the events and experiences that happen on Skinwalker Ranch even before you took over the property. Is there still a frustration for you that some people see it just as a TV show? And they think that when the cameras stop, the events and the experiences stop as well?
Sure. There can be a source of frustration, but it's understandable. And so I appreciate the opportunity to clarify that the docu-series on History Channel only exists because there has been an ongoing scientific investigation under my ownership that commenced in April of 2016 and has continued unabated until present day. And so it's an exciting opportunity to be able to bring the public onto the property virtually, if you will, through the docu-series format. And I only wish that we had the opportunity to create something a little bit more engaging. But we're working on it. We have a lot of other resources and opportunities that we are unveiling and opening up to the general public. I mean, our web portal, which is www.skinwalkerranch.com, is live and offers an opportunity for the public to engage and to be able to review a lot of the ongoing details relative to our investigation when the cameras aren't necessarily rolling.
Well, I was going to ask about that a little bit down the line, but you've touched on it, so let's talk about the website. So it's a premium slash subscription-based site. What was the thinking behind that and what is it people can access?
Well, you know, there's a lot of content, in fact, an abundance of content that doesn't cost anything, that is there for the public to review and to be able to have access to. The team is really excited and wanted the opportunity to engage more with the public and to continue, I think, a little bit more active role and engagement that would come through this portal. And so it's a good compliment to the series, but the series has been very well received. I, you know, we are a hit. I think we're the number two show on the History Channel, on the network. And we're consistently in the top 10 in all cable television, I believe, as we air. So it really is an indication that we have a global audience and that people are very interested in these topics and our ongoing investigation.
Has there been a particular highlight for yourself from this season that you can talk about?
Gosh, you know, we started the season off with a bang, bringing out former Governor Gary Herbert from the state of Utah to have the longest serving governor in recent history actually show an active interest and want to come on the property and to engage with the team and to be able to draw from his existing resources in order to assist was a big moment. But I think even beyond that, we saw right off the bat, UFO activity captured on camera in broad daylight in conjunction with advanced rocketry experiments and a host of other activities that continue to stimulate activity with the phenomena on the property.
Is there anything that's happened this season that you weren't able to get into the show that you or the other ranch members were hoping to?
Sure. There's always a lot of activity that doesn't make it onto the series. I would say that 95 percent of what is filmed ends up on the cutting room floor, if you will. It's just a reality associated with trying to put together a properly edited and packaged summary of our activities. But I think it's important for people to realize also that none of this is fabricated, contrived, scripted. This is a completely unscripted actual record of events as they unfold with the team. I think that presents a unique opportunity for people to see behind the scenes how our scientific research has unfolded on this really unique piece of property.
I remember speaking to Thomas Winterton just after season 1 had finished, and people were talking about one of the experiments, how it looked as if it had been faked because the equipment wouldn't have worked the way it would have. But Thomas explained quite rightly that the piece of equipment was supposed to be placed inside of a tin can, to which he said, you can't fit a TV camera inside the tin can to show it. So we have to one, do the experiment with the tin can, but also we have to then show you the piece of equipment we're using. And if things like that, people don't realize that that are happening.
No, and we have several physicists there on site that are assisting with the scientific protocols, with trying to establish the proper approach as far as the experimental activity on the property. And I think it's a learning process. I mean, this is something that people are thankfully able to see unfold as we're learning and attempting to approach the challenge of documenting and interacting with the phenomena. This is not a straightforward linear path to discovery. It is very challenging. A lot of people ask us, well, if you have so many equipment failures and electromagnetic anomalies and malfunctions, how are you able to present and record the docu-series? And I think it would surprise everyone to know that we are constantly dealing with everything from drone malfunctions to battery failures, over and over to all sorts of equipment malfunction and even damage during the course of trying to document this. So it is not an easy process in order to capture what is taking place on the ranch.
Now, that engagement from the phenomenon, something you mentioned, and digging has always been a sensitive subject on the ranch. A whole show, I believe in Series 1, was called Bad Things Happen When You Dig. Has there been any discussion, and this is something that quite a lot of listeners asked me, Brandon, any discussion around a larger scale dig to get to the bottom of what could be underneath the ranch? Sure.
If you see some of the trailer or preview material for this upcoming season, you see that we take a very aggressive approach to probing the mesa and to actually digging and probing the property to really, I think, follow up on the experiments of the last several seasons and to be able to, I think, zero in on really what is happening.
Now that we're three seasons in, and obviously we still have half of season three at least to go, where do you see Skinwalker Ranch as a series heading? Do you see an end goal or an end game?
I don't really have an end game relative to the docu-series. Although I'm thankful for the opportunity for us to present our investigation on the History Channel and to engage with the public, it doesn't change the fact that this is an ongoing scientific investigation and will continue with or without a docu-series in the works. It is my hope that we'll be able to continue to reveal to the public the progression of events that are occurring even on a daily basis, even this past week on the property. There are things happening that we were continually surprised by.
Anything particular you could mention, because people will be pulling my head out if I don't ask.
Well, I think it's safe to say without prematurely revealing anything that increased UFO activity or unidentified aerial phenomena is something that we are continuing to document on the property with great frequency. We're also uncovering other mysteries that are, in essence, puzzle pieces. Puzzle pieces that we're putting together in order to understand what we are dealing with at Skinwalker Ranch. Many of the scientists that came before us qualified the activity on the ranch as being attributed to a precognitive, sentient, non-human intelligence. Even something or some things that have the ability to interact or have access to our consciousness.
Now, are there any other places around the Uinta Basin that you would like to get involved within the show? And I wonder, even not just yourself, but Travis Taylor, Thomas Winterton, Brian Arnold and the others?
Good question. You know, the activity is not necessarily bound to the fence line at Skinwalker Ranch on my 512 acre piece of property. But it is important to realize that the highest degree of frequency of sightings and other high strangeness for whatever reason, going back decades, appears to be focused on this property. And so as much as we take a broad view and look at the Uinta Basin with our research, a lot of our resources will continue to be focused right there on that 512 acres. Now, that being said, we see some common commonality with other sites globally. There are other areas that report unusual activity that we have been communicating with, or at least with those researchers involved with those sites. And we may have the opportunity in the future to interact with them as part of the ongoing effort.
If anyone from the network was listening, that might be a nice Christmas special episode, maybe getting those other researchers or spots involved. If they wanted to do that, I'm sure people would be interested.
Yeah. I mean, you could create a whole series just on the science of Skinwalker Ranch. The scientific platforms that have been established are really, to a large degree, proprietary. I have to give great credit to Eric Bard, our full-time physicist who has been living on site, by the way, since last August, September, without returning to his home that much. He's constantly and vigilantly monitoring all of the systems and reviewing everything from the footage to a lot of the other scientific readings that are being made on the property.
I'm sure Eric works very hard, but he does get a beautiful view of the mesa and a very cool command center to work out of, so I'm not going to be too sympathetic towards him. He's got some pretty cool toys to work with.
Well, but it's a dangerous place, and bad things happen to people, unfortunately, on this property. That is why we require that everyone sign a liability waiver, acknowledging the risks associated with entering Skinwalker Ranch. It's a known fact that a number of participants have ended up in the hospital with mysterious illnesses or injuries over the course of the last couple of years, and it's something that continues to concern me.
Well, you talk about that this past week, I had a Professor Gary Nolan on the podcast, who was talking with me about the hitchhiker effect. And he thought it was potentially not something that is necessarily negative, that he thinks it can be from someone opening up and being more susceptible to whatever this entity being or beings are that are looking to attach themselves. And I wonder Brandon, as the months and years have passed, your six years now of stewardship, how has your perception of this hitchhiker phenomenon changed?
Well, I have great respect for Dr. Nolan and his work. I mean, he's one of the finest scientists on the planet right now. And so to hear that he's reference to the hitchhiker effect and some of what we are dealing with or what attends the phenomena is interesting and something I respect. I think that we've seen both malevolent, negative and somewhat, I wouldn't call it positive, but at least some benign hitchhiker activity that has followed people home, that has been witnessed by family members. But unfortunately, I would say over half the time, it seems to be somewhat negative.
Do you think, and I wonder, is this a discussion that you or your colleagues have had, that what we interpret as humans as being a negative experience could potentially be something just trying to communicate in its own way?
Perhaps. I think that there may be entities that are simply trying to communicate with this. I believe we have evidence of that at Skinwalker Ranch. But I don't know that we're dealing with just one entity. I think we're dealing with a diversity of agendas and origins associated with the activity seen at Skinwalker Ranch.
Just thinking of fish inside of a fish tank, that if you tap the outside of it, you're not necessarily trying to scare them, but maybe get their attention. But what you do is inadvertently cause a reaction that does scare the fish. And I wonder sometimes, are these the effects that could be happening? But I've also spoken to people like Thomas Winterton and George Knapp, who George Knapp himself said he had an experience and actually went on to his wife as well, which he said was particularly terrifying and scary. So I can appreciate there's been some not very nice things happen to people who have visited the ranch. Sure.
Sure. I think there is a diversity of activity and experiences associated with those that have participated at Skinwalker Ranch. I mean, Thomas Winterton, our superintendent of six years, has unfortunately had very negative experiences, not only negative experiences on the ranch that we believe led to his hospitalization and almost threatened. I mean, these were life-threatening situations, but he's also had things that have gone beyond that, that I'll leave for him to decide whether he wants to discuss in the future.
If anyone wants to go back, it was one of the first interviews I done was with Thomas Winterton, and he does discuss in some detail things that followed him back to his home, potentially in some scary experiences with his car. So yeah, something definitely worth checking out. Thomas was very open. I want to ask you though, you mentioned it's been six years now, Brandon, since you've taken over the stewardship of the ranch. What's been your proudest moment in those six years?
I think my proudest moment has been seeing this team work together and really coalesce into a truly multidisciplinary collaborative effort to discover the nature of what we're dealing with and document it, to see these fine individuals that have come together and are faced with some very challenging circumstances and a task to try to get to the bottom of a mystery that has been going on for decades, if not millennia, and to see them actually executing on not only the experiments, but working together to to solve the mystery and to put the puzzle pieces together in a way that we haven't seen in any other instance that I'm aware of in the public domain. I find all of that very, very inspiring, and I'm most proud of that. I'm very proud of my team and their efforts and to see them all grow together and see this effort bring, I think, the most professional focus and scientific tools and investigation to what was previously a controversial topic or arena of topics is something that I'm quite proud of.
On that, just today, as we record this, it's the 17th of May, congressional UAP hearings took place within the Congress in the United States. Have you had a chance yet, Brandon, to catch up on what happened at those events?
Yeah, I've reviewed some of that and I'll reserve comment rather than to state that it's about time. I mean, it's about time that the public be awakened to the fact that this is real, that this is not the figment of people's imaginations, that our airspace is being violated, that some of our most skilled fighter pilots and military officers have witnessed phenomena and have been willing to step forward and vocalize their experiences. I think that's a big deal. I think that the facts speak for themselves. Anyone who does their due diligence regarding these topics, I mean, real due diligence, looking at witness testimony, excuse me, witness testimony and the documentary evidence associated with these topics, I think we'll find that there is very real legitimacy and validity to them. So it's good to see that Congress is taking it seriously. I think that we're just barely scratching the surface, and there is so much more to be revealed in the weeks and months to come.
Can you foresee a time where the ranch itself is brought up as a place of interest and hearings or settings like that?
Oh, absolutely. I mean, it's no secret that Skinwalker Ranch has been a living laboratory and was part of a Pentagon-funded black budget program for years. And for whatever reason is a hot spot for monitoring this type of activity.
Is there an open invitation to any of those congressmen or women with an interest in the UFO, UAP or phenomenon as a subject to come to the ranch and visit?
Well, we don't schedule tours. I mean, this isn't something that we're anxious to open up for the public. I mean, if I even granted 1% of the requests that I receive on a weekly basis from people and a lot of very qualified people that want to visit the property, meet with the team, I would be overwhelmed 24-7. We are conducting a very sensitive scientific investigation right now and there is liability associated with it. So I'll answer your question with the statement that we'd be happy to brief anyone in authority relative to the reality of our ongoing investigation and the data, the hard data underpinning our findings and our research and activity and look forward to being very transparent with the public and anyone who is interested.
That's a fair comment. To finish off, I'd like to get to some listener questions for you, Brandon. There was a lot of interest. So if you can get through a couple of these, that would be appreciated.
You bet.
First up is from BB. BB would like to know if you have any idea who or why is constantly surveilling the ranch, i.e. drones in the airspace, black helicopters flying around or anything like that.
Well, if you saw Episode 1 of this new season, you saw that we are most definitely being monitored by government entities, even above 45,000 feet conducting very sophisticated monitoring and surveillance of our property. I mean, and we've continued to document additional activity that has even taken place in the last few weeks that is undeniable, that is well documented. So we know that the ranch is an area of interest. We know that, for whatever reason, it has gone far beyond just the scope of our investigation, but has captured the attention of other entities. What they know that we don't know, that's a good question. It would be great to collaborate and to be able to know the exact nature of some of that surveillance that is taking place. But there's a big difference between that surveillance that is taking place and the bona fide, unidentified aerial phenomena that we are documenting and experiencing with third-party witnesses they're seeing before their very eyes. That's what is, I think, most compelling. We continually document, I think, some of the best evidence of unidentified aerial phenomena, correlated with electromagnetic anomalies and equipment malfunctions, and also third-party expert witnesses that are engaged with the team that are there and witnessing these things happening in real time.
Julie wants to know, has Dr. Avi Loeb ever visited the ranch, and would you be interested in working in any capacity on the Galileo project?
I had the privilege of meeting with Dr. Loeb several months ago. In fact, we spoke at the Museum of Science in Boston and discussed a collaborative effort. In fact, I offered to have a Galileo project installation at Skinwalker Ranch, and to closely collaborate and work together and to compare data in service to discovery.
That's good to know. Is that something that's on the horizon or just has been left out there tentatively?
It's on the horizon. But I think we're working through that process and hope to re-engage and continue the discussion here in the near future.
Excellent. Tree of Life says in the book Skinwalkers at the Pentagon, it is suggested that the Hitchhiker effect can jump from one person to another, so family members of someone who visited can have experiences outside of the ranch. Are there any theories on why it spreads and how many people it can spread to?
There are a lot of theories and there is a lot of data backing up the so-called Hitchhiker effect. One thing is for sure, there are a number of military operatives and former scientists and participants on the ranch that refused to ever set foot back on that property ever again. Even Mr. Bigelow refuses to ever set foot on this property again, and we've received a lot of feedback confirming that the Hitchhiker effect is real and that the impact that it has had on families, on family members associated with those who have visited the ranch and participated in the investigations, it's something to be taken very seriously.
Brandon has a question. Is the ranch a place that indigenous people went to in order to induce ontological shock as part of an initiation? And if so, why is there any reason to assume a nuts and bolts investigation will give any answers as the phenomenon there would not seem to be made from nuts and bolts?
Good question. We've identified areas of the property where there are pictographs or petroglyphs and megalithic structures that are ancient, that have been around for a very long time. The indigenous peoples, the Native Americans that inhabited the property, left traces of their habitation, and also the fact that they were making some record of not only potential star charts, but also, I think, signifying that this property, for whatever reason, was a place of significance. Being sensitive to that cultural history and bringing consultants on the property to help our team and our full-time anthropologist, Candice Lindy, better understand the historical context has been an important part of our investigation.
Ryan wants to know that when you saw the silver metallic craft or any UAP experience you've had, have you ever had any overwhelming sense of emotion that you've felt along with that experience?
I didn't personally. I was astonished by what I witnessed with other witnesses sitting right by my side when I had my own sighting in broad daylight and observed that craft or that object maneuvering in ways that just defy any conventional description. But I didn't feel any sense of dread. It was more that I was in awe. It just seemed unbelievable that we were witnessing it. And the whole episode happened over the course of about 20 seconds and was over. And I think it's difficult for people to understand sometimes that when you're caught off guard, even on Skinwalker Ranch, that has this history, I mean, it's something that you're never really prepared for. I think most people will attest to the fact that they're unprepared for what they witness on the property.
Two more questions, Mr. Fugal. This one from Mark. Is there any person or organization besides yourself sponsoring research at the ranch?
No. No. In fact, it's really all been sponsored and paid for by me since I acquired the property in April 2016. Along with, of course, the History Channel, helping to subsidize some of the experimental activity and personnel and expenses during the short period of time every year that they are working on production. So the History Channel engagement, while important and I think very helpful, this doesn't come close to covering the costs and expense associated with the ongoing scientific investigation that has now surpassed six years under my stewardship.
And final question from Gaz. Is there anywhere else in the world you would like to investigate and why? If you were looking at purchasing a new Skinwalker Ranch, is there anywhere you would have your eye on?
Sure. There are other areas of interest that I would like to have the team investigate simply because I believe pulling the data together and finding correlations can help us better understand potentially the nature of what we're dealing with, the origin, the agenda. I think there are some common signatures, if you will, that we find across the world in other locations. It would be interesting. But as of right now, I haven't found any place of interest that merits actually acquiring.